Ihr seid aber schon ganz schön früh am Start, alle.
Ich habe letztens bei Heise total bescheuert das gelesen.
Und zwar so eine Art Heizlüfter, der seine Abwärme durch Krypto-Mining bekommt.
Mir ist nicht ganz klar, wie man auf die Idee kommen kann, dass das eine gute Idee ist.
Beziehungsweise, ich meine jetzt nicht mal irgendwie umwelttechnisch, sondern dass es sich überhaupt in irgendeiner Art und Weise lohnt.
Ich meine, es ist die letzten Jahre über, vor allem auch noch Bitcoins.
Ich meine, es ist die letzten Jahre so schwer geworden, Bitcoins zu minen.
Du brauchst so spezialisierte Hardware mittlerweile, um so wenig rauszubekommen.
Das meiste ist natürlich immer Abwärme.
Dass man damit sagt, man heizt, okay, ist das ein...
Letztendlich würde es ein normaler Miner auch heizen.
Aber die Idee dahinter erschließt sich mir nicht.
Es ist doch vollkommen klar, dass das um ein Vielfaches teurer ist,
als das Ding zu betreiben, als das, was du an Heizkosten sparst.
Und so wenig, wie du aktuell noch verdienen kannst mit reinem Krypto-Mining, also Bitcoin-Mining,
die paar Cent werden es dann...
Also, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie man auf die Idee kommt, dass sich das in irgendeiner Art und Weise lohnen könnte.
Und witzigerweise, in dem Artikel kommt natürlich am Ende auch raus, dass sich das nicht lohnt.
Das war...
Als ich das Ding gesehen habe, habe ich mir schon gedacht, das kann sich doch nicht lohnen.
Das hat sich auch nicht.
Das hat sich doch nicht gelohnt.
Du musst das, glaube ich...
Dass sich das rechnet, musst du die Dinger, glaube ich, 40 Jahre durchlaufen lassen.
Und dann auch nur, wenn sich weder der Strompreis verändert, noch die...
Noch Bitcoin härter zu meinen wird und alles.
Das ist so unsinnig.
Also, Abwärme, wenn man eh Abwärme hat, ja...
Also, man hat ja Abwärme bei vielem, so als Abfallprodukt.
Wenn ihr euren Rechner betreibt, ein Spielspiel, habt ihr auch viel Abwärme.
Aber, Alter...
Nee, dass damit der Raum ein bisschen wärmer wird, ist ja okay.
Aber das als primäre Heizquelle einsetzen zu wollen, erscheint mir doch dann ein bisschen bescheuert.
Ausprobieren kann man es ja.
Aber man will ja nicht machen.
Es war immer das Normale.
Das, was wir gestern auch anhatten, das war schöne Fahrstuhlmusik.
Besser, besser als Fahrstuhl.
Hatte letzte Woche ein Praktikum an der Schule und bin direkt wieder krank geworden.
Ich würde allein schon krank werden, ganz ohne Bazillen,
wenn ich mich den ganzen Tag mit irgendwelchen Kindern auseinandersetze.
Die gehen einem nach 3 Sekunden schon EXTREM auf den Sack.
Also...
Das würde ich gar nicht so...
Das würde ich nicht mehr aushalten, bis ich Zeit hätte, krank zu werden.
Der Sbarro macht ja sowas auch freiwillig, was ich nicht verstehen kann.
Deswegen sehen wir den wahrscheinlich so selten hier in letzter Zeit.
Müsste ja mittlerweile auch mal fertig sein.
So.
Wir machen mal kurz OS-Updates.
Warum?
Weil Arch, by the way...
Wie?
Was ist das?
Keine Ahnung.
Das ist ja...
Das ist ja ein bissl wenig.
Nur 2 Package-Updates seit gestern Abend.
Ich mein...
Die hatten immerhin knapp 11 Stunden Zeit, neue Package-Updates ranzubringen hier.
Arch, da komm ich mir gar nicht mehr als richtiger Arch-User vor.
Wenn es nur 2 Package-Updates gibt.
Es müssen mindestens 80 sein.
Dass ich mich so richtig schön Pleading Edge, Arch by the way, fühle.
Tü-tü.
So.
Zack.
Und Aquarium.
Habe ich die Woche irgendwas verpasst, Chat?
War irgendwas Wichtiges?
Übliche Sicherheitsgeschichten oder so, die ich irgendwie verpasst habe?
Es war die letzte Woche, war irgendwas mit Cups.
Dann...
Microsoft hat Vesos abgeschafft.
Was war denn sonst noch?
Hast du schon mal Testing aktiviert?
Nee.
Du hast recht.
Wenn ich unbedingt mehr Updates haben möchte, ja, könnte ich das machen.
Ich hatte noch irgendeine Probleme.
Firefox hatte irgendwie, gab es so einen...
Irgendwas in der CSS-Engine, was Probleme macht.
Irgendwas mit Animationen, glaube ich, war das.
Das hatte man die Woche auch noch.
Mehr fällt mir gerade nicht ein, was Security-technisch diese Woche gewesen ist.
IODomains.
Ja, stimmt, du hast recht.
Dass die vielleicht verschwinden werden.
Wobei ich das nicht glaube, ehrlich gesagt.
Da gibt es garantiert eine Ausnahme.
Ja, das Archiv ist offline, das habe ich auch gelesen.
Und die wollen es auch erst mal offline lassen, bis sie sich besser vor DDoS-Angriffen geschützt haben,
bis sie ihre Architektur um...
Aber ich hoffe, das kommt wieder.
Ohne Scheiß, das Internet-Archiv, das ist eines der wichtigsten Seiten überhaupt für mich.
Gerade, seitdem es kein Google-Cache mehr gibt.
Das ist auch so ein Mist, der abgeschafft wurde.
Ich war ja ein großer Fan des Google-Caches.
Kennt noch jemand Google-Cache überhaupt?
Gibt es ja schon zwei Jahre oder so nicht mehr.
Du konntest früher, wenn du bei Google was gesucht hast...
Ja, du hast zum Beispiel...
Nein, natürlich hast du Wobblos gesucht.
Ja, du hast Max-FPS-Gesicht gesucht.
Und da konntest du dann hier hinklicken und hast gesagt, im Cache öffnen.
Und da hast du halt auch Seiten gefunden, die es nicht mehr gab.
Und das Beste war, ehrlich gesagt, dass die Seiten ohne JavaScript geladen wurden.
Und dementsprechend hattest du immer das Highlight von dem Text, das du gesucht hattest, auf der Seite.
Das war halt richtig nice.
Aber Google-Cache war anscheinend zu teuer und zu wenig haben sie es verwendet.
Deswegen hat sich Google gedacht, nope, weg damit.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Zu advancede Features kosten zu viel Geld bei Google.
Google hat zu wenig Geld, das geht nicht.
Ich habe was gelesen dazu, dass das wohl nicht sonderlich beeindruckend ausgesehen haben muss.
Also, ich habe einen Bericht gelesen zu dieser letzten...
Wie hieß das?
Von Tesla.
Die hat noch letztens so eine Presentation.
Da gab es noch einen Bus und ein Taxi zu sehen und irgendwelche Roboter.
Und nichts davon muss sonderlich beeindruckend ausgesehen haben.
Ja, nicht nur die Hände.
Da ist ja schon einiges geleakt.
Meine Beine wurden auch...
Ich wurde ja sogar mal komplett geleakt.
Aber...
Ich habe keine gecheckt.
Gestern einen leisten kann, der seinen eigenen Router, weil sein ESP ihm verbietet, einen anderen als Fritzbox zu benutzen.
Hä?
2020 habe ich meinen Optik...
Ich habe meinen Internet-Service-Provider gehackt.
Router.
Okay, ich predikte mal, was da rauskommt.
Der liest dort irgendwelche Zugangssachen aus, MAC-Adressen aus oder sonst was.
So, dass er einen anderen Router anschließen kann und der Internet-Provider das halt authentifiziert.
Weil es denkt, es ist der Originale.
Irgendwie so was wird es wahrscheinlich sein.
Aber können wir mal schauen.
Aber können wir...
Können wir uns angucken?
Warum nicht?
Mal schauen.
Kann ich gleich immer...
Bei solchen Videos bin ich ja immer im Meckermodus.
Aber es ist eigentlich total bescheuert, weil diese Videos richten sich ja nicht an Leute, die...
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich kenne das Video ja noch nicht.
Richten sich ja nicht an irgendwelche Netzwerkexperten oder so.
Was ich auch nicht bin.
Sondern an normale Leute.
Deswegen meckere ich da immer ein bisschen viel bei solchen Videos.
So.
Dann schauen wir doch mal.
Was auf Shithub so trendet weekly, würde ich sagen.
Python Algorithms trenden.
Das können die auch ohne mich.
DPI Bypass Multiplattform.
Ich habe absolut keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Was ist das?
DPI...
Also der meint mit DPI bestimmt nicht das, was ich mit DPI meine.
Bypass Multiplattform.
Ich meine damit...
Ja, Auflösung ist ja nicht richtig.
Ist ja nicht die Auflösung.
Das ist quasi die...
Ja doch.
In gewisser Weise ist es schon ein bisschen was wie die Auflösung.
Also quasi wie viel Pixel pro Fläche man hat.
Per Inch.
So.
Eigentlich sind es Dots.
Ja.
Die meinen damit bestimmt Dynamic.
Das D steht bestimmt für Dynamic oder sowas.
Was ist?
Wow.
Gekommnet am Start.
Okay, alles klar.
Jetzt wissen wir natürlich Bescheid.
Ja.
Mhm.
Dots Englisch.
Gibt es angeblich auch.
Read me Englisch.
Ja, das werde ich...
What is it for?
A standalone DPI...
Ja, was ist das denn?
Deep Package Inspection ist das, glaube ich.
Kann das sein?
Ja.
Ich glaube, das wollen die damit sagen.
Jetzt, wo ich das mit Firewall und so gelesen habe.
Meine Güte, ey.
Könnt ihr das nicht einfach mal ausschreiben?
Dann wüsste man auch gleich, was Sache ist.
AI Applications.
Ja, nee.
Wir bilden jetzt keine AI Applications.
Puh.
Ja.
Es war...
Ahh!
Wie script, wie immer.
AI.
Telegram, iOS.
Goodbye...
Schon wieder?
Ist das...
Wartet mal.
Ich muss mein Headset mal kurz fixen.
Habe ich irgendwas verpasst?
Warum trenden so viele...
Wir umgehen irgendwelche Firewall..
Geschichten..
Sachen..
Pفيipii!
Trendet.
OK.
Nice!
Fünfundz...
A-Fünfundzwanzigtausend Sterne.
Keine Ahnung, was das ist.
By Traders for Traders.
Ah, OK.
Crypto Pros am Start.
AI.
Ich habe eine Präsentation gesehen, dass der Vite-Erfinder und Vue.js-Erfinder, der hat jetzt ein eigenes Unternehmen gegründet und die machen jetzt eigene JavaScript-Tools.
Void irgendwas heißt das, Void Zero, genau. Evan Yu, der hat sein eigenes Startup aufgemacht, nachdem er jahrelang schon Open Source-technisch am Start ist.
Und ich meine, es ist nicht so, als wäre Vue oder gerade Vite irgendwelche kleinen Projekte, so ziemlich das gesamte JavaScript-Ökosystem basiert ja mittlerweile.
Gefühlt auf Vite. Ja, und ich habe eine Präsentation gesehen von dem. Der hat gesagt, das ist ihm alles zu umständlich, dass er da verschiedene Tools für Vite und so braucht.
Deswegen wird jetzt alles rewritten. Placingly fast. In Rust. Natürlich. Was sonst?
Es gibt einfach noch nicht genug JavaScript-Parser, Linter, Formatter. Da brauchen wir noch den 570. für.
Wobei ich halt sagen muss, wenn der das macht, der hat da eine gewisse Ausdauer.
Bei Projekten bewiesen, ja. Also, das könnte durchaus was taugen. In Zukunft vielleicht.
Zumindest, es ist natürlich Rust und natürlich dürfen keine Benchmarks fehlen, die zeigen, dass das Placingly fast ist.
VPN-Client. Für was? Amnesia VPN. Habe ich noch nie gehört. Auf was basiert das?
Sagt mir gar nichts. More than a VPN. Okay.
Sieht schon. Ich weiß nicht.
Die Webseite, finde ich, sieht schon irgendwie ein bisschen shady aus mit dem, aber vielleicht täuscht das auch einfach nur.
Im Moment ist es schon mal nice, dass es den ganzen Krempel für alle Plattformen gibt.
Okay. Für nicht mobiles Windows, aber wir benutzen auch mobiles Windows.
Oh, VPN. Aha.
Also, diese Woche ist die Trending-Sache ja wirklich massive langweilig.
Ist ja gar nichts dabei, was mich interessiert.
Normalerweise gibt es ja immer so ein, zwei Sachen, die ich aufmache und denke, oh, das könnte man sich mal angucken.
Aber da ist ja gar nichts dabei. Null. Was mich irgendwie juckt.
Okay. Today. Deno. Dino. Trended.
Schauen wir mal, was in .NET trendet. Wahrscheinlich wieder die üblichen Verdächtigen.
Und wahrscheinlich trendet Maui wieder, oder was ich bis heute nicht verstehe.
Bitworn-Server. Unitask. Unity. Okay.
Ja, 67 ist ja nichts.
ASP.NET Core.
Ich mag ASP.NET Core. Das ist mein Lieblings-Web-Framework.
Also, für serverseitig.
Die Eraser-Pages-Rendering-Sache verwendet.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das überhaupt jemand verwendet.
Moment. Ein Memory-Ein-Windows-Memory-Cleaner.
Ich sag ja, sowas ist immer Schwachsinn, aber wenn das Open Source auf GitHub ist und so viele Sterne hat, vielleicht ist das doch nicht Schwachsinn.
Bilibili-Tool Pro. Ist Bilibili nicht das China-Chinesen-YouTube?
Osu. Jawoll.
Endlich was für die Weebs hier am Start.
YouTube-Downloader.
Moment, da gibt's jetzt was. Da gibt's jetzt was Eigenes.
YouTube-DL-P ist out, oder was?
Memory-Cleaner.
What the fuck?
Das ist so ein typisches Tool, was ich mir nie im Leben installieren würde.
Was aber auch daran liegen mag, dass ich nicht weiß, was ich mit meinem ganzen RAM machen soll.
Guck mal, Leute.
Ich hab 64 GB RAM.
Weiß nicht, was ich damit machen soll.
Ich, ich, ich brauch nicht mal ansatzweise 64 GB.
Ich hab einfach nur, wisst ihr, was der Grund ist, warum ich 64 GB RAM hab?
Das ist der dümmste Grund aller Zeiten.
Der Grund ist, weil ich mehr haben wollte als im alten Rechner.
Das ist der einzige Grund, nicht weil es sinnvoll ist.
Ja, genau.
Ich wollte mehr haben als im alten Rechner.
Nicht weil es Sinn macht, sondern einfach weil es geht.
Das ist, das ist legit der einzige Grund.
Ich wär auch mit 32 GB ohne Probleme ausgekommen.
Aber ich wollte mehr haben als im alten Rechner.
Ich wollte mehr haben.
Ich, das ist so ein Tick, den ich habe, was, was neue Rechner angeht.
Ich will, dass mein neuer Rechner quasi in allen Belangen besser ist,
als mein alter.
Das Problem ist, das geht nicht linear so weiter.
Weil das würde bedeuten, wenn ich mir einen neuen Rechner kaufe, bräuchte ich den nächsten 128.
Und wir sind nicht mehr im Jahr 2000, wo sich das alles verdoppelt, dreifach und vierfach hat in ein paar Jahren.
Vielleicht, vielleicht mach ich dann einfach nur,
vielleicht mach ich dann einfach nur,
einfach nur, was ist denn, was ist denn 32 mal 3?
Das sind dann 96.
Vielleicht mach ich einfach nur 96.
Aber dann hab ich keinen Dual Channel.
Ah ja, gut.
Ich glaub, ich bleib einfach bei 64 beim neuen Rechner.
Wobei, neuer Rechner.
Wenn ich das hier denk, ich hol mir schon wieder einen neuen Rechner.
Hast du denn in dem DDR4 oder 5?
5?
Ich find meinen Rechner nicht, aber ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass es DDR5 ist.
Ja.
Ja, 2022, da ist er doch.
Ja, DDR5.
Stimmt, 48 Gigriegel und dann mal 2, ja, das wird auch gehen.
Und sogar relativ schnell in DDR5.
War vor ein paar Monaten bei einem Kunden, der seine Razer-Sachen jetzt alle wegschmeißt, mit HTMX neu macht.
Das sind sie, guck mal.
Ja, das würde ich, ganz ehrlich, das würde ich nicht machen, wenn ich irgendein funktionierendes Produkt habe,
das zu irgendwie rewriten, ist meistens, ich sag nicht immer, aber meistens zum Scheitern verurteilt.
Was sind denn meine Food-Trends?
Ja, ihr wisst alle, was es heute gibt bei mir zu essen, oder?
Gibt nicht so viele Möglichkeiten.
Kaufst du dir jedes Mal einen komplett neuen Rechner?
Ja, zu 90%.
Ich benutze manchmal alte SSDs weiter, oder alte Festplatten, aber der Rest ist neu.
Okay.
Das liegt doch einfach, okay, und die 10 Gigabit, die 10 Gigabit-Netzwerkkarte hatte ich jetzt, hatte ich jetzt schon in mir.
Aber ansonsten, es gibt doch eigentlich nichts, was du großartig wiederverwenden kannst.
Mainboard kannst du nicht wiederverwenden?
Was hast du hier?
Ups.
Was ist hier?
Okay, Disks und so.
RAM-Karte, SSDs, ja, da hatten wir es, okay.
CPU kannst du nicht wiederverwenden?
RAM kannst du nicht wiederverwenden?
Grafikkarte kannst du theoretisch wiederverwenden?
Ja.
Ich habe ja zwei Rechner nebeneinander stehen und ich mache das immer so, dass quasi mein Vorschau-Rechner, der hier quasi auf der linken Seite neben diesem Monitor steht.
Ich habe zwei Monitore an zwei unterschiedlichen Rechnern.
Links ist mein, quasi mein Vorschau.
Offstream Rechner und rechts ist quasi mein Haupt
hier Rechner mit Streaming Account und allem dabei
und ich, das
wird immer rotiert, der
mein, damals
also als ich den neuen Rechner gekauft
habe, wurde das rotiert, der alte wurde
weg, der alte wurde quasi zum
Vorschau Rechner und der neue wurde zum Main Rechner
so und wenn ich jetzt wieder
neuen Rechner kaufe, wird quasi der jetzige
zum Vorschau Rechner und der neue dann zum Main Rechner
ich rotiere das immer durch, die
restlichen kommen dann auf den Dachboden, ich schmeiße den
Kram nicht weg, ich hab da oben, jetzt weiß ich nicht
drei Rechner stehen oder so
und den alten
19 Zoll Server, der steht auch noch da
der fette dir, die 4 HE Kiste
das, äh, SLI ist
nett, oder? War das nicht so? SLI
kannst du eigentlich komplett knicken, keiner macht mehr SLI
Neue CPU für den gleichen
Sockel? Na, das ist ja bei Intel immer
schwierig, bei AMD geht
das besser, aber bei Intel hast du ja gefühlt
jeden, jede
Mini-Generation neue Socke
Arch Linux bei, du
wey, das ist richtig, du, du musst
eine Sache, Marlin, du musst eine Sache nur noch machen
du musst regelmäßig den Leuten mitteilen
dass du Arch Linux benutzt
das, also du machst das schon gut, du machst das schon gut
aber du kannst es noch ein bisschen öfters den Leuten mitteilen
das ist noch nicht genug, mach dich da auch
jeden Stream und auch ganz wichtig
ganz wichtig, du musst, du musst
ab und zu mal musst du den Leuten
dein Neo Fetch Output zeigen
du bringst genau das gleiche
du musst dann sagen, hier, by the way, ich benutze
Arch Linux, ähm
mit, äh, i3 als
als Desktop und meine Icon
Themes und meinen Mouse Theme, mein Terminal
mein Font, meine CPU
und so viel Rahmen hab ich und das
musst du den Leuten ab und zu mal zeigen, ja
Fast Fetch, aber Leute, mein
Neo Fetch ist alias auf Fast Fetch
insofern, ich benutze nur noch
Fast Fetch
das hat uns sogar die Linux-Oma
auf, auf, ähm, YouTube
erzählt, dass Neo Fetch
outdated ist und wenn die das sagt, dann stimmt das
Moment
Neo Fetch
outdated
guck, sogar
sogar die Linux-Oma auf YouTube
hat uns gesagt, Neo Fetch ist
discontinued
dann können wir Neo Fetch eigentlich nicht mehr
verwenden und das Video
hat 380.000 Aufrufe, man
Endeavor, Endeavor ist okay, das, das
da darf man auch Arch, by the way
sagen
fraglich ist bloß
ob man Jaro-User
sagen dürfen, dass sie Arch
by the way usen, da bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher
Chat, was sagt ihr?
Dürfen, dürfen man Jaro?
Eigentlich nicht, streng genommen darf man
dürfen man Jaro-User nicht sagen, dass sie Arch
by the way usen, keine Ahnung
wie es dem Neo Fetch-Entwickler geht, ich weiß nicht mal
wer der Neo Fetch-Entwickler ist
Hedorah, nee, nee, nee
Hast du mittlerweile mal Erfahrung
mit Potman gesammelt? Ja, immer mal
wieder, weil bei mir auf der Arbeit hat
irgendjemand gesagt, Potman ist quasi
das, was die Leute verwenden sollen
und die Leute
strugglen regelmäßig mit rootless
Containern, deswegen benutze ich einfach weiter Docker
Leute, es läuft zwar alles
quasi alles gut
wenn du erstmal Docker ausführen kannst, ja
Zugriff auf die Docker-Dieben hast, aber
es funzt, viele Container-Images
sind gar nicht dafür was anderes gemacht
Hab ich geklägert gerade
beim T muss ich mal kurz abputzen
Ja, das könnte ich machen
dann würden alle denken, ich verwende Potman, kek, Wade
Also ich mein, Potman kannst du genauso gut
wie Docker verwenden mit
root permissions, solange du das nicht aufgesetzt
hast mit
dieser ganzen rootless Geschichte
das macht nur Probleme und es sind eh irgendwelche
Entwicklerrechner ohne Rechte
also insofern, wen juckt's
Also Potman ging mir eigentlich bisher immer nur
auf den Keks, ich verwende nach wie vor
Docker
Ist das so, ist das
wirst du da quasi dann
verbal gesteinigt
Wobei, ist das, ok
Ich kenne den Vortrag nicht, oder ich kenne diese Aufnahme nicht
auf die du dich beziehst
Ist es schlimmer, als bei
Linux-Kernel-Entwicklern vorzustellen
dass man sich um Rust im Linux-Kernel
kümmert
Hat jemand diese Präsentation gesehen
von dem Typ, der, die sind sehr schlecht
auf Manjaro, ok
Benutz ja auch kein
Manjaro mehr schon seit ein paar Jahren, sondern
bin echter Arch-Linux-User
by the way geworden
Habt ihr diesen Vortrag gesehen, wo
einer der Kernel-Entwickler
Vortrag gehalten hat
über Rust
über Rust im Linux-Kernel
und dann irgendein Typ von den, also irgendein
Kernel-Maintainer, ein anderer Kernel-Maintainer
der Rust überhaupt nicht mag
die ganze Zeit aus dem Publikum reingeschwätzt hat
und den übelst abgefuckt hat
Ja
Ein ziemliches Shitfest
Ich konnte mir das ehrlich gesagt gar nicht am Stück angucken
So fremd geschämt habe ich mich dafür
Dabei, nicht dafür, dabei
Ich muss das immer wieder
weiter skippen
Ich betreue auf der Arbeit viele Arch-User, zählt das auch
Vielleicht könntest du sie dazu überreden
Arch-Linux zu benutzen
Wobei, du darfst auf der Arbeit sicherlich kein Arch-Linux
installieren, weil, weil Windows
Shit und sowas
Max?
Was?
Ausrufezeichen
Ich verwende schon mal
gar nicht Linux
Ich verwende knu slash linux
Ja?
Oder wie ich es manchmal auch nenne
knu plus linux
Ich hab, ich hab leider das
das Kommando vergessen
Wir haben irgendein Chat-Kommando dafür
Userwechsel von Ubuntu
zu Arch, aber nie umgedreht
Ja gut, das ist ja auch irgendwo klar
Es mag sicherlich die ein oder andere
Leute geben, die beides verwenden
Ich hab ne Zeit lang beispielsweise
Arch-Linux auf dem Desktop verwendet
Ubuntu auf dem Server verwendet
Ich hatte auch noch ne Ubuntu Desktop vorab
für manche Sachen
Aber, ja, das ist anscheinend sehr selten
Weil, sag mal, Ubuntu ist ja eher was Richtung
Einsteiger
Und Arch ist dann schon eher was für Fortgeschrittene
Warum wechseln Fortgeschrittene zurück zu Einsteiger?
Gut, vielleicht weil sie sagen
Ey, bei Arch geht mir zu viel kaputt
und ich muss mich zu viel selbst kümmern
Aber letztendlich
Ich würde auch sagen
90% wechseln eher von Arch zu Ubuntu auf dem Desktop
als von Ubuntu zu Arch
Gibt's das noch?
Auf die Seite traue ich mich jetzt nicht drauf zu gehen
Ne Moment, das ist doch gar nicht was ich meine
Das meine ich doch gar nicht
Es gab doch mal so nen Weebskin
für Ubuntu
Ich hab vergessen wie das hieß
Hatte ich auch mal JustForFun hier im Stream installiert
Da sind sie alle durchgedreht
Linux Mint, ja das ist gut
Mein Vater verwendet auch Linux Mint seit
nem Jahr oder so oder eineinhalb Jahren
Ich weiß nicht wie lang
Wie hieß denn dieser Ubuntu
Ubuntu Weebskin?
Gibt's doch so nen extra
Wubuntu? Nein
Ich hab vergessen wie das heißt
Ach hier, ich hab's wieder
Mobuntu
Ups, das meine ich
Das ist dann doch schon ein bisschen
Overload, oder?
Das sieht aus wie irgendwie ne 0815 Scam
Seite
Du kannst sogar Bitcoin donaten
Mein Vater hat Linux Mint am Start
Der hat die
Der hat so ne Mini PC von mir gekriegt
Mit Linux Mint drauf
Ich hab einfach Auto-Updates eingeschaltet
Dass ich nix machen muss
Aber ich hab Teamviewer drauf installiert
Dass ich theoretisch mich einloggen könnte
Per Teamviewer, wenn was ist
Aber es ist erstaunlich selten was
Der scheint damit einfach klar zu kommen
Aber der macht ja auch nix
Der macht den Webbrowser auf und das war's
Browser only
Sollen die machen
In letzter Zeit hab ich fast nix mehr geguckt
Ich hatte mal so ne Anime-Guckphase
Was aber hauptsächlich daran lag
Dass mir die ganzen Streaming-Services auf den Sack gingen
Hier brauchst du noch ein Abo
Hier kannst du jetzt nicht mehr für mehrere Geräte abschließen
Hab ich einfach gesagt
Was scheiß auf Streaming-Anbieter
Ich fang jetzt einfach an Anime zu gucken
Ich hab nie großartig geguckt
Ich kann jetzt quasi seit 50 Jahren alles nachholen
Weil das so ne Grauzone ist
Vom Streaming her
Du kannst die meisten Anime ja kostenlos gucken
Kostenlos
So
Was ist das?
Das Problem kenn ich
Hätte das meiner Mutter auch erzählt
Wenn sie nicht drauf fühlt
Ja das Problem kenn ich
Oh shit ja ihr habt recht Leute
Ich hab gehustet das muss was ganz schlimmes sein
Ja das Problem kenn ich
Meine Mutter hatte damals auch Ubuntu
Also schon richtig lange her
2008 und 2009
So als sie noch nen Desktop Rechner hatte
Mittlerweile hat die gar keinen Desktop Rechner mehr
Mittlerweile hat die nur noch Tablets
Und die hat theoretisch noch nen Notebook aber das wird nicht verwendet
Das ist ein uraltes Single Core was auch immer
Schrott Notebook
Ja und es war damals auch so
Die ist super klar gekommen mit Ubuntu
Damals war das noch Ubuntu mit
Die hatte sogar Compets
Wobbly Windows Leute Wobbly beste überhaupt
Die ist damit super klar gekommen
Aber die wollte einmal im Jahr ihre Steuererklärung machen
Und damals hat die
Was hat die verwendet?
Wieso Sparbuch?
Ist das wieso Sparbuch?
Ja
Wieso Sparbuch hieß das damals?
2010 oder so
Das hat die
Von Bool genau das hat die verwendet
Damals
Und das ging halt
Mit Wine unter Linux nur rudimentär
Das ist nicht so da ich gesagt hätte
Ohja das will man haben
Und
Die musste dann immer
Windows VM booten
Das war halt voll für den Arsch
Die war dann immer nicht geupdatet und so
Da hab ich gedacht ey komm
Steig doch mal auf irgendeinen Online Service um
Oder im Zweifelsfall mach es wie ich
Lass es den Steuerberater machen
Mach den Scheiß doch gar nicht selbst
Die Kohle für den Steuerberater
Die ist es wert das man sich nicht damit rumschlagen muss
Großartig
Mittlerweile schon 2008
Sah das ein bisschen anders aus
Kann man das im Browser machen
Aber es gab dann immer mehr solcher Tools
Was ich immer mit dem Popup mache
Du meinst das hier?
Nix nix das ist einfach bescheuert
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen 1 im Chat
Da erklär ich das was ich da mache
Da können wir
Dürfen wir
Dürfen wir nicht
Das ist genau so wenig wie das wir
IHK Abschlussprüfung zeigen dürfen
Nein nein nein
Ausrufezeichen 1 so
Ausgeschrieben
Wir könnten das vielleicht mal aliasen
Die Vorschau geht nicht
Aber der Clip an sich geht ne
Ja
Okay
Also
Na es läuft
Github Trends haben wir uns schon angeguckt
Gab es die Woche sonst noch irgendwas spannendes
Irgendwas was ich verpasst habe fällt euch irgendwas noch ein
Hab es irgendwas wichtiges
Max das ist mit Wordpress
Ich hab gesehen da gibt es ein Video von
Fireship
Das können wir uns gleich angucken
Wollen wir uns das angucken
Ne erst mal das hier
Das hat jemand im Chat vorgeschlagen
Ne wir gucken das Fireship Video zuerst
Das Fireship Video
Das Fireship Video ist kurz und knackig
Komm wir gucken das
Fireship Video sind auch immer taugen auch immer
The Wordpress Ecosystem has lost its mind
Ich hab das
Ich frage euch jetzt mal für die Leute die es mitgekriegt haben
Ich hab da auf Twitter ein bisschen was mitgekriegt
Und zwar
Irgendein langjähriger Wordpress
Contributor
Hat getwittert
Dass er jetzt obwohl er langjähriger Wordpress
Contributor ist Wordpress nicht mehr verwenden darf
Weil
Weil er für einen seiner Kunden
Auf einer VM Wordpress laufen hat
Oder sowas
Gehts da drum
Ist das das gleiche
Das ist Arc 3 ok da kommt noch mehr
Dann gucken wir uns das doch mal an
The things people are saying about the guy behind Wordpress right now
Are absolutely brutal
He has main character syndrome
A cancer to his own community
Matt has the legal acumen of a pissed off preteen who thought he was clever
Naming his company Automatic really says it all
Automatic is doing open source dirty
It's sad to watch really
The internet really seems to hate this guy right now
Which is ironic
Because it's his own tool
That's responsible for over 40% of the websites on the internet
But is he really a tyrannical leader who's losing his mind
Or is he actually an open source freedom fighter
Battling evil private equity firms
To make the world a better place
In today's video you decide
We'll look at a timeline of the recent Wordpress drama
Which began to spiral out of control a couple weeks ago
When Automatic
The owner of the Wordpress trademark
Requested millions of dollars from WP Engine
One of the most popular Wordpress hosting platforms
That's led to a bunch of mean tweets
Erinnert mich ein bisschen an
Elasticsearch und Amazon
Da gab's doch auch Stress
But the drama hit new heights yesterday
With the most controversial checkbox ever implemented on a website
What the hell is going on
Wait wait wait
Login your Wordpress org account to contribute
I am not
Affiliate with WP Engine
In any way financially
Und wenn du das nicht anhakst
Darfst du dich nicht einloggen
Wie?
What the hell is going on with Wordpress
It is October 11th 2024
And you're watching the code report
If you're a Javascript developer
It may come as a shock to you
That nearly half the websites on the internet run Wordpress
An open source tool built on PHP and jQuery
And easily the most successful website builder of all time
Because why write code
When you can just put a bunch of plugins together like Lego bricks
The main reason Wordpress is so prolific
Is that it has a massive ecosystem
Of themes and plugins
Check, habt ihr schon mal Wordpress in irgendeiner Art und Weise benutzt und gehostet?
Ich hab immer einen riesen Bogen um Wordpress gemacht
Weil die ersten Sachen die ich von Wordpress mitgekriegt hab
Waren immer Sicherheitslücken
Ich hab immer einen riesen Bogen um Wordpress gemacht
Und ähm
Hab ich auch weiterhin vor
...
Und was kommt als nächstes? Die dritte Million mit Salesforce?
Ich muss euch sagen, ich finde eine Sache immer ein bisschen fragwürdig, wenn Wörter und einfache Buchstabenkombinationen in irgendeiner Art und Weise rechtlich Probleme verursachen.
Sehe ich übrigens bei Wörtern wie Apple ganz genauso problematisch.
Und die Kombination von W und P, was auch Well Played heißen könnte, jetzt irgendwie zu Copywriten von WordPress...
Ja, Rust ist auch...
Rust ist auch so ein Ding, ja genau.
Da gab es ja auch schon Stress drüber.
Wenigstens ist JS nicht Copyrighted irgendwie.
WordPress.com ist der default Host, den jeder mitgeht.
Aber es gibt noch eine andere, sehr erfolgreiche Firma, die WP Engine nennt.
Sie macht hunderttausende Millionen Dollar, die WordPress hostet und ist unterstützt von der Privat-Equity-Firma Silverlink.
Wo das Hauptziel ist, Kapital zurückzuholen.
Und das bedeutet, dass sie viel weniger Arbeit zurückgeben, als die Non-Profit-Arm von WordPress.
Zumindest im Vergleich zu Automatik.
Und ein wichtiger Fakt, was hier zu wissen ist, ist, dass Automatik ein Investor und Part-Owner von WP Engine war, bis es in 2018 zu Silverlink verkauft wurde.
Es gibt wahrscheinlich ein schlechtes Blut zwischen den beiden Firmen, die Jahre zurückgehen.
Aber der Hauptkatalys für den letzten Drama ist am 20. September, als Automatik diesen trademarken Lizenzvertrag an WP Engine sendete.
Es ist im Grunde ein Ransom-Not, der beurteilt, dass Automatik eine Räumlichkeit von 8% ihres Großes bezahlt.
Ich kann das in gewisser Weise nachvollziehen, so wie er das jetzt dargestellt hat.
Dass sie das nicht so geil finden.
Das hat ein bisschen was von der Elasticsearch und Amazon.
Dass Amazon quasi Elasticsearch, nennen wir es mal, kopiert hat oder benutzt hat, um damit massig viel Geld zu machen, ohne dass Elasticsearch was von hatte.
Also ich kann das halbwegs nachvollziehen bis hier, dass sie das irgendwie kacke finden.
Auf der anderen Seite könnte man auch einfach sagen, ah ja gut, das ist halt ein Open-Source-Produkt und wenn da einer sein Business drumherum aufbaut, ist das erlaubt und gerechtfertigt und okay.
Aber weiß ich nicht.
Chat, wie seht ihr das bis jetzt?
Ist das gerechtfertigt, dass der abgefuckt ist versus WP Engine oder ist WP Engine da komplett fein?
Ich bin mir nicht selbst sicher.
Ich kann es zumindest nachvollziehen, dass er da abgefuckt ist.
Sie wollen sie nicht forken und ihre Open-Source-Plugins wie WooCommerce vermarkten.
Nun, wie ihr euch vorstellen könntet, hat WP Engine nicht den Termin geschehen.
Was verrückt ist, dass am nächsten Tag, am 21. September, Matt Mullenweg auf der Bühne ist,
an der World Camp US-Commerce.
Und er nennt WP Engine, Quote, ein Kanzer zu WordPress.
Wie private Qualität...
Okay, das muss dann wiederum nicht sein, auf irgendeiner Konferenz die anderen zu Trash-Talken.
... und zerstören.
Es gibt doch Open-Source-Lizenzen, die das irgendwie erschweren.
Ja, aber anscheinend war das bei WordPress bis jetzt okay.
Deswegen haben sie ja unter anderem ihre Bedingungen geändert.
... Open-Source-Communities.
Sehr interessantes Zeitpunkt für diese Präsentation.
Aber es wird viel verrückter.
Wenn ihr nur über diese Situation hört,
müsst ihr wirklich auf daily.com sein.
... die Sponsorin dieses Videos.
Nicht nur ist es ein guter Ort, um eure Programmierungs-Skizzen zu leveln,
um alle neuesten und größten Inhalte zu behalten.
Aber ihr könnt auch...
... aber ihr könnt auch finden, was echte Entwickler denken,
über kontroversielle Probleme, wie dieses WordPress-Drama.
Wenn ihr Teil der Kontroversie.Dev-Squad seid,
verpasst ihr nie eine große Geschichte.
Dann könnt ihr...
... über diese Themen diskutieren
und mit gleichmächtigen Entwicklern networken,
anstatt mit einigen anonymen Spots auf Reddit zu argumentieren.
Als Entwickler ist die Anzahl der Informationen,
die ihr aufnehmen müsst, absurd.
Anstatt über die Internet-Internet-Dumpster zu surfen,
könnt ihr einfach...
Man kann auch einfach 90% ignorieren und warten,
bis es relevant wird.
... auf 90% ignorieren und warten,
um alle Informationen, die in einem Ort wichtig sind,
Und sich nur die Sachen rauspicken, die einen wirklich interessieren.
... und ihr könnt mit meinem Anruf-Link signen.
Aber jetzt zurück zu WordPress.
WordPress.org hat auch einen Blog-Post gemacht,
der heißt WP Engine ist nicht WordPress,
was wiederholt, dass sie nicht genug Informationen geben,
... und beschreibt, wie sie Features wie Revisionen auswählen,
um Geld auf ihrer Backend-Infrastruktur zu sparen.
Zwei Tage später, am 23. September,
klatscht WP Engine zurück mit einem Saisondesist,
welches Mullenweg beurteilt,
dass sie salatische und furchtbare Statements machen.
Das selbe Tag klatscht Automatik wieder auf ihren Klatsch zurück
mit seinem eigenen Saisondesist,
... und sagt WP Engine, dass...
Okay, die Einzigen, die daran gerade Geld verdienen, sind Anwälte.
... den unverantwortlichen Nutzung ihrer Marken stoppen.
An diesem Punkt hat es nur ein paar legales Shit-Talking.
Ja.
Aber zwei Tage später, am 23. September,
... wird WP Engine von WordPress.org verabschiedet.
Das ist ein großer Deal, weil es bedeutet,
dass die WordPress-Installe auf ihrer Plattform
keine Updates mehr erhalten können,
oder Plugins aus der .org-Repo hinzufügen,
was einen direkten Einfluss auf WordPress-Developer und Anwälte hat.
Und das ist ein bisschen verrückt.
Und jetzt sind bestimmt...
Das ist halt immer problematisch, sowas.
Letztendlich ist es ein Battle zwischen den zwei Unternehmen,
aber es fällt am Ende unvermeidlich negativ auf WordPress zurück,
auf das Produkt WordPress.
Weil...
Ganz ehrlich, jemand, der sich seine...
Der Zahnarzt, der sich eine Webseite auf WP Engine hostet,
und da irgendwie einmal im halben Jahr seine Urlaubszeiten einträgt, zum Beispiel,
und ansonsten auf seiner Webseite nichts updatet, nichts macht,
dem ist das doch scheißegal, was da abgeht.
Der will, dass der Kram funktioniert.
Und wenn es jetzt auf einmal nicht mehr richtig funktioniert, ja,
weil, keine Ahnung, das Urlaubszeiten-Calender-Sync-Plugin nicht mehr geladen werden kann,
dann fuckt das den ab.
Und dem ist das egal, ob das WP Engine-Fault ist, WordPress-Fault, Automatic oder sowas, Fault ist.
Den fuckt das einfach ab, und er sagt, ich verwende nie wieder WordPress, weil es ein Kackprodukt ist.
...considering that Mullenweg is offering a competing platform with WordPress.com,
and he also went to his blog and said, quote,
WP Engine is free to offer their own hacked up bastardized simulerica of WordPress's GPL code to their customers,
and they can experience WordPress as WP Engine.
WP Engine envisions it.
That's harsh, but Molenweg does have a good number of supporters online.
If you don't agree with them, Automatic even offered a severance package to employees who wanted to leave,
offering $30,000 or 6 months pay, and 159 employees took that deal.
Or offering $30,000...
Wer hat wem was?
Moment, wer hat wem jetzt was angeboten?
Nein, nein, WP Engine betreibt...
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, nicht...
Ja, ja, das ist...
Nee, wordpress.com?
Jetzt blick ich auch nicht mehr durch.
Ist wordpress.com jetzt WP Engine gewesen?
Ich check's nicht mehr.
Ah, Tom, ja, okay.
Ja.
Warte mal, wer hat wem jetzt angeboten?
WP Engine hat den Wordpress-Leuten angeboten, wenn sie kündigen, kriegen sie 30.000 Euro?
Oder was, wie, wo?
...$30,000 oder 6 Monate pay, und 159 Mitarbeiter took that deal.
Oder 8,4% of the employees.
Das ganze Team.
Now, after the initial ban, Mullenweg went on a media tour, where he argued his position on the Primogen and Theo streams.
This stuff, I think it attacks so much.
I can imagine you've had a...
Actually, like, at one point, I'm, like, not feeling the best, so I know this is a video stream, I probably don't look the best, but please...
Oh, you look great, don't worry about how you look.
I mean, don't worry, you have me next to you.
He's fighting a battle in the court of public opinion, but I can't imagine his lawyers advised him to do that,
because then immediately after, WP Engine filed a lawsuit, and it even cited those stream appearances.
Inside the lawsuit, there's all kinds of claims, like computer fraud and abuse act violations, attempted extortion, unfair competition, libel and slander, and many others.
Also, ganz ehrlich, die einzigen, die sich da freuen, sind gerade irgendwelche Anwaltskanzleien.
Die sind happy.
But then, things got even more nutty, when the WordPress.org login added this new checkbox that said,
I am not affiliated with WP Engine in any way, financially or otherwise.
You'll want to talk to your lawyer before you check that, because it has a CSS class of login lawsuit, and you can't even log into WordPress without checking it.
That forced WP Engine to come out and clarify.
That their customers and users are not affiliates.
All this nonsense has people talking about forking WordPress, but the entire thing is a great example of how there are no good guys in war.
Are you on the team of the petty megalomaniac CEO, who's willing to burn down his entire community to prove a point?
Or are you on the team of the parasitic, freeloading private equity firm, whose only guiding principle is financial gain?
There's only one loser in this war, and that's the WordPress user.
Ja, das ist genau das, was ich auch gesagt habe.
Richtig.
Weil was interessiert es den Zahnarzt, der da seine Webseite drauf hostet?
Und irgendein Kalender-Sync-Plugin hat, um seine Urlaubszeiten zu aktualisieren.
Genau das.
Und das, was hängenbleiben wird, am Ende ist ein Schaden an WordPress, weil die Leute sagen, ey, den Kack kannst du nicht mehr verwenden.
Ja, so ungefähr denke ich mir das.
Habe ich mir das auch gedacht, ja.
Aber was, was, aktive...
Also ich meine, für Fireship ist es gut.
Der hat ja quasi durch solche Sachen unendlich Content.
Ach, die haben ihren eigenen Leuten, die nicht deren Meinung sind, eine Abfindung angeboten.
Schade.
Ups.
Schade, dass die alte Firma, für die ich gearbeitet habe, das nicht gemacht hat.
Das hätte ich auch gemacht.
Hätte mir die alte Firma, wo ich gearbeitet habe, angeboten, 30.000 Euro Abfindung für Leute, die irgendwie das Geschäftsmodell nicht mögen oder ja, nicht damit im Einklang sind, was da passiert, dann hätte ich sofort, hätte ich auch sofort gemacht.
Weil ich meine, ich wollte eh weg.
Dann hätte ich einfach...
Wäre ich eh weg, wie geplant und hätte noch 30.000 Euro gekriegt.
Dann hätte ich nicht Nein dazu gesagt.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Na, jetzt gucken wir mal das Video, was der Chat, der Chat empfohlen hat.
Ja, also ich sag mal so, so kacke sind die Fritzboxen jetzt ja auch nicht.
Wenn man ein schönes Multifunktionsgerät haben will, wohlgemerkt.
Wenn man jetzt irgendwelche advanced Routing-Anforderungen hat, dann ist die Fritzbox nix.
Aber die meisten Leute haben das nicht.
Which I instantly wanted to get rid of.
Unfortunately, or should I say fortunately, as you shortly discover, my ISP told me there is no way I could not use it.
Challenge accepted.
Ich bin nicht sicher, ob das laut genug ist.
Ah, ich glaube schon.
This is Fritzbox 15.
Okay, das ist eine ganz alte.
Das ist eine 5.
Das ist, das ist so eine Provider.
Ne, 4, das ist so eine, so eine Provider Edition.
Oder nicht?
Ach ne, die 5er, sind das die Glasfaser?
Ich blick da bei den Dingern immer durch.
Das ist mir zu hoch.
Fritzbox 5491.
War das, gell?
Gibt es das überhaupt?
Bei denen noch.
Gibt es da, gibt es da irgendwie, Datasheet?
Gibt es nicht.
Eigenschaften und Funktionen, okay.
Okay, ganz so alt kann sie schon mal nicht sein.
Die Firma, ja gut, sieht mir nach einer 0815 Fritzbox aus, ehrlich gesagt.
Nix, nix abartig Schlimmes, aber auch jetzt nix super krass Tolles.
And according to my ISP is a high-end device.
I mean, in all seriousness, it's actually not a bad one for someone who just needs the basics.
Such as your gigabit links, Wi-Fi, IPTV and even classic telephony.
It even has a backdoor, sorry, a management protocol called TR069, which the ISP can access
the device through without me knowing.
The problem I have with this, though, is the fact that my ISP can have full access to a
device in my home and I only get basic and proprietary web interface.
Okay, das, das verstehe ich.
Wie ich das bei mir gelöst habe, ist ganz einfach.
Das Provider, die Provider-Kiste sitzt vor meinem Mikrotik-Router und von dem Netz vor
meinem Mikrotik-Router kommst du halt einfach nirgendwo hin.
Plus, take a good look at it.
I mean, it's hideous and I will not have a piece of ugly networking gear in my home, period.
Naja, so hässlich sind die Fritzbox-Dinger auch nicht.
Also, ganz ehrlich, ich bevorzuge die Optik der Fritzbox-Dinger versus die Stealth-Bomber-Router.
Jetge, was findet ihr optisch ansprechender?
Diese futuristischen, was auch immer es sein soll, Router oder eine Fritzbox von der Optik?
Also, ich finde da tatsächlich die klassischen Fritzbox-Dinger.
Fritzbox-Look schöner und den neuen Fritzbox-Look finde ich sogar noch einen Ticken besser.
Den neuen weißen Fritzbox-Look.
Also, mir ist das auch egal, aber er bezieht sich ja explizit auf die Optik.
Und ich finde die Optik gar nicht mal so übel.
Mein Telefon läuft über die Fritzbox.
Ja, macht sie auch.
Hast du die Fritzbox hinter dem Mikro-Link?
Ne, ich habe meinen Provider-Modem oder meinen Provider-Router, also die Vodafone-Box,
steht vorne, dahinter ist direkt daran angeschlossen, ist eine Fritzbox, die macht VoIP und Gedöns und ja, eigentlich nur VoIP, ja.
Ah ja, und die Heizungsthermostate sind da auch dran.
Und am Vodafone-Router ist auch noch mein Mikro-Tik-Router angeschlossen.
Hinter dem ist dann mein ganzes anderes Netzwerkzeug.
Wählt sich der Mikro-Link PPOE ein?
Ne, ich habe Kabel-Internet, das geht nicht.
Nein, nein, die Vodafone-Box macht die.
Einwahl.
Und der Mikro-Tik-Router benutzt die quasi als Gateway.
Das ist quasi vorne die Vodafone-Box, dahinter ist quasi der Mikro-Tik-Router und die Fritzbox.
Die Fritzbox macht nichts außer VoIP und der Mikro-Tik-Router ist dann letztendlich der Endpunkt für alles, was ich dahinter habe.
Oder sagen wir mal, der hauptsächliche Netzwerk-Knotenpunkt für alles, was dahinter ist.
Hinter dem Mikro-Tik-Router kommen dann die WLAN-Axis-Points.
Dann kommt mein interner Switch, wo mein internes Netz dran ist, wo der Desktop-PC, die Konsolen und alles mögliche dranhängt.
Der Fernseher, das Shield-TV, das hängt alles dann an dem Switch.
Dann, wie gesagt, an den PPOE-Ports vom Mikro-Tik-Router hängen die Access-Points dran.
Doppel-NUT.
Ja, es ist tatsächlich zur Zeit doppelt NUT, aber es müsste nicht doppelt NUT sein.
Das ist nicht zwangsläufig. Nur weil man zwei Geräte hintereinander hat.
Ich habe doppeltes NUT, das stimmt, weil es einfach vom Setup her einfacher ist.
Du müsstest nicht doppeltes NUT machen. Das ist nicht notwendig bei so einem Setup.
Du kannst auch Routen eintragen, das funktioniert auch.
Du musst nicht doppeltes NUT machen.
Aber ich habe doppeltes NUT gemacht, weil es easy einzurichten ist und du dir auch ohne irgendwelche großen Firewall-Regeln sicher sein kannst.
Okay, von außen.
Kommt nix rein, solange nix weitergeleitet ist.
Die ISP bezeichnet es als ein High-End-Device.
Na ja, weil nachdem der Techniker, der es aufgeräumt hat, weggegangen ist, habe ich sofort die Unterstützung angerufen,
um zu fragen, ob ich etwas Besseres finden kann.
By the way, in Deutschland ist es ja so, man hat ja freie Routerauswahl.
Ich glaube, das ist immer noch so.
Bin mir nicht sicher, ob sie das nicht mittlerweile gekippt haben.
Aber das war zumindest so.
Du hast freie Routerauswahl.
Also wenn die sagen...
Jetzt, das habe ich mir auch schon überlegt, ich habe sogar noch eine FRITZ!Box hier stehen, die ich daran anschließen wollte.
Ich wollte ja eigentlich schon mal meine FRITZ!Box und den Vodafone-Router durch eine etwas neuere FRITZ!Box ersetzen.
Aber war ich zu faul bisher dafür.
Die CDU will das kippen. Ja, die können mich mal.
Der Markt regelt das, wisst ihr doch.
Aber das ist so ein...
Das ist so ein Special SFP-Modul.
Das sieht hier vorne vom Stecker her irgendwie anders aus.
Ach genau, das sind doch diese Dinger, wo so ein halber LC-Stecker reinkommt, oder?
Oder SC? Ich kann mir das immer nicht merken.
Nee, LC.
Nee, SC-Stecker.
Genau, das sind ja Dinger, wo so ein halber SC-Stecker reinkommt.
Weirdchampiges Ding.
Aber eine Frage, Chatge, warum ist das überhaupt ein SFP-Modul
und warum hat das die Fritzbox nicht eingebaut, sodass du den SC-Stecker direkt in die Fritzbox stecken kannst?
Wahrscheinlich, weil es mehrere Anschlüsse gibt, ne?
Wahrscheinlich, weil manche Hersteller so einen Stecker machen
und manche Hersteller so einen Stecker machen,
und manche Hersteller machen so einen Stecker.
Ja, okay.
AVM?
Das stimmt.
Da habe ich auch...
Da habe ich auch schon einige Sachen drin gefunden.
Fiber-Optik-Routers included.
There is a downside though, for me at least.
It's all in German, which I do not speak, so I had to browse those forums through Google Translate.
This took a lot of time, but at that point there were lockdowns all over the place,
so time was something I did have.
The only downside was that while I was experimenting with the router,
the internet wouldn't work, so I was only allowed to do it after the rest of the family was in bed.
Which meant after midnight.
Welches Forum?
Hier.
IP Phone Forum.
Das da.
After a couple of weeks of searching the forum and getting nowhere,
I decided I'll turn the thing around and ask directly.
Again, using Google Translate.
To my surprise, people replied that it is indeed possible to get root access to the device
and pointed me to a particular GitHub repository with full...
Gab es nicht sogar mal eine Custom-Firmware für die Fritzbox?
Das irgendwie Fritz oder so hieß?
Können wir ja weitere Modifikationen für die Fritzbox, ja?
Weiß ich nicht, ob es das überhaupt noch gibt, ob das noch aktiv weiterentwickelt wird, keine Ahnung.
Nee.
Fritz NG soll man verwenden, okay?
Wie installiert man das eigentlich?
Ich hab mir das noch nie angeguckt.
Flash Firmware, okay.
Wie schließt man das an?
What?
News?
Install.
Es gibt drei Wege, ein Web-Interface.
Okay, der prüft die Signaturen.
Bootloader.
Der Bootloader, okay.
Okay, das ist dann tatsächlich etwas advanceder, das zu installieren.
Machen wir mal.
You...
You, Fritz...
...the code from the repo and generate a USB drive,
which you then stick into the router,
that is this...
...disconnected from power.
Because the device needs to be somehow recoverable or accessible,
if it gets completely bricked,
it has the following behavior built in.
While it's booting up,
if it detects a certain directory structure on the USB drive,
it's booting up.
If it detects...
Dieser USB-Stick, Alter.
Das ist dieses Ding, was jeder schon mal hat.
Das sind diese 30-Cent-USB-Sticks.
Warte mal.
Die es diesem 20er-Pack gibt.
Die Dinger sind das hier.
Diese billigen Drecksdinger, die hatte jeder schon mal.
Chatke, Hand hoch, wer so ein Ding schon mal hatte
oder als Werbegeschenk bekommen hat
oder auf einer Messe bekommen hat oder sonst was.
Diese USB-Sticks, die sind überall.
Jeder hat so ein Ding.
Und die sind einfach abgrundtief schlecht.
Die sind so schrottig.
Die sind so schlecht.
Jeder hatte die schon mal, stimmt's?
Jeder hat den Grab schon mal gehabt.
So was hier, genau.
So ein Teil.
Das ist das, was er hier gerade hat.
Das ist das, was er hier gerade dran macht.
Liegt gerade vor mir.
Und die sind extrem langsam.
Hyper langsam sind die.
Ich hab da mal ein paar SSH-Keys drauf kopiert.
Das hat 5 Minuten gebraucht, bis es den Ride-Vorgang abgeschlossen hat.
Das sind ein paar Kilobyte.
Ah, Mann, ja.
Diese Dinger hatte jeder.
Guck, das sind exakt die.
Die hatte jeder schon mal.
So, hier sind wir.
Wir haben euch noch ge cuisinexperts genuinely durchgebracht.
Perspektive nach einer ganzen Lab,
mit denen wir uns fast die ganze Zeit AOA-Module ansehen,
ist das schon alles einfach.
Wenn ich das jetzt so einfach auf den Punkt Klappen,
habe ich schon die ganze Zeit,
keine Zeit mehr,
weil ich solche Videos mit dem Swap habe.
Ich habe nicht mal die ganze Zeit viel CKP gemacht,
die ich auf der Website erst mal gemacht habe.
Und das war es.
Diese ganze Zeit habe ich alles auf der Website gedruckt und
die ganze Zeit habe ich auch nicht gesagt,
wie ich das alles machen muss.
Und dann bin ich nicht mehr da,
aber ich bin immer auf der Website.
Und das ist jetzt das ganze Stück.
Das ist alles, das es geht.
Was? Das macht jetzt keinen Sinn.
Warum? Das SFP-Modul hat doch nicht keine eigene IP.
What?
Okay. Wirklich?
Das hat keine eigene IP?
Also meine SFP-Module
hatten noch nie eine eigene IP.
Wireshark.
Das habe ich auch noch nicht gesehen.
Ich habe es euch gesagt, Leute.
Ich habe es euch gesagt.
Das ist genau das, was ich im Vorfeld von dem Video gesagt habe.
Okay, ich habe gesagt, er liest die MAC-Adresse aus.
Aber es ist schon sehr ähnlich zu dem, was ich gesagt habe.
Ich habe es schon gesagt.
Okay, das heißt, die Fritzbox hat damit gar nichts zu tun.
Das macht das Linux, was in dem SFP-Modul quasi Embedded ausgeliefert wird.
Das ist auch...
Nein, das hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass es SFP-Module gibt mit einem Embedded Linux.
What the fuck?
Also meine SFP-Module sind einfach nur dumm.
Die stecke ich in den Switch und dann übersetzen die Fiber zu...
Ja, was?
Was auch immer.
SFP-Port.
Sage ich jetzt einfach mal.
Vielleicht haben die das ja auch.
...Modules.
Knowing nothing about them at the time, but enough about physics,
all I cared about was their wavelength and power.
The latter is...
The latter is obviously very important, as I didn't want to damage any of the service provider's equipment on the other side of the optic cable.
I ordered as many standalone SFP-Modules I could find, probably around seven in total, but none of them worked properly.
This one, for example, from an indie GPON-Developer, got online, but the IPTV didn't work.
The ones from Ubiquiti called UF Instant actually come with solder points on the PCB inside,
so I was actually able to solder a UART-Interface on it.
...
Das wird's aber advanced, eine serielle Verbindung zu einem SFP-Modul, und dann mit einer Konsole dran, oder was?
...but they run a proprietary firmware that unfortunately only works with their switches, on the optic side, that is, so these were a no-go as well.
But eventually I did find the one.
This is the FiberStore.com.
GPON ONU stick with MAC SFP optical trans...
...FiberStore.com...
Ich hab's erst mal schön von FS bestellt, die D-Dacker haben relativ... die haben günstige SFP-Module.
...FiberStore.com... die D-Dacker haben relativ... die haben günstige SFP-Module.
...GPON ONU stick with MAC SFP optical transceiver, and has been a part of my network stack for about two years now.
And I guess it's the only SFP GPON module on the market that satisfies all the requirements, or put it differently,
is a perfect replacement for the one that came with the Fritzbox.
It has the same wavelengths, it has the same transmit and receive power, and more importantly, I can SSH into it and per...
Ha ha, ich find das irgendwie geil, SSH in das SFP-Modul!
Hahaha.
...GPON ONU stick with MAC SFP optical transceiver, and has been a part of my network stack for about two years now.
Okay, ich kann mich auch auf meinen DVB-C Receiver ssh-en, oder auf noch abgedrehtere Sachen.
Ich kann mich auf ganz vieles Zeug her ssh-en,
wo man sich eigentlich denkt, da sollte man sich...
aber ssh auf's esfp-Modul ist mir jetzt auch wirklich schon neu.
...GPON ONU stick with 6508 ssh, das ist jetzt auch schon neu.
...GPON ONU stick mit 6008 SSH, das ist jetzt auch schon neu.
...permanently save the serial number into its flash storage and this means the power outages don't have any effect on it and it just continues to work when the power is back on.
You can find it on fs.com and I'll leave the link in the description below.
The only drawback, it's somewhat expensive for...
Serious? Ich hab keine Ahnung, warum man damit überhaupt anfängt.
Wegen sowas vielleicht, ja?
...but it is coming at around 70 euros.
But, given I have likely spent hundreds of hours trying to get to this point, I wasn't going to let that stop me.
Alright, let's wrap this one for now.
If you have any questions, don't hesitate to ask below.
And if you enjoyed the video, consider subscribing for more content like this.
Tomas from Slovenia, signing out.
Wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp.
Stimmt, ausverkauft mittlerweile.
Hot ist es, hot.
Das wollen ganz viele haben.
Anscheinend, ja? Ja, ja.
Die Fritzbox macht das nicht.
Die Fritzbox redet mit dem Ding wohl nur über die...
Ja, was auch immer das hat.
Irgendeinen Port offen oder so.
Über IP zumindest.
Wahrscheinlich könntest du darauf sogar Doom spielen.
Wenn du irgendwie über SSH oder so, grafische Ausgabe, ASCII, ASCII Doom oder so.
Wahrscheinlich könntest du sogar ASCII Doom auf den Dingern spielen.
Interessant, also...
Ja, warum er jetzt aber die Fritzbox so scheiße fand, habe ich gar nicht verstanden.
Okay, doch, weil sein Provider da Access drauf hat.
Okay, das verstehe ich, aber das könnte man auch anders fixen, so wie ich es auch gefixt habe.
Ein Rieselrad dreht wegen Stromausfall durch.
Oh, da kriegst du es aber mit der Angst zu tun, oder?
Da wurde dann entsprechend gemeldet, dass das Riesenrad sich immer mehr beschleunigt,
dass die Menschen im Riesenrad natürlich auch Angstgefühle entwickeln.
Ja.
Man muss sich vorstellen, das ist erst am Anfang wie in so einer Zentrifuge.
Es wird unwahrscheinlich schnell.
Die elektronischen Mechanismen waren ausgeschaltet.
Schreckensminuten.
Da denkst du auch so, ups, gleich fliegen wir raus.
Ein Stromausfall in 38 Metern Höhe.
Das Rad pendelt ungebremst.
Da war aber auf einmal der ganze Platzlicht aus.
Platzmeister, der sagt, ja, das ist komplett der Umkreis, es hat keinen Strom.
Und deswegen musste ich dann Not evakuieren.
Die Luftbein runter, das ist der schwerste Punkt.
Entsprechend gemeldet.
Irgendwann.
Kommt schnell, die zu Folgefehlern führt.
Da kriegst du bestimmt wieder Angst zu tun.
Denkst, was ist hier los? Irgendwas stimmt da nicht.
Die Zerstörung von Windows.
Ja, bei dem Titel.
Also es gibt genug, wo ich mich über Windows abfacken könnte.
Guck mal, was die sagen.
Zerstörung von Windows.
Guck mal hier, diesen Dreck hier zeigt mir mein frisch installiertes Windows 11,
wenn ich den vorinstallierten Browser starte, also Edge.
Die gleichen schrottigen Nachrichten gibt es übrigens auch,
wenn ich links hier auf dieses Wetter-Icon klicke.
Ja, das geht mir auch auf den Sack.
Das habe ich, glaube ich, ausgeschaltet.
Ja, und wenn ich meine Energieeinstellungen sehen will
und Energie ins Startmenü eintippe, dann gibt es da auf einmal mehrere Einzüge.
Das ist ja nichts Neues.
Mein Lieblingsbeispiel dafür ist immer noch der Icon-Auswahl-Dialog.
Und die Icons da drin.
Hier.
Direkt aus Windows 3.11 kommen die.
Da hat sich die letzten 15 Jahre nichts mehr getan hier.
Wird mir einmal das hier angezeigt, aber auch das hier.
Und bei der einen ist ausbalanciert angewählt, bei der anderen aber beste Energieeffizienz.
Ja, warum das unterschiedlich ist, aber Windows-Logik.
Effizienz, obwohl mir das auch ausbalanciert anbietet.
Hä?
Was ist denn jetzt das Richtige?
Wieso gibt es überhaupt zwei Menüs?
Und warum hält sich das eine Menü nicht dran, dass...
Warum gibt es da überhaupt zwei Menüs?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Warum gibt es, Leute, warum gibt es hier zwei Menüs?
Weil Windows absolut Schrott ist in diesem Punkt und immer schlimmer wird die letzten
Jahre über.
Wenn ich in Windows den Dark-Mode eingeschaltet habe, das ist das Windows-Feeling anno 2024.
Denn an ganz vielen Stellen denke ich mir so, wer hat das entschieden?
Also wer hat entschieden?
Ja, klar, so machen wir das, so will ich das haben.
Ja, und...
Ich glaube, es ist eher ein Fehlen von Entscheidungen.
In dem Fall, die machen halt neue Sachen, die haben, es hat noch keiner übergreifend
entschieden, dass das mal ordentlich angepasst werden muss.
Deswegen bin ich auch der Meinung, das beste, einheitlichste Windows, was sie je hinbekommen
haben, war Windows XP.
Das war wirklich wie aus einem Guss.
Und ich mochte ehrlich gesagt Windows, das Windows XP Design auch, das war nicht so kühl
und und businessmäßig.
Das das war bunt.
Und ja, angenehm.
Also, wenn mich einer fragt, was ich als das angenehmste Windows empfand von der Optik her
und auch von der Einheitlichkeit, dann würde ich eindeutig sagen Windows XP.
Tatsächlich beschweren sich ganz viele Leute darüber, dass sie von Windows genervt sind
und dass sie wegwollen von Windows.
Also so mäßig.
Jetzt steig ich aber wirklich um.
In diesem Video gucken wir uns das alles mal genauer an.
Also was jetzt eigentlich die genauen Problempunkte bei Windows sind.
Also, was jetzt eigentlich die genauen Problempunkte bei Windows sind.
sind und ob man das objektiv messen kann dass gerade viele leute wegwechseln ich glaube man
kann das objektiv mehr sind ich habe letztens eine umfrage gesehen oder keine umfrage ist
falsch eine auswertung von irgendeiner statistik seite das jetzt glaube ich fünf leute in 100
linux auf dem desktop verwenden also fünf prozent fünf in 100 bescheuerte ausgaben von windows und
wo die dann hingehen tatsächlich ist das wirklich ziemlich interessant bleibt dran
dieses video wird gesponsert von nord vpn pcs mit intel vipro und intel core ultra prozessoren
sind für eine effiziente nutzung der systemressourcen ausgelegt ich war noch nie in einer
wüste leute also seit dieser kanal hier existiert beschäftigen wir uns mit windows und man kann die
uhr danach stellen dass es immer wieder kommentare gibt in denen es heißt windows gut dass ich das
nicht mehr benutze oder so jetzt hat microsoft aber den bogen überspannt jetzt steige ich
wirklich um
und dann gibt es aber halt oft leute die sagen ja das sagt ihr seit 100 jahren dass ihr umsteigen
wollt macht ein nächstes jahr ist das jahr des linux des tops ich ich chat ich bin mir nicht
sicher als was zähle ich zähle ich als linux user oder zähle ich als windows user ich benutze halt
ich benutze halt beides ich benutze linux und windows sowohl auf dem desktop als auch auf dem
server sorry ich benutze linux sowohl auf dem desktop als auch auf dem server windows nur auf
dem desktop ich bin beides ja
mach das aber eh nicht ist doch alles nur gelaber also was stimmt jetzt aber erstmal warum passiert
das eigentlich frau und ich verdiene mit linux mein geld das dürft ihr auch nicht vergessen kann also
zumindest gefühlt zurzeit noch mehr leute als sonst über windows warum sie so doll genervt ja
und das haben wir euch mal gefragt ihr nämlich auf der community seite von unserem youtube-channel
community hier haben wir auf die frage 252 kommentare von euch community gern schulma dafür das war wirklich sehr aufschlag bei uns
die frage 252 kommentare von euch community gern also vielen dank schon mal dafür das war wirklich sehr aufschlag
dafür, das war wirklich sehr
aufschlussreich. Also ich habe das natürlich alles gelesen
und dann mal versucht, das in drei
Kategorien aufzuteilen, also
eure Kritik. Also Server habe ich
keine Windows-Server. Das
kommt mir nicht in die Tüte. Ich habe mir im Stream
zur Belustigung von euch
ja ab und zu schon mal Windows-Server
angeguckt und jedes Mal habe ich mir gedacht, wie
kann man sowas ernsthaft verwenden?
Das ist
Selbstpeinigung, ja, das ist wie
Auspeitschen Windows-Server.
Datenschutz und
Account-Zwang, ja, fuckt mich auch ab.
Erste Kategorie würde ich jetzt mal aufstellen, Datenschutz
Bedenken und Account-Zwang.
Also ganz klar, das Datenschutz-Thema
begleitet... Doch, auf der Arbeit bleibt mir glücklicherweise
was anderes übrig. Ich bin offiziell als
Linux
System-Engineer,
oder?
Linux System... Ach, ne,
Linux... Ich weiß noch nicht mal, was ich bin.
Zumindest nicht Windows.
Ich habe gehört, dass Mail unter Linux schlimm sein soll.
Nö.
Thunderbird, fertig.
Oder du benutzt Outlook.
Das ganze Office läuft wunderbar
im Browser mittlerweile.
Wenn man das selbst... Selbst-hosted
Mail ist immer Ultra-Paints-Champ
und würde ich nicht machen.
Ich benutze auch Thunderbird unter Windows.
Ich weiß gar nicht, also
wäre für mich überhaupt keine Umstellung.
...Windows, ja, seit
Jahrzehnten... Thunderbird, genau.
Immer wieder beklagen sich Leute darüber, dass Windows ihnen zu viel
nach Hause telefoniert. Und ja, dann
behelfen sie sich zum Beispiel mit so gemoddeten
Windows. Ja, das finde ich unsinnig.
Ganz ehrlich, das kommt mir nicht
in die Tüte. Da weiß ich nicht, was es macht,
was es sonst noch reinpatcht. Ja, ich weiß,
theoretisch kann man sich die Scripts durchlesen.
Nö, und dann... Also, wenn schon,
wenn schon, dann tatsächlich normal.
Aber es gibt halt viel, was abfuck ist.
...ReviewOS oder Tiny11,
dazu hatten wir ja schon ein eigenes Video gemacht.
Ob sowas langfristig hilft, oder ob man, wenn man...
Max, werden bei euch eigentlich gerade
Leute eingestellt? Ja, tatsächlich. Wir stellen
aktuell gerade einen ein,
aber das liegt daran, weil ein anderer
abhaut Ende des Jahres. Probleme hat
lieber gleich zu Linux wechselt, das ist...
Also bei mir, im Team, ne, so insgesamt
versicherungsweit
noch deutlich mehr. Andere Frage,
was aber definitiv in den Jahren
immer schlimmer geworden ist, ist der
Account-Zwang. Ja. Also, konnte man
bis vor kurzem einfach so eine Quatsch-Mail-Adresse
eingeben und schon ließ sich Windows
ohne Account installieren, geht das seit
ein paar Monaten nur noch mit
sehr, sehr großen Umfragen. Ja, Trick 17
geht man... Also, Windows,
Home, glaube ich, gar nicht mehr.
Bei Windows
11 Pro muss man entweder
das Terminal aufmachen und da
irgendwas mit OOB, sonst was, eingeben.
Oder man muss irgendwie
klicken, äh,
Account, und dann irgendwie...
Irgendwo kann man danach dreimal klicken, Offline-Account
sagen. Ja, okay, das kann ich auch wirklich gut
nachvollziehen, dass man davon genervt ist.
Vor allem, weil das ja jahrelang ohne Account
ging, und dann auf einmal einem diese...
Netzwerkverbindung deaktivieren, weiß ich nicht, ob das
noch geht, aber das ist nicht erforderlich. Das geht
auch anders. ...Möglichkeiten nicht mehr gegeben wird.
Zum Vergleich übrigens, macOS-Rechner
kann man problemlos ohne Account in Betrieb
nehmen, indem man bei der Apple-ID-Abfrage
einfach auf Später hinzufügen
klickt. Einige Sachen funktionieren
ohne Account dann allerdings nicht, zum Beispiel
Software-Updates aus dem App-Store, aber der
Rechner lässt sich zumindest betreiben.
Bei Linux ist das natürlich... Genau,
STRG-SHIFT-F2, macht das
die Konsole auf, ne?
Ehe kein Thema, da gibt's nicht mal Online-Accounts.
So, okay, alles schon so ein bisschen
ärgerlich, aber wir sind noch...
Ich sag mal so, im gelben Bereich.
Was uns, ich sag jetzt mal bewusst uns,
weil ich ein jahrzehntelanger
Windows-User bin, und mich
persönlich das auf jeden Fall doll
wütend gemacht hat, war das
Recall-Desaster. Ihr erinnert
euch wahrscheinlich. Dazu gab's ja auch ein Video.
Da hab ich auch schon oft genug was zu gesagt.
Und es ist genauso, oder es wird genauso kommen,
und es ist schon teilweise genauso kommen, wie ich gesagt hab, so
Hups, nee, nee, nee, nee, das
machen wir erstmal nicht, und
wenn überhaupt, dann nur deaktiviert
und Hups, jetzt ist es doch
standardmäßig an, genauso wie ich das
gesagt hab. Also Microsoft
hatte sich als großes neues
Feature... Ich finde, ich bin übrigens der Meinung,
sowas sollte defaultmäßig gar nicht dabei sein.
Ich hab kein Problem, wenn es sowas als
extra Software gibt, zum bewusst
nachinstallieren,
aber default im Betriebssystem, finde ich, sollte
so ne quasi Betriebssystem
eigenes Spyware einfach
nicht dabei sein.
Aus Bildschirminhalt und archiviert
das Ganze. Da KI ist das Ganze auch
als Bild durchsuchbar. Also man kann
zum Beispiel fragen, wann bestimmte Körperteile
zu sehen waren und bekommt...
Das hat er nicht genug geblurrt, dass man
nicht erkennen könnte, was da gerade abgeht, ne?
Das ist dann angezeigt.
Oder Erdbeeren. So, das kann man
jetzt praktisch finden, oder auch
nicht. Das Prinzip will ich hier jetzt gar nicht
beurteilen, aber was halt wirklich
unfassbar stümperhaft war, war die
Umsetzung. Also erstmal, dass die Funktion
so geplant war, dass sie
standardmäßig eingeschaltet ist.
Was? Hä? Also, dass solche Daten
sehr intim und schützenswert
sind, das liegt ja wirklich
auf der Hand. Nun waren in den
öffentlich zugänglichen Recall-Versionen
diese Daten rein gar nicht geschützt.
Die Bilder waren einfach JPEGs, alle
anderen Daten... Da freut sich
jeder Virus-Malware, den man sich sonst
einfängt. Der kann einfach
sich komplett alles anschauen
von der Person, inklusive
intimsten Sachen und
Logins und alles, was da
geinschottet wurde.
...lagen in einer unverschlüsselten
SQLite-3-Daten. Ja. Also
leichte Beute für alle, die an
einer Stelle richtig viel privates
Zeug über eine Person finden
wollen. Also, zugegeben, das waren
Vorab-Versionen. Nur kamen die
wirklich sehr, sehr kurz vor der
offiziellen Veröffentlichung der
Copilot-Plus-PCs raus. Also, man
darf auf jeden Fall bezweifeln, dass das
alles noch verbessert worden wäre.
Vor allem schon alleine, weil Microsoft
selbst komplett dann den
Stecker gezogen hat mit diesem
Recall-Feature, nachdem ein riesiger
Aufschrei durchs Netz ging und Microsoft
dann auch etliche zusätzliche
Sicherheitsfunktionen versprochen hat. Und vor allem
auch versprochen hat, dass die
Recall-Funktion opt-in... Ja, mal
abwarten, mal abwarten.
Wie gesagt, da bin ich skeptisch.
Das ist zufälligerweise dann in einem
Update standardmäßig aktiviert und Microsoft
sagt dann, oh, das war ja gar nicht so
gewollt. Beim nächsten Update ist es dann wieder
standardmäßig aus, wenn der Aufschrei zu groß ist
und sowas. Jaja.
Also, dass das nicht mehr standardmäßig
eingeschaltet ist, sondern man...
Ich glaub denen halt gar nichts.
Ja, ich will das haben. Für mich stellt sich da die Frage
und da haben wir auch in der CT-Redaktion
wirklich schon viel drüber diskutiert. Warum ist das
überhaupt Bestandteil von Windows, frag ich mich
da. Da sollte was zum Nachinstallieren
sein. Also, wer
winkt sowas durch? Also, bei Microsoft.
Wer denkt, ja klar, lass uns mal ein
Protokoll von allem, was
Leute auf ihrem privaten PC machen,
ungefragt und unverschlüsselt
abspeichern. Super gute Idee.
Machen wir so, klar. Also, das finde ich
auch wirklich einigermaßen gruselig, dass
da Leute in Entscheidungspositionen
offenbar gar kein Gefühl dafür haben,
was die Kunden... Äh, ja, das geht denen
am Arsch vorbei.
Das Einzige, was die sehen, ist,
damit kann man irgendwie Kohle machen.
...Kundschaft so will und
wie die Kundschaft so tickt. Und ja,
und da sind wir dann auch direkt bei der zweiten Kategorie,
Usability und
machen, was die Leute nicht wollen. Ja, das stimmt.
Ich hab hier die brandaktuelle Windows 11
24H2. Ich sag nur, ich sag,
nur, Windows 11 hat standardmäßig
die Taskleiste in der Mitte. Wollte
auch keiner. Standardmäßig konntest du
die Fenster nicht entgruppieren.
Standardmäßig unter Windows 11 war es so,
diese Fenster waren immer gruppiert.
Egal, was du gemacht hast.
...laufen und
wenn ich hier in die Energiespareinstellung
will, was ja durchaus etwas ist, was
häufiger vorkommt, also Energie
hier in das Suchfeld eintippe, dann
kommt zuerst Energiesparplan
auswählen und als zweites
Energie, Ruhezustand und Akku.
...Einstellung. Hä? Hm. Hm.
Klicke ich jetzt das erste an, dann werden mir erst mal
die Augen weggeblitzt, weil alles
weiß ist, obwohl ich Windows eigentlich im
Dark-Mode laufen habe. Ja, und... Okay, Chat,
das ist eine gute Sache hier. Chat,
das...
Post auf Twitter.
Jede Installation
von Windows 11
24H2
hat es installiert und es ist enabled.
No script, no custom
and just a fresh download von Microsoft.
...
Es ist genau das, was ich gesagt hab.
Das ist... Alter, das ist so
predictable schon.
Vielleicht kommt's auf die Region an, oder was?
Wie kann man das nachgucken?
So, hier.
...
Ich hab H2 noch nicht.
Ach so, okay, das geht
nur mit...
...
Routerechten. Wichtiger Schrott, ne?
Will den Scheiß nicht. Niemand will
den Scheiß haben. Bei dem anderen
mit den Energieeinstellungen, da
wird dann der Darkmode-Aufgabe
mit Augen weggeblitzt, weil alles
weiß ist. Ja gut, das ist halt
das Problem, dass das eben
unterschiedlichste UI-Technologien
aus den letzten 30 Jahren sind
und der Darkmode von Windows eben sich nur
auf UWP und neues
WinUI 3 und sonstige Sachen
erstreckt. Das ist halt dieses
Stückwerk, was man überall unter Windows
sieht.
Weil ich im Darkmode laufen habe. Ja und bei dem
anderen mit den Energieeinstellungen,
da wird dann der Darkmode auf einmal
beachtet. Was aber wirklich komisch ist,
dass hier in der dunklen Version steht,
ich wäre nicht im ausbalancierten Modus,
sondern in beste Energieeffizienz.
Bei dem anderen steht aber
ausbalanciert empfohlen.
Verwirrend? Ja, hundertprozentig
verwirrend. Was da passiert ist,
dass Windows 11 zwei komplett
unterschiedliche Systeme hat.
Einmal ein Jahrzehnte
altes und halt neues. Was man aber auch
braucht, weil das Neue nicht alles kann.
Man kann die Sachen ganz gut darin unterscheiden,
dass die einen halt den Darkmode
respektieren und die anderen halt nicht. Also hier
guckt man zum Beispiel der alte Taskmanager
und der neue und hier ist auch noch der alte
Gerätemanager mit diesem ganz alten
Windows 95 Icon. Also
alter Kram. Also ich kann die
Gedankengänge dahinter auch einigermaßen
verstehen. Also ich gehe mal davon aus,
dass die alten Menüs irgendwelche Funktionalitäten
haben, die die neuen nicht.
Oder noch nicht haben. Und falls
Leute die alten Funktionen brauchen,
sind die alten Menüs weiter im System.
Nun gäbe es aber ja durchaus die Möglichkeit,
die neuen Menüs erst zu
veröffentlichen, wenn sie die alten Funktionen
zu 100% ersetzen. Oder als
Workaround die alten Menüs im System
zumindest oberflächlich zu verstecken. Also
dass man die erst manuell anschalten muss, wenn man
die braucht. Ich würde nämlich denken, dass
das recht wenig Leute sind, die die alten Menüs
brauchen. Stattdessen ist es aber so,
dass wenn ich nach den Energieeinstellungen
suche, die alten zu
erst angezeigt werden. Ey, sorry,
das geht doch besser, oder? Genauso
wie dieser schreckliche Clickbait-Müll,
der seit Jahren auf der
App-Startseite und hier nach einem
Klick auf das Wetter-Icon hier unten links
kommt. Ja, dieses Wetter, das check ich immer noch
nicht. Wer diese Widgets,
gibt es irgendjemand, der diese komischen
Widgets verwendet?
Das haben sie ja groß angekündigt damals bei
Windows 11, wo sie fast geheult haben in der
Präsentation. Die haben ja
fast geweint in der Präsentation, so
emotional war die Windows 11-Vorstellung.
Damals. Könnt ihr euch auch dran erinnern?
Wo ich auch gedacht habe, den Scheiß werde ich halt
genau einmal deaktivieren und nie mehr benutzen.
Bitte. Putin lässt
Atombombe über London
fliegen? Kein Clickbait. Nein, nein,
nein, nein. What? Also
in Wahrheit war im russischen Fernsehen
irgendeine Animation zu sehen von einer Atombombe.
Sorry, aber das ist einfach
nicht lustig. Stellt euch mal eine Person
vor, die vielleicht nicht so medienkompetent
ist, vielleicht auch ein bisschen ängstlich ist.
Und die startet ihren Browser und dann
poppt sowas auf. Ist nicht gut, oder?
Und eine Medienplattform, die solche Überschriften
veröffentlicht, die sollten sofort
aus diesem Feed rausfliegen.
Und ja klar, das kann man alles manuell
anpassen. Aber das ist ja keine Geschmacksfrage,
sondern das sind objektiv Lügen,
die nur dafür sorgen sollen, dass
Leute irgendwo hinklicken. Und wenn
jetzt jemand ankommt, dass bei 2003
auch manchmal so ein bisschen baitige
Thumbnails sind, sorry, das ist wirklich
nochmal eine ganz andere Kategorie. Ja, das stimmt.
Übrigens ist das kein rein deutsches Problem, sondern
ein internationales. Weil auf Reddit
beschweren sich ziemlich viele
Leute über den Müll. Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher,
niemand will solche
Meldungen sehen, oder? Microsoft,
fragt doch die Leute einfach mal, was die sich wünschen.
Oder interessiert euch das womöglich gar nicht?
Das ist denen scheißegal.
Windows ist mittlerweile ein
Nebenprodukt bei Microsoft, bin ich mir eigentlich
relativ sicher.
Plattformen für eure anderen Kosten.
Die haben zum größten Teil
ihre Abo-Services und Cloud-Geschichten
im Kopf. Pflichtigen Produkte.
Tja, das wäre dann auch direkt die Überleitung
zum dritten Themenblock, nämlich,
Bloatware und Werbung.
Das habt ihr nämlich auch sehr häufig kommentiert,
dass Windows an jeder Ecke irgendwas
verkaufen will. Zum Beispiel hier in der
vorinstallierten Xbox-App.
Wollen sie halt so ein Abo verkaufen. Oder hier
im vorinstallierten Videoschnittprogramm
Clipchamp. Da gehen auch...
Der Name ist gut von dem
Programm. Das muss ich Microsoft lassen,
Clipchamp. Viele Sachen
nur mit Premium-Abo.
Das einem da ständig...
Man könnte fast denken, wir hätten den Clipchamp
entwickelt.
Was?
Von der Benahmung.
Kostenpflichtiger Extra-Kram angedreht wird,
passiert auch nicht nur im laufenden Betrieb.
Nein, schon bei der Installation
wird man damit die ganze Zeit
vollgeschwallert. Okay, das sind jetzt
vielleicht keine super schlimmen Probleme,
aber es wirkt halt einfach extrem billig
und auch ein bisschen unseriös.
Ich meine, das ist ja mein Betriebssystem.
Das ist meine Kommandozentrale.
Da will ich keine Werbung...
Will man wirklich, dass sein OS aussieht wie AliExpress?
...Gradmenü haben.
So, und jetzt die ganz große Frage.
Sind diese ganzen Sachen jetzt wirklich dazu,
dass Leute zu Linux oder
MacOS wechseln? Kann man das irgendwie...
Ganz ehrlich, wisst ihr, was ich glaube?
Die Schwelle ist noch nicht ganz erreicht.
Ja, es wechseln mehr.
Es ist mehr geworden in letzter Zeit.
Aber ich glaube, die kritische Schwelle ist noch
nicht erreicht. Das staut
sich aber immer mehr auf bei den Leuten.
Und ich glaube, es wird irgendwann die
nächsten Jahre, wie gesagt, nächstes Jahr,
ist garantiert das Jahr
des Linux-Desktops, so wie letztes Jahr
und dieses Jahr auch.
Wird so dieser Damm brechen, glaube ich.
Und dann wirst du noch irgendwelche
Mainstream-Channels sehen, die sonst
gar nichts mit Linux am Hut haben auf YouTube.
So nach dem Motto, ich spiele jetzt unter Linux
und sowas. Das wird dann so ein
Hype-Phänomen werden,
dass die Leute sagen,
fuck Windows.
Das Problem ist die Game...
Ja, das stimmt. Das stimmt schon.
Ich habe ja da auch ein Video zugemacht.
Linux ist kein Ersatz für Windows.
Da habe ich auch ein Video zugemacht, wo es genau
unter anderem um solche...
Hallo? Was ist mit meinem Broser?
Hallo Leute, hier ist...
Was browset der so?
Hier. Habe ich auch ein Video zugemacht.
Das haben tatsächlich sogar relativ viele Leute geguckt.
Also, ja, Max hat ein Video zugemacht.
Ich bin ja der Wobblos, ja.
Also, Link, okay.
Also, ich habe da ja auch ein Video zugemacht,
wo ich genauso diese Probleme auch anspreche
mit den Games und sowas.
Aber, das wird immer besser.
Es ist natürlich noch nicht perfekt.
Gerade wenn es um Anti-Cheat geht,
ist es halt nicht usable.
Aber nicht jeder möchte jetzt,
sagen wir mal, Rainbow Six oder
LOL oder sowas spielen.
Und ich glaube, dass
mit zunehmendem Druck
der Leute,
dass sie von Windows weg wollen
und auch teilweise
weggehen und so,
dass der Druck auf die Hersteller,
dass das eben ordentlich funzen muss,
unter Linux höher wird.
Da kommt ein bisschen das Problem rein,
was Linux hat,
dass es bei Linux eben vieles
nicht sonderlich einheitlich ist.
Guckt euch das Desaster an,
wenn es um irgendwelche Wayland-Geschichten geht,
wer jetzt an welcher Stelle was machen muss.
So nach dem Motto,
Fenster, die aus anderen Fenstern gestartet werden,
sollen ein eigenes Icon haben.
Ja, wer macht das jetzt?
Muss es der Desktop implementieren?
Muss das ins Wayland-Protokoll?
Wo muss das hier und jenes und sonst wie?
Und hast du nicht gesehen?
Oder guckt euch das Elend an
mit Video-Decoding im Browser.
Video-Decoding im Browser
ist halt wirklich so ein Ding,
dass man sich nicht mehr so ein bisschen
Das geht unter Windows und wahrscheinlich Mac
seit 15 Jahren oder so schon
und unter Linux funktioniert es
jetzt gerade mal so halbwegs
und auch nicht mit allen Codecs.
Das geht nur, wenn du das richtige
Zusammenspiel hast aus den richtigen
Grafikkartentreiber,
den richtigen Mesa-Treibern,
der richtigen Browser-Version,
dann theoretisch noch
der richtigen Plugins im Browser,
weil du brauchst teilweise Plugins,
die H.264 forsten und nicht VP9
oder irgendwas anderes, weil das dann zufällig
mit deiner Kombination unter Linux
nicht funktioniert.
Das ist tatsächlich
gar nicht so einfach.
Das ist halt so ein bisschen
der Wildwuchs, der ist, das sage ich ja im Video auch,
das ist einmal
der große Vorteil
von Linux.
Allerdings gerade für Hersteller, die einfach
nur wollen, dass es auf möglichst vielen
Plattformen oder auf möglichst vielen
Endgeräten einfach funktioniert,
für die ist das kacke.
Was Mesa ist,
Mesa ist eine Implementierung
oder ist so quasi die Referenz oder Basis
oder wie auch immer man das nennt,
Implementierung von OpenGL,
Vulkan und
Zeug für
Linux.
Ja.
Also die ganzen Grafik-Schnittstellen
sind von Mesa.
Also diese Low-Level-Grafik-Schnittstellen,
die sind von Mesa
und
Mesa stellt auch
irgendwelche, fragt mich nicht genau,
irgendwelche anderen Schnittstellen
sonst noch zur Verfügung, aber
hauptsächlich ist Mesa die
Implementierung unter Linux von OpenGL
und Vulkan und sowas.
Konsole ist auch nicht die Lösung.
Konsole ist einfach Casual-Shit.
Sage ich als langjähriger
Konsolen-Only-Spieler, ja.
Da wäre so von 2000,
das war, als ich auf YouTube angefangen habe,
habe ich fast ausschließlich Xbox gespielt.
Moment, das ist mal in meinem Video.
Quantifizieren.
Und ja, das kann man offenbar.
Hier ein Diagramm von Statista
mit den Marktanteilen von Desktop-Betriebssystemen.
Ja, genau, genau, genau.
Das ist ja, du sagst es ja im Prinzip
auch gerade, das, was ich schon angesprochen habe,
das ist natürlich bei weitem nicht das Einzige.
Ja, es gibt auch noch
die proprietären Treiber von Nvidia, AMD
macht, ich blicke da auch ehrlich gesagt
nicht mehr durch, wer da jetzt wie, wo, was macht.
Du kannst ja auch, du hast drei verschiedene, also
am einfachsten fährst du unter Linux,
wenn du einfach nur willst, dass es funktioniert, tatsächlich
mit einer Intel-GPU,
der krampft uns in der Regel einfach
out of the box, weil Intel, was
Open-Source-Treiber angeht, ziemlich weit
vorne mit dabei ist. Leider sind halt
die Intel-GPUs performance-mäßig
scheißen die halt ab gegen eine ordentliche
AMD- oder Nvidia-GPU.
Aber gerade diese
Anti-Cheat-Geschichte und sowas, ich könnte
mir durchaus vorstellen, wenn der Druck
da von User-Seite
höher wird mit Linux, wird
sich da auch was tun.
Die Frage ist bloß, ob bewusste,
sicherheitsbewusstere
Linux-User allen
Ernstes sich Rootkit-like
Anti-Cheat-Sachen
auf den Rechner packen
lassen. Ja, genau,
manche Sachen gehen nicht. AMD
hatte viel Probleme mit HDMI, das
habe ich auch letztens irgendwo gelesen, ja.
Da sind Kleinigkeiten,
das ist übrigens das, was ich in meinem Video auch erzähle,
sind oftmals auch Kleinigkeiten.
Und, ganz ehrlich, meiner Meinung nach
das Wichtigste ist,
bei der Frage,
komme ich mit Linux klar
anstelle von Windows, das Wichtigste
ist, wie man da rangeht.
Und zwar, man darf nicht rangehen,
dass, man steigt
jetzt auf Linux um und das löst alle die
Probleme, die man mit Windows hatte. Das stimmt nämlich
nicht. Man muss einem klar sein,
es ist ein komplett anderes Betriebssystem
und es ist
kein Windows-Ersatz
in dem Sinn. Es ist nicht so, dass man sagen kann,
ich habe dann Windows, nur ohne
die Sachen, die mich nerven an Windows.
Es ist genau das Gegenteil. Es ist nicht
Windows und man muss auch mit dem
Mindset, wie man das so schön nennt heutzutage,
daran gehen, dass das nicht
Windows ist. Man darf zum Beispiel
keine Angst davor haben, auch mal einen Terminal
aufzumachen und da was reinzutippen.
Auch wenn vieles über das UI geht,
früher oder später muss man
mal irgendwelche Sachen tweaken,
fixen, sonst was,
weil die eben noch nicht so out of the box funktionieren.
Du landest früher oder später.
Wenn du
ein ernsthafter Desktop-User
bist und dann auch mal ein bisschen mehr machst, als immer nur
einen Browser auf, landest du früher
oder später im Terminal und das Ding ist halt,
das hört sich immer so an, als wäre das was
Negatives. Das ist aber nichts Negatives, weil
man dieses Scheißding hier
das alte
Terminal und Batch null
vergleichen kann mit einem ordentlichen Terminal
und ZSH oder Bash unter Linux.
Das Terminal unter Linux ist was Gutes,
das Terminal unter Windows ist Shit.
Deswegen haben die Leute da so Abneigung
dagegen. Da muss man halt auch
weg von kommen. Man muss
wirklich rangehen daran,
wenn man das erste Mal Windows benutzt hat
quasi. Klar, die ein oder anderen Sachen kann man
transferieren. Man muss damit rangehen,
das ist ein neues System, was ich noch nicht kenne,
wo ich nicht sagen kann, oh, das ist
quasi wie Windows und ohne die
Probleme von Windows. Das ist ein eigenes
Betriebssystem mit eigenen Regeln, an die man
sich gewöhnen muss. Und dann kommt man damit auch
klar. Ja, das ist
auch so. Es gibt kaum was
abartiges als Windows CM,
das ist die alte Windows CM, das alte
Windows CMD Fenster und Batch.
Mittlerweile hast du PowerShell, wobei
man halt auch sagen muss, PowerShell.
PowerShell,
da hast du recht, ja, aber PowerShell
ist halt not even close
zu dem, als interaktiv.
Ich rede hier nicht von Automatisierung
und Skripting-Umgebung, als interaktive
Shell, wie beispielsweise ordentlich
eingerichtete ZSH.
Das ist einfach viel
angenehmer. PowerShell ist ein gutes Skripting
und Bastel-Umgebung, aber keine Daily
Daily, ich benutze das Shell.
Welchen Window Manager? Gar keiner, das ist
i3-WM, der hat keine Fenster. Okay,
die streng genommen hat man schon Fenster, aber
die haben noch nicht mal Fenster drumherum.
Floating Windows hat das. Also, by the way,
ich use Arch.
Kommt fast fetch, für die coolen Leute.
Ich use Arch, by the way, das ist wichtig.
Generell, wenn ihr Linux benutzt, müsst ihr
regelmäßig der Welt mitteilen, dass ihr
Linux benutzt.
Und vor allem, wenn ihr Arch-Linux
verwendet, ist es enorm wichtig, der Welt mitzuteilen,
dass ihr Arch-Linux verwendet.
Ich würde sagen, so alle
dreieinhalb Minuten muss das sein.
Boah, oh nee, eine Suse, Alter.
Suse, hör mal bloß auf.
Wie kann man ernsthaft
Suse? Aber das soll jeder
verwenden, was ihm gefällt.
Das ist i3-WM, was ich hier habe.
In der 4M, by the way.
Das ist i3-WM. Ah ja, und hier
übrigens auch die, also
Unreal
Engine kann einpacken.
Aber immerhin 3000 FPS.
Massive
Coggers, ja.
Also, ich bin noch auf
X.org.
Weil
in der 4M
gibt es ziemlich große Probleme
mit Wayland.
Da kann man sich jetzt auch wieder streiten, woran es liegt.
Ja, an Wayland selber,
also an der Spezifikation,
an den Leuten, die die Spezifikation
implementieren, liegt es an 4M,
den Grafiktreibern, keine Ahnung.
Ist mir ehrlich gesagt auch scheißegal. Ich will einfach,
dass es funktioniert.
Und funktioniert aber nicht richtig.
Was funktioniert
ist tatsächlich, was funktioniert ist KDE,
und Gnome auf Wayland-Basis
in der 4M.
Aber
alles andere kannst du vergessen.
Also, wer mal beispielsweise versucht hat, Hyperland
oder sowas zu betreiben in der 4M, vergesst es einfach.
Wenigstens
funktioniert der Maus-Cursor
mittlerweile unter Wayland in der 4M.
Das ursprüngliche
Problem unter Wayland in der 4M war, dass
ich 0 FPS hatte.
Das heißt, der Screen hat nie refreshed.
Cinnamon, weiß ich nicht.
Cinnamon selbst läuft doch gar nicht unter Wayland.
Das ist doch die Sache von Mint.
Und das ist schon seit ewig nur unter X
verfügbar.
Excellent. Ja. Mooncure. Sehe ich auch so.
Schön, dass du am Start bist.
Nee, Hyperland hat doch nicht richtig
funktioniert. Spätestens, wenn man irgendwas
drin... Zum Laufen hab ich auch bekommen.
Aber wenn man da was drin gestartet hat, ist es gecrashed.
Ja. Zumindest
wichtigste ist, wenn man
an die Sache rangeht, umzusteigen,
dass man da mit dem
Hintergedanken drangeht, dass es eben
ein anderes Betriebssystem ist und andere
dass es anders
funktioniert und andere Regeln gelten als unter
Windows.
Da kommt man damit auch klar.
Bei manchen Sachen beißt man einfach in
wie nennt man das so? Rennt man gegen eine Wand?
Ja, manche Sachen hast du einfach keine Chance.
Wenn du aktuelle Spiele mit Anti-Cheat
spielen willst, die Linux nicht unterstützen.
Weiß ich nicht. Was gibt's denn da hier?
Rainbow Six, Fortnite, LOL.
Bei CS weiß ich's gar nicht, wie es ist.
Valve ist da ja immer recht gut
dabei, Linux zu unterstützen. Keine Ahnung, wie's
bei CS 2 aussieht.
Valorant, Funst
auch nicht. Wobei Valorant weiß ich nicht, Valorant wird
anders funktionieren. Also ich weiß, dass
zum Beispiel Fortnite und
Rainbow Six und LOL und so kannst du eigentlich komplett
knicken.
Also gerade so, gerade die, das ist halt auch das Ding.
Es sind vielleicht von der Anzahl her
nicht
super viele Games, die so
große Probleme haben, aber es sind
Games, die halt ne Riesenmasse
an Spielern haben.
Das hat ja auch kein, wahrscheinlich
kein Rootkit-Level,
Anti-Cheat.
Ja, genau, genau, das ist halt das Problem.
Das wird halt unter Linux auch nicht funzen.
Aber ich denke, wenn der
Druck von User
Fortnite funktioniert, nein,
Fortnite funktioniert unter Linux gar nicht. Fortnite funktioniert nur
unter Windows. Fortnite, durch den Anti-Cheat kannst du
knicken. Du kannst gucken hier übrigens,
wenn du wissen willst, wie gut
Sachen funktionieren, kannst du hier mal schauen.
Fortnite
steht noch nicht mal drinnen.
Hab ich das überhaupt richtig geschrieben?
Ja.
Das steht noch nicht mal drinnen.
Warum auch immer.
Achso, wahrscheinlich, weil es das nicht auf Steam gibt.
Kann das sein?
Wie sieht es mit League of Legends aus?
Ja, okay, da stehen nur die Sachen drin, die es auf Steam gibt.
Aber kannst du knicken, ja.
Brocken.
Borkt.
Also, da hast du halt Probleme mit Anti-Cheat.
Der Rest,
ganz ehrlich, ist
eigentlich mittlerweile
ganz okay.
Okay,
das Einzige, was mir noch einfällt,
davon abhalten können, Linux zu verwenden, ist halt, wenn die
irgendwelche super expensive
Business Enterprise Software
einsetzen, die es vielleicht nur für
Windows oder Mac gibt.
Ja, die Leute, die wirklich unbedingt
Native Photoshop
benutzen wollen oder sowas vielleicht.
Aber, wie gesagt,
ich glaube, der Druck der User
wird immer größer. Gerade durch den Scheiß
sind Microsoft-Veranstalter die letzten Jahre
über. Gehen wir mal kurz zurück
und gucken uns das Video fertig an.
Multi-Monitor 4K.
Ja, das stimmt, unter Linux hast du auch
mit High-DPI-Displays
unter manchen Oberflächen ein bisschen
Probleme. Ja, es gibt
so ein paar Kleinigkeiten.
Aber deshalb die Frage,
sind störend, und das ist eine individuelle
Frage, die kann man nicht so pauschal für
jeden beantworten.
Sind diese Kleinigkeiten unter Linux, oder halt
die Probleme unter Linux, wiegen die mehr
als der Abfuck unter Windows? Das muss man
sich halt letztendlich überlegen.
Und für viele Leute ist die Antwort aktuell anscheinend
noch ja, oder auch
der Aufwand, sich damit zu beschäftigen, dass sie
lieber Windows benutzen. Ich bin für meinen
Teil darauf hängen geblieben, ich benutze einfach beides
parallel. Linux hier,
Windows da.
Und da fahre ich seit Jahren schon ganz gut mit.
Oder MacOS wechseln.
Kann man das irgendwie quantifizieren?
Und ja, das kann man offenbar.
Hier ein Diagramm von Statista
mit den Marktanteilen von Desktop-Betriebssystemen.
Also Desktop-Betriebssysteme
schließen natürlich Notebooks mit ein.
Ist das Windows?
Och, guck mal, wie das
runtergeht. Das ist ja, das ist ja
krass. Guck mal, wie Windows runtergeht. Seht ihr das?
Hier ein Diagramm von Statista.
Das da unten ist was?
Da ist jetzt dieser dumme
Balken drüber. Dankeschön,
YouTube. Nice.
Jetzt wirklich dazu, dass Leute
zu Linux oder MacOS wechseln.
Kann man das irgendwie quantifizieren?
Ich will mal gucken, was da unten für ein Datum steht.
Hier ein Diagramm von Statista.
Guck mal, 2009 hatte Windows fast
100%. Und das ist auch das, wo
sie angefangen haben, so langsam,
aber sicher. Da kam man dann,
irgendwann Windows 7 raus
und dann kam dieses verkackte
Windows 8. Und das ist immer weiter runtergegangen.
Guck mal, die sind nur noch,
das muss man sich mal mitnehmen, die sind nur noch bei
75% auf dem Desktop.
Die meisten
wechseln zu Mac, ja klar. Aber
auch Linux geht.
Gerade die letzten Jahre. Und das, Leute,
ich sag euch eins, das haben wir zum größten
Teil, wo hab ich ihn,
zu verdanken.
Letztendlich mit dem Steam Deck
haben sie versucht, aus ihren Bemühungen,
was Proton
und Linux Gaming angeht, ein bisschen Geld zu machen.
Ist ja nichts Verwerfliches dran. Ist ja auch ein ganz
gutes Produkt geworden.
Es haben wir zum größten Teil
Gaben zu verdanken, ist meine Meinung.
Dass das
hier, ab hier
dieser leichte,
dass das dann
abhebt. Die Jahre davor ging nix,
aber dann hier, so mit dem Steam Deck
und Gaming unter Linux.
Mit den Marktanteilen
von Desktop-Betriebssystemen.
Desktop-Betriebssysteme schließen natürlich
Notebooks mit ein. Ja, und im Januar
2009 hatte Windows noch einen
weltweiten Marktanteil von über
95%. Und der ist
über die Jahre einfach immer kleiner.
Ja, Microsoft hat halt verschissen.
Im Juli 2024 waren es dann nämlich nur noch
72,1%. Linux steht
auf 4,4%.
Ich bin super gespannt, wie das die nächsten Jahre
weitergeht. Ich sag's euch,
es wird irgendwann dieser Kipppunkt
kommen. Man kann, ich weiß,
jedes Jahr ist der Jahr des Linux-Desktops,
es zeichnet sich langsam ab, der Frust
bei Windows ist immer mehr aufgestaut
und die Leute wollen
eigentlich Linux verwenden. Viele wollen.
Sie können aus einzelnen Gründen
nicht. Und der Druck auf die Hersteller
wird da auch immer größer.
Irgendwann wird so dieser Damm brechen
und es wird auch auf Mainstream-YouTube-Channels
kommen, so nach dem Motto,
die sonst mit so Technik und Sachen
gar nix zu tun haben, so
hey, ich bin jetzt auf Linux umgestiegen, funktioniert alles
gut. Ja, und spätestens wenn
Kronk Linux-Benutzer
nutzt, dann
bricht der Damm, Alter. Dann wird,
wobei ich weiß gar nicht, ob Kronk überhaupt noch so
angesagt ist. Fällt mir jetzt einfach nur als größter
Let's Player da ein in Deutschland.
Dann ist vorbei.
14,9%.
Ja, vor allem die Linux-Zahlen finde ich
überraschend, weil man hier wirklich sehen kann, dass
das vor allem in den letzten Jahren
stark wächst, was eventuell mit den
Fortschritten beim Linux-Gaming
zu tun hat. Also von 1,9%
Das hat auf jeden Fall Fortschritt.
Das ist seit Steam Deck und Gaben am Start.
Im Januar
2021 sieht man hier
in nur drei Jahren. Für die allermeisten
Casual-User wird das Betriebssystem keine Rolle spielen.
Genau deswegen ist es wichtig,
oder genau deswegen wird so ein
wird der Damm brechen, wenn so Leute
wie, ich nehme jetzt einfach mal Kronk als Beispiel,
wenn da wirklich, wenn der mal wirklich
sagt, ey Leute, ich bin jetzt auf Linux umgestiegen
und es funktioniert gut.
Weil es die meisten Casual-User null juckt.
Deutliche Verdopplung
auf über 4%.
Die MacOS-Nutzung ist bis 2020
ziemlich gut.
Sie ist ziemlich stark gestiegen auf über 18%.
Zuletzt aber wieder etwas gesunken
und ist aktuell auf ungefähr 15%.
Wenn ihr euch fragt, woher kommen diese Zahlen?
Ja, die sind von StatCounter,
so einem Zähldienst für Websites.
Kann man da einbinden. Ja, und die veröffentlichen
jeden Monat solche Zahlen.
Da kann man sich das auch alles nochmal genauer aufschlüsseln
lassen, zum Beispiel für Deutschland.
Danach sind hierzulande die Linux-Zahlen
sogar etwas besser als weltweit.
Was man aber auch bedenken muss, natürlich
verzeichnet nicht jede Website
StatCounter-Zahlen, sondern laut
Wikipedia sind das nur 0,9%
aller Websites. Also diese Zahlen
sind natürlich durch. Und man muss sich halt auch mal angucken,
welche Webseiten das sind.
Beispielsweise auf Heise. Heise hat auch öfter
so Statistiken. Da sind die Linux-User
viel mehr vertreten. Was aber auch
daran liegt, das ist halt eine Technik- und IT-News-Seite
und das Lesen zum größten Teil Technik-Interessierte
und Technik-Interessierte haben natürlich
auch überdurchschnittlich oft
Linux am Start.
Muss man halt mal genau gucken.
... aus mit Vorsicht zu genießen.
Mein Fazit. Ganz klar,
viele Leute sind frustriert mit Windows.
Das hat ja auch unsere Umfrage hier bei
2003 gezeigt. Und ich bin
auch unzufrieden. Und das kommt hier jetzt nicht
aus einer stumpfen Hater-Richtung, sondern
das habe ich ja schon mehrfach in den Videos hier gesagt,
ich benutze schon sehr lange Windows und
mochte Windows auch immer. Ich habe aber
wirklich in letzter Zeit, also wie ihr auch,
das Gefühl, dass Microsoft da
ihr eigenes Ding macht und wir User
irgendwie nicht mehr so wichtig sind. Also,
wenn jemand von Microsoft das hier sieht
und erklären kann, wie dieser
Clickbait in der Startleiste,
die sich widersprechenden Menüs oder
das Recall-Desaster zustande
gekommen sind, also sprecht mich gerne an,
freue ich mich drüber, schreibt mir eine Mail
an 3003.ct.de
und vielleicht gibt es da ja eine gute Erklärung dafür.
So, aber das Gefühl...
Wie gesagt, meine Meinung nach ist die Erklärung dafür
nicht, dass die Entscheidungen bewusst
getroffen wurden, sondern dass nie explizit
eine Entscheidung getroffen wurde, dass
man das eben nicht so machen will, dass
man das jetzt endlich mal vereinheitlicht. Ich glaube,
das ist einfach wieder zig Microsoft
Teams basteln so vor sich hin und stückeln,
sich in Windows zusammen, ohne dass eine
übergeordnete Position mal sagt, Leute,
wir brauchen jetzt irgendwie mal so ein Windows-mit-einheitlich-Projekt.
...jetzt durch
Windows 11 und Recall und so,
das fast bei den Windows-Fans
übergelaufen ist und die jetzt
alle in Scharen umsteigen.
Das lässt sich zumindest mit den
Stat-Counter-Zahlen nicht belegen. Was die
Zahlen aber zeigen, dass die Nutzung von
Windows seit Jahren permanent und langsam
aber sicher sinkt.
Dass vor allem Linux auch langsam aber
sicher immer mehr genutzt wird.
Ich bin wirklich gespannt, wie das weitergeht und
auch, ob Linux die letzten Problemfelder
lösen kann. Also zum Beispiel, dass viele
Spiele mit Anti-Cheat nicht laufen oder
halt auch keine Adobe-Programme.
Das wird auf jeden Fall noch interessant. Wie seht ihr das?
Gerne in die Kommentare. Ich glaube, das
ist ein Problem, das muss Linux nicht lösen.
An der Stelle. Das ist wirklich was, was die
Hersteller lösen müssen. Linux kann
da natürlich mithelfen, indem sie
vielleicht versuchen,
nicht mal ganz so abfuck und
ähm, tja,
kleinteilig
zu sein.
Man muss sich nur mal
ein paar Diskussionen angucken.
Also die Leute sind da teilweise auch schon
sehr unangenehm mit denen
zu reden und zu sprechen und
zu interagieren.
Ihr habt bestimmt alle mitbekommen,
die Diskussion gerade mit
BcacheFS, wobei sich das hauptsächlich
im Kernel-Umfeld abspielt. Da kriegen Normalsterbliche
nichts von mit.
Oder letztens diese Präsentation
Rust im Linux-Kernel und der Typ, der das
nicht wollte und sowas. Also,
da sind schon, da gibt es schon, ich sag mal,
eine Menge unangenehmer Leute,
wo ich verstehe, dass da vielleicht
auch Unternehmen da keinen Bock
drauf haben. Aber letztendlich,
wenn der Druck von den Usern
da ist, muss sich
das und wird sich das
über kurz oder lang lösen.
Wie kann man
kein Rust im Kernel wollen? Du musst
dir den Konferenztalk angucken.
Die haben da eine Viertelstunde diskutiert,
quasi mit dem Präsentator
über, das ist,
Cringe, ich konnte mir das gar nicht komplett
am Stück angucken, so Fremdschämen
musste ich mich bei.
Was natürlich auch passieren
könnte, Leute, und das hätte ich
vor ein paar Jahren noch als komplette
Science-Fiction oder gar
Verschwörungstheorie
abgetan, was natürlich aber auch passiert,
aber mittlerweile halte ich
das nicht mehr für ganz ausgeschlossen,
das ist,
wenn Windows tatsächlich
ein vollwertiges Linux bekommt.
Und ich meine damit jetzt nicht
WSL, sondern quasi noch einen
Schritt weiter, dass du
quasi das nicht mehr auseinanderhalten
kannst.
Nicht, dass wirklich Windows
auf einmal jetzt den Linux-Kernel verwendet,
aber was in der Richtung.
Vor ein paar Jahren hätte ich gesagt, komplett ausgeschlossen
wird nicht passieren, aber nachdem
Microsoft Windows immer mehr als
Nebenprodukt betrachtet,
hauptsächlich auf ihre
Services schielt, sei es
Cloud-Dienste, Office und alle möglichen
Abo-Sachen,
ist das ein Ding, wo ich sagen würde,
das halte ich nicht mehr für
komplett ausgeschlossen.
Ja und ich meine, sie wäre nicht das erste
große OS mit einem
Unix-Style-Kernel drunter.
Bei macOS ist es
genauso und bei der Playstation
ist es auch schon so.
Sowohl macOS als auch Playstation basieren,
oder das Playstation OS basieren weiter auf
FreeBSD.
Ist jetzt natürlich ein bisschen
an den Haaren herbeigezogener Vergleich, das gebe ich zu.
Welche
Situationen, äh, boah, Chatge,
hatte jemand von euch
zufälligerweise am Start
äh, Kernel
Rust Presentation
keine Ahnung, es gab
letztens eine Konferenz, die müsste ich
suchen, die hatten wir irgendwann auch hier mal offen.
Äh, Rust
äh, keine Ahnung.
Da gab es dann eine Riesendiskussion, quasi
auf, äh, mit dem Präsentator
und dann, das war super cringe zum angucken.
Wo die streiten, genau, ja,
die, die, die, die
Linux-Leute, beziehungsweise
der Linux-Kernel-Rust-Typ
mit dem Linux-Kernel-C-Typ.
Gibt's auch
viele Diskussionen auf der Linux-Mailing-Liste,
aber das, das Cringigste war echt
diese Präsentation.
Finde das jetzt grad nicht mehr.
Was ist das hier?
Ja, ja, genau.
Genau.
Die, die dann irgendwie da eine halbe...
Das ist super cringe.
Also, wer sich das angucken will, kann sich das angucken.
Wir gucken uns das jetzt hier an.
Im Prinzip geht's hier auf,
geht's hier um Rust im Linux-Kernel
und sonst was. Und da wird halt
permanent aus dem Publikum
reindiskutiert. Das ist wirklich super,
ultra, ultra, guck mal, die sind immer noch
am gleichen, die sind immer noch am gleichen Slide.
Immer noch am gleichen Slide.
...
Ich finde, dass es auf dem Konferenztalk sich nicht gehört,
den Konferenztalk komplett mit irgend so nem Shit zu hijacken.
Guck mal, der Typ, der Typ kommt einfach in dieser Präsentation nicht über diese zwei Slides raus.
Das kann man ja machen.
Aber nicht wirklich
eine Präsentation zu hijacken mit so nem Scheiß, ja.
Die Zerstörung von Windows, gut.
Ah, Moment, wir haben das Video noch gar nicht fertig, keck, wait.
... schreiben, wir lesen alles.
Achso, achso, achso, ich hab noch was.
Ich verkaufe meinen privat gekauften PC,
den ich live on air Ende 2019 bei CT Uplink zusammengebaut habe.
Das ist übrigens auch der PC, auf dem die ersten 3003-Videos geschnitten worden sind.
Ja, und gut, kann er ja mal machen.
Das ist auch für einen guten Zweck.
Also laut Ebay ist die Kiste noch mindestens...
... 600 Euro wert.
Ich will nur noch 400 Euro dafür haben und den Rest würde ich spenden.
Ja, und wenn ihr mehr als 600 Euro bieten wollt, dann...
Siehste, ich verkaufe keine Rechner und ich schmeiße keine Rechner weg.
Ich rotiere die nur durch und der quasi vorletzte Rechner,
ich habe immer die letzten zwei hier neben mir stehen,
also den aktuellen und den davor neben mir stehen,
einmal als Vorschau-Rechner und einmal als Main-Rechner
und danach kommt er einfach auf den Dachboden.
Die letzten, wobei, ich hab mir so wenig Rechner gekauft,
so viele sind da eigentlich gar nicht auf dem Dachboden.
Ich meine, den letzten Rechner hatte ich fünf Jahre,
muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Und den hier habe ich jetzt auch schon wieder zwei Jahre.
Ich habe den Ende 2022 zusammengebaut.
Aber Ende 2022, da sehe ich, ohne Scheiß, Leute,
man sieht mal, wie langsam die aktuelle Hardware-Entwicklung
geworden ist bei meinem Rechner, ne?
Ich habe hier mein...
Das ist den Rechner, den ich mir Ende 2022 zusammengebaut habe.
Das war der krasseste High-End-Shit,
den man sich zusammenbauen konnte zum damaligen Zeitpunkt, ja?
Schnellste CPU, schnellste GPU, kein schlechtes Mainboard,
Wasserkühlung, das war...
Also, viel mehr High-End-Rechner ging nicht.
Das hat am Ende irgendwie knapp 5.000 Euro gekostet.
Das war echt ein fettes Ding.
So.
Und zwei Jahre später ist der Rechner immer noch komplett High-End.
Und es geht kaum besser.
Zwei Jahre...
Früher habe ich den Rechner gekauft,
und nach zwei Jahren konnte ich froh sein,
wenn aktuelle Games überhaupt noch gestartet sind.
4090 immer noch...
Es gibt keine bessere Grafikkarte als die 4090.
Ich bin nicht Konsolengamer.
Ich sagte, ich war lange Jahre Konsolengamer.
So 2008, 9, 10, 11, als ich angefangen habe mit YouTube und so,
habe ich nur Xbox gespielt, aber schon lange nicht mehr.
Ich glaube, ich hatte die letzten Jahre,
außer mal kurz die Switch für ein, zwei Games,
keine Konsolen mehr an.
Die gibt es schon seit zwei Jahren.
Ja, der Rechner ist von Ende 2022.
Ja, wir haben sogar on stream das Ding ein bisschen zusammengebaut,
was aber echt schwierig war,
weil der Kameraausschnitt so klein war und ich kaum was gesehen habe.
Das war...
Mikrorisse im Mainboard, Leute.
Erinnert sich noch einer?
Mikrorisse im Main...
Oder Haarrisse im Mainboard.
Einfach mal ohne Scheiß, Leute.
Ich kann mich daran erinnern.
Wann kam Far Cry raus?
Moment mal, Far Cry...
Das erste.
Das erste Far Cry.
2004.
Okay.
Legit, ich kann mich daran erinnern.
Ich hatte zu diesem Zeitpunkt einen Athlon XP 1900 Release Date.
So, den habe ich 2022 gekauft, den Rechner.
Und das war zum damaligen Zeitpunkt auch high end.
Ja, das war, glaube ich, eine GeForce 3 Grafikkarte,
die da drin war oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Und das war auch...
Das war im Jahr 2022 wirklich high end,
was ich mir damals gekauft habe.
Und dann kam Far Cry raus, quasi zwei Jahre später.
2002, nicht 2022.
Ja, ja, Blödsinn.
2002.
Ihr wisst, was ich meine.
2002 gekauft.
2002 habe ich mir damals den Rechner gekauft.
Und 2004 kam Far Cry raus.
Und, Leute, das Spiel lief nicht richtig auf der Kiste.
Zwei Jahre später.
Zu der damaligen Zeit war ein high end Rechner...
Zwei Jahre später Schrott.
Weiß ich...
Ich vermisse den Chainlaw jetzt ein bisschen
wegen seinem komischen ASCII-Gespamme, ja.
Aber so wirklich eigentlich auch nicht ist Cry engine...
Das ist quasi die erste Variante der Cry engine gewesen, ja.
So, und das lief nicht richtig.
Ich habe das Ding damals abgegradet mit einer AMD Grafikkarte.
Das war wirklich...
Man muss sich mal vorstellen, was ist die aktuellste Cry engine?
Kein Schimmer.
Muss ich mal wirklich vorstellen.
Damals war ein absoluter high end Rechner.
Also, den Rechner, den ich damals hatte, mit dem Athlon XP 1900 und der GeForce 3,
das ist vergleichbar mit meinem aktuellen Rechner vom high end Grad, ja.
Das war wirklich...
Der hat damals auch 2500 Euro oder sowas gekostet.
Und ich meine, heute hat ein Rechner...
Das ist ungefähr...
Das kommt aufs Gleiche raus, ja.
Das war wirklich komplett das Beste, was es gab.
Und was ist?
Zwei Jahre später Schrott.
Okay, vielleicht ist der aktuelle Rechner ein bisschen high endiger noch als der damals, aber es war beides ziemlich high end, ja.
Und zwei Jahre später Schrott.
Da sieht man mal, wie sich die ganze Hardware-Entwicklung verlangsamt hat die letzten Jahre über.
Das wollte ich eigentlich jetzt sagen.
Das war das...
Hups.
Das war das, worauf ich raus wollte.
Ah ja, es tut sich auch nicht mehr so viel.
Ja und nein.
Also, ja, wir haben aus Anwendersicht, dass du dir nur noch alle fünf Jahre einen neuen Rechner kaufen musst, ist das natürlich gut.
Auf der anderen Seite, ich fand den technischen Fortschritt damals echt geil.
Du konntest quasi zugucken.
Und das war auch die Zeiten, wo ich tatsächlich dann angefangen habe, mir ein CT-Abo zu holen.
Das habe ich bis heute.
Ich lese die CT überhaupt nicht mehr, aber ich habe ein CT-Abo geholt.
Es war gefühlt...
Jeden, jede, jede Ausgabe von der CT war irgendwas drinne, wo ich gesagt habe, geil, und das kommt bald so.
Das hast du halt heute nicht mehr.
Also, es war schon nice, das mitzuerleben.
So, so von, ich würde sagen, von 1995 bis so, sagen wir mal die 20 Jahre, 1995 bis 2015 vielleicht.
Wobei 2015 auch schon deutlich langsamer ging alles.
Sagen wir mal 1995 bis 2010, ja.
Das war richtig krass zu sehen.
In diesen 15 Jahren ist von Pixel-Geruckel zu Crysis, hat sich das entwickelt.
Weiß ich nicht, wann war Crysis Release? 2007.
Das war schon geil.
Das hätte ich, das fände ich, ganz ehrlich, ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht, aber ich persönlich hätte gerne lieber eine Technik-Entwicklungsgeschwindigkeit,
wie damals, dass ich mir alle zwei Jahre einen neuen Rechner kaufen muss, anstatt alle fünf Jahre.
Ich fand das einfach spannender.
Es tut sich natürlich heute immer noch viel, aber in anderen Bereichen.
Es ist nicht mehr so, dass ich mir heute in zwei Jahren später eine GPU kaufe und die ist dreimal so schnell.
Dafür habe ich bis früher kein RGB.
Okay, da würde ich im Zweifelsfall auch wieder drauf verzichten.
Weiß nicht, wie ihr das seht.
Ja, natürlich...
Die Frage stellt sich gar nicht.
Gute Spiele brauchen beides.
Gute Grafik heißt ja übrigens auch nicht mal, es muss unbedingt fotorealistischer sein oder so.
Ich sage euch, wie es ist.
Grafisch meine Lieblingsgames sind Super Nintendo Spiele.
Und das kannst du nicht, ich mag Pixel-Grafik einfach.
Vor allem Oldschool Pixel-Grafik.
Und das kannst du natürlich nicht mit aktuellen Games vergleichen.
Aber Spiele, die mich grafisch am meisten ansprechen, sind Super Nintendo Spiele.
Ich mag auch aktuelle Games auf Pixel-Grafik.
Leider muss man sagen, dass in den letzten Jahren das ein bisschen Überhand genommen hat.
Und auch vieles nicht so...
Wie soll ich sagen?
So Artstyle-mäßig nicht so schöne Pixel-Grafik teilweise auch...
Viele machen Games so nach dem Motto Pixel-Grafik, weil...
Ja, weiß ich auch nicht, warum sie das machen.
Weil es irgendwie gar nicht dazu passt.
Ne, sagt mir nichts.
Es ist ja laufend, kommt ja mal irgendwas.
Aktuell ist es eher der ganze AI-Trend.
Ein paar Jahre davor haben sie alle geschrien...
VR!
Hat sich auch wieder abgeflacht.
Welche Tastatur hast du?
Eine Logitech G512.
Mit so einer extra Handballenauflage zusätzlich.
Aber wie teuer war ein guter PC damals zum Vergleich?
So wie heute.
Also so meint sie.
Ja, also 2500 Euro damals so.
Also so ein 2500 Euro Rechner von 2002.
Ist ungefähr das, was du ein 4500 Euro Rechner, 5000 Euro Rechner heute hast.
So vom High-End-Grad her.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das alleine mit Inflation erklären kann.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Es gibt aber auch Hardware-Sachen, die unverhältnismäßig teuer geworden sind.
Also damals hat eine High-End-Grafikkarte wirklich nur einen Bruchteil von dem gekostet, was heute die beste Grafikkarte kostet.
Also wenn ich mir damals...
Damals hatte ich eine 7800 GTX.
Eine GTO hieß das damals glaube ich noch.
Das war mehr oder weniger das gleiche.
Ja.
Das war damals die absolute High-End-Grafikkarte.
7900 GTO.
Genau.
Das war damals die absolute High-End-Grafikkarte.
Vor so 2005 oder so.
Weiß nicht, wann das Ding rausgekommen ist.
Release Date.
Kam raus 2005, 2006.
Und hat gekostet 250 Euro.
Heute bezahlst du...
Für die 5090 willst du 2500 Euro bezahlen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was es mit Inflation ist.
Auf jeden Fall keine Null hinten dran.
Für die 5090 willst du 2500 Euro bezahlen.
Ja.
Damals gab es die High-Endigste GPU für 250 Euro.
Ich habe die übrigens noch.
Die habe ich mir aufgehoben.
Die habe ich hier irgendwo unten im Schrank liegen noch.
Die Grafikkarte.
Hattest du mal Multi-GPU?
Nein.
Ich glaube ich hatte nie Multi-GPU.
Ich habe mir immer gewünscht.
Ein Voodoo 2 SLI Setup zu haben damals.
So.
Weiß ich nicht.
1996 oder so.
Das war aber preislich.
Und alles komplett.
Außerhalb.
Als ich in die Schule gegangen bin.
Außerhalb des Möglichen.
Sowas zu kaufen.
Und danach hatte ich eine TNT 1.
Da habe ich gar nicht erst angefangen.
Mit Voodoo Grafikkarten mehr.
Da hatte ich eine Nvidia TNT 1.
Nämlich eine Elsa E-Razor 2.
Das war meine erste Nvidia Grafikkarte.
Nicht PCI, AGP.
Wer das nicht kennt.
Das ist quasi der Vorgänger.
Das ist quasi der Vorgänger von PCI Express.
Aber meine war passiv gekühlt.
So sah das Ding aus.
Muss ich vorstellen.
Das war die Highendste Grafikkarte.
Die es damals gab.
1996 oder so.
Ohne das man Voodoo 2 SLI noch dazu gemacht hat.
Also quasi als Standalone Grafikkarte.
War das Beste was ich damals kaufen konnte.
Und die konnte man damals.
Musst du dir mal vorstellen.
Die konnte man damals auch passiv kühlen.
Matrox, ja aber die waren damals.
Konnten die da nicht mit.
Matrox konnte generell nur ganz kurz was Leistungsfähigkeit mithalten.
Nur ganz kurz was Leistungsfähigkeit mithalten.
Vielleicht ein halbes Jahr oder ein Jahr danach.
Konntest du dir vergessen.
Passiv, heutzutage eine passiv gekühlte Grafikkarte.
Moment den Hersteller gibt es noch?
Gar nicht klar gewesen.
Also sah das aus.
Das waren andere Zeiten so 1996 rum.
Tetris.
Tetris geht für mich.
Ganz knapp überhaupt als Game durch.
Das hat ja nix.
Okay ich weiß.
Die Tetris Speedrunner sehen das anders.
Also ich muss sagen.
Pixel Grafik technisch.
Gibt es ein paar Games.
Die ich sehr nice finde.
Wobei ich sagen muss.
Das auf dem Super Nintendo gibt es so ein paar Games.
Wo ich sagen würde.
Also wirklich richtig richtig gut.
Also von der Pixel Grafik die mir so aus dem Kopf einfallen.
Das ist Tales of Phantasia.
Das sieht super aus auf dem Super Nintendo.
Eines der schönsten Super Nintendo Games.
Final Fantasy 6.
Und Secret of Mana 1 und 2.
Wobei das zweite ja nie rausgekommen ist in Europa.
Und Chrono Trigger.
So für RPG mäßig Pixel Grafik.
Sind das wirklich so.
Auch heute noch.
Das sind typische Pixel Games.
Die aus.
Ich will nicht sagen unerreicht sind.
Von der Optik her.
Weil heute kannst du auch Pixel mäßig.
Dank der schöneren Auflösung.
Doch durchaus mehr machen.
Aber das sind wirklich Zeitlose Games.
Was die Optik angeht.
Weil Pixel Grafik altert einfach nicht.
Ja Terraria ist ein Spiel.
Was beispielsweise zeigt.
Dass man durchaus mit Pixel Grafik und höherer Auflösung.
Auch was schönes machen kann.
Der Look von Secret of Mana.
Dieses bisschen.
Der Secret of Mana Look.
Ist wirklich schwer zu beschreiben.
So dieser Cute Monster Look.
Secret of Mana ist auf jeden Fall.
Eines der schönsten Games auf dem Super Nintendo.
Konnte man damals nicht höher tacken.
Du konntest Lüfter drauf machen.
Ich weiß noch.
Dass ich mich damals wieder übelste Hackerman gefühlt habe.
Das habe ich ja schon mal erzählt.
Ich hatte zwischenzeitlich irgendwann mal.
Ein Pentium 2 400.
Diese Dinger wurden ja.
Auf so Cartridges geliefert.
Ja so sahen die Dinger aus.
Das hat Intel einmal und nie wieder gemacht.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Bin ich mir bis heute nicht sicher.
Was der Grund war.
Warum Intel damals gesagt hat.
Sockel CPUs sind Kacke.
Wir machen die jetzt auf so eine Cartridge drauf.
Keine Ahnung warum.
Das hat Intel davor nicht gemacht.
Und das hat Intel danach auch nicht mehr gemacht.
Ich weiß bis heute nicht warum man das so gemacht hat.
Und.
Die waren dabei.
Das war wegen dem Cache.
Aha.
Ja da war die CPU drinnen damals.
Guck hier so sah das innen aus.
Das war quasi so eine Mainboard Erweiterung.
Wenn man so will.
Sie haben halt was riskiert.
Naja anscheinend ja nicht.
Weil danach haben sie es ja wieder rückgängig gemacht.
Und sind wieder auf Sockets gegangen.
Also das war wohl Intel auch nicht so ganz recht.
So zumindest die CPU.
War die erste CPU.
Die ich jemals übertaktet habe.
Damals hat man noch nicht CPUs direkt übertaktet.
Damals hat man mit Frontside-Bus übertaktet.
Und da habe ich quasi.
Ich glaube von 100MHz Frontside-Bus.
Auf 133MHz Frontside-Bus übertaktet.
Das war im Prinzip.
Einmal im BIOS was umstellen.
Und dann lief die CPU mit 450MHz.
Und ich hatte richtig.
Als ich das umgestellt habe Leute.
Ich hatte richtig Schiss.
Dass mein Rechner gleich kaputt geht.
Dass der irgendwie.
Ich weiß auch nicht was ich mir gedacht habe.
Ich hatte wirklich.
Ich habe richtig gezittert dabei.
Ich habe gedacht.
Fuck Alter.
Du machst gerade deinen Rechner kaputt.
Und er war so teuer.
Und du kriegst keinen neuen.
Aber ich will mal ausprobieren.
Ich hatte richtig Schiss dabei.
Als ich das übertaktet habe.
Und natürlich habe ich mich gefühlt.
Wie der ultraste Hacker-Man aller Zeiten.
Ja.
Jetzt muss ich mal überlegen.
50MHz bei einer 400.
Das ist ja.
Wer kann gut Prozent rechnen?
20% oder irgendwie sowas.
Was sind 50MHz von 400?
25.
25% oder?
Ja 25%.
Das sind 25%.
Übertaktet meine CPU heute um 25%.
Alter.
Was?
12,5?
Nee.
25.
Nicht 200. 400.
Ach so.
Wait a minute.
Ihr habt Recht.
QuickMuffs im Chat.
12,5.
25.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich habe 400 gesagt.
War bei 200 im Kopf.
Aber in Wirklichkeit waren es 400.
Ist eine Hausnummer.
Aber kannst du heute auch machen.
Du müsstest quasi eine 4000MHz CPU auf 4400 übertakten.
Oder 4500 übertakten.
Ja.
4500 übertakten.
Ja na gut.
Das ist durchaus im Bereich des Machbaren.
Mit der passenden Kühlung würde ich sagen.
Da müsste man den Bauer fragen.
Der wüsste das bestimmt.
Der Auer.
Der 8 Auer.
Zumindest ich kam mir super Hacker-Man mäßig vor.
Als ich das Ding damit übertaktet habe.
Wie gesagt.
Damals hat man noch nicht wirklich übertaktet.
Wie man das heute macht im BIOS.
Damals hast du eingestellt.
100MHz Frontside-Bus.
133MHz Frontside-Bus. Fertig.
Welche CPU würdest du aktuell empfehlen?
Preis-Leistung.
Ich kann dir nichts ruhigen Gewissens empfehlen.
Weil ich keine Ahnung von aktueller Technik habe.
Ich habe nur Ahnung von aktueller Technik.
Wenn ich mir selbst etwas kaufen will.
Ich glaube, dass ich mir aktuell.
Aber ich nehme das nicht als Empfehlung.
Wahrscheinlich würde ich mir aktuell.
Tatsächlich mal wieder einen AMD Rechner bauen.
Wenn ich mir jetzt etwas kaufen würde.
Und bauen würde.
Aber das ist nur mein Bauchgefühl.
Und meine Vermutung zur Zeit.
Ich kann das nicht belegen.
Oder widerlegen.
Ich bin mir da nicht sicher.
Ich kenne mich immer nur mit Hardware aus.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt, wenn ich mir etwas Neues kaufen will.
Macht aber auch keinen Sinn.
Also wenn man jetzt nicht gerade ein Technik-Channel ist.
Oder einen das persönlich wahnsinnig interessiert.
Früher hat mich das viel mehr interessiert.
Aktuelle Hardware-Entwicklung.
Da habe ich wie gesagt.
PC-Games-Hardware, GameStar, CCT.
Alles mögliche.
Mir immer verschlungen.
Aber mittlerweile juckt mich das gar nicht.
Die Update-Rate meiner PC-Hardware.
Ist mittlerweile im 4-5 Jahres-Rhythmus.
Und es macht für mich einfach keinen Sinn.
Immer auf dem aktuellen Stand zu sein.
Zumal mich Hardware auch nicht mehr so interessiert.
Wie früher.
Intel-Kacke.
Das hat Intel ja angeblich gefixt.
Jetzt bei den neuen CPUs.
Sagt Intel.
Warum man Intel da glaubt, weiß ich nicht.
Was? Was Max?
Hast du das von der Oper in Stuttgart mitbekommen?
Die Vorstellung war so verstörend, dass die Zuschauer da...
Nein. Habe ich nicht mitbekommen.
Was haben die denn gemacht?
Haben die gesagt, Android ist besser als IOS?
Oder...
Xbox vs. Playstation?
Das triggert die Leute.
Naja.
Das ist ja das Krankenhaus, oder?
Wobei, man weiß ja nicht, was dabei passiert ist.
Es soll schon vorgekommen sein,
dass Leute danach ins Krankenhaus mussten.
Hat dein Mainboard schon USB-C?
Ja klar.
Achso, mein Mainboard.
Ja gut. Ja.
Am Gehäuse habe ich USB-C.
Mit so einem Kabel aufs Mainboard.
Hinten bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher, ob es USB hinten hat.
Lass mich mal gucken. Ich glaube nicht.
Einen USB-C habe ich hinten.
Tatsächlich.
Ja gut. Die müssen halt auch Zeug...
Die müssen halt auch ein bisschen über die Stränge schlagen,
dass man von ihnen redet.
So. Chat...
Ich kriege es so langsam aber sicher echt Hunger.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
End of Adblockers in Chrome.
Ja, das habe ich auch schon mitgekriegt.
Noch habe ich uBlock Origin installiert
in Chrome.
Aber sobald das nicht mehr geht,
fliegt Chrome weg.
Sobald das quasi
sich deaktiviert,
fliegt das weg.
Und danach gibt es wieder den Klassiker,
Leute.
Sponsored, sponsored, sponsored.
Dismiss.
Danach gibt es Firefox
einfach anstatt Chrome.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass Chromium nicht das Problem
haben wird, da komische Dinger zu entfernen.
Warum benutzt du Chrome eigentlich?
Ich kann dir das nicht
tiefgreifend beantworten.
Ich benutze ja alle
drei Browser. Ich benutze Chromium,
Chrome und Firefox.
Firefox fehlen die Extensions?
Ist es nicht sogar so,
dass der uBlock Origin
Erfinder explizit sagt,
der beste Browser für seine Extensions ist Firefox?
Hast du auch ein Raspberry Pi?
Ja, habe ich.
Im Stream gestern
haben wir sogar auf dem Raspberry Pi was gemacht.
Also um genau zu sein, habe ich
wahrscheinlich acht Raspberry Pis
oder so mittlerweile.
Im Einsatz
sind
eins, zwei,
drei,
äh,
ich muss gerade mal mein Haus durchgehen.
Ich glaube, es sind aktuell
nur drei im Einsatz. Einer im Keller,
einer am 3D Drucker und noch ein Raspberry Pi Zero.
Wenn ich nicht
irgendwas vergessen habe.
Ich habe das nämlich alles
ein bisschen entschlackt
vor ein, zwei Jahren.
Sodass jetzt ein Raspberry Pi quasi im Keller
auch mehrere Sachen macht.
Und ich nicht noch einen zusätzlichen Zero
im Keller brauche und einen normalen Raspberry Pi.
Dazu musste ich aber ein bisschen Kabel verlängern,
dass das alles da hinkommt.
Ich glaube, aktuell sind es zwei.
Zwei Raspberry Pis und ein Zero.
Ja, genau.
Wie sieht es eigentlich bei Edge
mit Manifest V3 aus?
Okay, ja gut, aber das liegt ja nicht an uBlock.
Das Problem
liegt ja an Twitch und...
Ja gut, ich verstehe aber, was du meinst.
Ja, du brauchst...
Du fixst das nicht mit uBlock,
du fixst das mit irgendwelchen extra
Extensions, die quasi explizit
auf Twitch zugeschnitten sind und die gibt es nicht
für Firefox. Ja, das ist natürlich dann doof.
Kannst du da
einen guten Kanal empfehlen, da ich für meine Ausbildung
auch einen habe und mich damit beschäftigen soll?
Ja.
Kommt drauf an, was du machen willst. Also, mir fällt jetzt kein guter
YouTube-Channel ein, der sagt,
wir machen alles mit dem Raspberry Pi.
What the fuck?
Ey, ich habe einen Fiat 500e.
Ich habe einen Fiat 500e. Wo ist das?
Problem? Das stimmt überhaupt nicht, dass keiner
den kauft. Der wird so oft
gekauft, dass du Lieferzeiten hast von
keine Ahnung, einem halben Jahr oder so.
Und ich habe nur 15...
Ne, wie viel habe ich dafür bezahlt?
Bisschen mehr. Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
20.000? Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
17.500?
Ne, ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Was habe ich... Ne, was habe ich
dafür? Moment. Also, ich habe
auf jeden Fall weniger bezahlt, weil
mein Auto nicht 1 zu 1
aus der Fabrik kam, sondern...
die das zum Vorführen
von dem Auto verwendet haben.
Ähm...
Hier.
Ca. 25.000 Euro habe ich bezahlt.
Ca. 25.000 Euro.
Ist mir egal, ob das
brumm brumm macht.
Das macht...
Elektroautos haben so einen
Elektroauto-Sound.
Ne, erst mal nicht.
Auch wenn ich das... Ich gucke da auch schon
eine ganze Weile, aber erst mal
steht das nicht auf dem Programm.
Ich soll mit dem Pi zum Beispiel auf
seinem Server per RDP zugreifen?
Ne, das ist ja easy.
R-Desktop. IP vom Server. Fertig.
Viel interessanter wäre das, wenn du mit
RDP auf den Raspberry Pi zugreifen könntest.
Wobei man auf den Pi eigentlich nicht mit RDP
zugreift, sondern Headless per
SSH.
Ich glaube, du musst dich weniger mit dem
Raspberry Pi beschäftigen, du musst dich mit
Linux an sich beschäftigen.
Und das Beste, sich mit Linux zu beschäftigen,
ist, es einfach täglich zu benutzen.
Mach dir eine Linux-VM
und benutze sie für deine tägliche
Arbeit am Rechner.
Oder für tägliche Sachen, die
du machst am Rechner. Da lernst du am meisten was.
Du brauchst Linux-Skills, du brauchst
nicht wirklich Raspberry Pi-Skills.
Raspberry Pi-Skills brauchst du erst, wenn es um
Raspberry Pi-spezifische Sachen geht.
Du willst Sensoren an die GPIOs anschließen,
du hast irgendwie ein
Erweiterungsboard
gekauft, was du
an die Header anschließt.
Willst du damit irgendwie was auslesen,
dann brauchst du Raspberry Pi-spezifische Sachen.
Oder du willst eine Kamera an den Raspberry Pi.
Was du aktuell machen willst, ist einfach nur,
du willst Linux-Skills aufbauen.
Das geht mit dem Raspberry Pi,
das geht aber auch mit einem Linux auf einer VM.
Wichtig ist, dass man es einfach verwendet.
Da lernt man am meisten drüber.
Ja, das ist illegal.
Kannst von ausgehen,
dass das illegal ist.
Wie viele VMs kannst du gleichzeitig laufen lassen
mit deinem aktuellen Setup?
Wenn ich da drin einfach nur minimal
Linux-Kram boote
und der VMs nur 256 MB RAM gebe,
dann kann ich wahrscheinlich
keine Ahnung, 100 oder so laufen lassen.
Ja, ViPo ist aber auch kein
klassisches IPTV, wo du jetzt irgendwie sagst,
ich geh jetzt an RTSP-Stream dran
und greif das ab und mach damit,
was ich will.
Das geht nur über den ihre App
und da ist auch alles
per DRM gesichert,
soweit wie möglich.
Also, das ist einfach so.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du ViPo
mittlerweile irgendwie anders abgreifen kannst.
Also, ich glaube,
es ist gar nicht so einfach zu sagen,
ich nehme jetzt einfach mal eine Sendung auf,
bei mir lokal irgendwo hin.
Aber ich gehe auch nicht davon aus,
dass er von ViPi oder Satu
oder so was spricht,
sondern ich gehe davon aus,
er spricht von
russischem Anbieter X,
der dir eine Playlist
mit, ähm,
ähm,
Streams zur Verfügung
stellt,
wo du quasi mit jedem Player
alle Programme gucken kannst.
Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht legal.
Was schade ist,
weil das mit Abstand das angenehmste wäre.
Ich bin eh der Meinung, dass klassische
TV-Sender es maßlos übertrieben haben
und deswegen man das nicht mehr unterstützen sollte.
Ihr müsst euch mal überlegen.
Man kann mittlerweile,
man muss sich das wirklich mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen,
wenn man jetzt sagt, ja, ich will, keine Ahnung,
ProSieben in HD gucken,
dann musst du
erst mal Geld bezahlen,
dass du das überhaupt empfangen kannst.
Also du brauchst erst mal, sag mal, du brauchst erst mal
einen Kabelanschluss oder du brauchst erst mal
einen DVB-T2 oder was auch immer.
Du brauchst irgendwie eine Empfangsmöglichkeit, das musst du dir kaufen.
Dann brauchst du noch eine Smartcard
oder irgendwie ein Abo
oder was auch immer, wo die HD-Varianten
drin sind.
Von den Sendern. Das heißt,
du bezahlst den Empfang, du bezahlst
zusätzlich nochmal den Empfang von
HD-Programmen und jetzt
kommt der Hit. Jetzt kommt der Hit.
Das Ganze ist dann immer noch mit Werbung
und jetzt kommt noch eins oben drauf.
Sie können dir verbieten,
den Aufnahmen in der Werbung zu spulen.
Das heißt,
du bezahlst zweimal schon,
du guckst Werbung
und wenn du es aufnimmst,
können sie dir verbieten, die Werbung zu überspringen.
Dementsprechend geht das auch nur
mit den passenden Endgeräten,
die ihren komischen DRM-Kram entforsten,
dass sie dir das eben untersagen können.
Das ist
so lächerlich,
dass ich einfach, ich gucke kein
klassisches Fernsehen mehr.
Private Fernsehsender schon gar nicht.
Gerade wegen diesem
Kram. Das ist was, was ich
absolut null unterstützen will.
Das ist so lächerlich.
Und dann dazu kommt, dass es auch noch shit ist,
was gesendet wird.
Weil ganz ehrlich, Filme im Fernsehen gucken,
warum? Jetzt meine, ich habe mit Ernst
eine ganz gemeinte Frage.
Warum sollte ich mir
einen Film, wo ich sage,
würde ich mir gerne angucken,
warum sollte ich mir einen Film
auf Pro7 HD angucken,
wo ich für den Empfang bezahle,
für das Freischalten der HD-Sender bezahle,
den Film vielleicht aufnehme noch,
dass ich die Werbung skippen kann
und dann verbieten sie mir die Werbung zu skippen?
Warum sollte ich das machen?
Warum sollte ich den Film nicht einfach
auf Prime gucken oder auf Netflix gucken?
Oder auf
wo auch immer Grauzone
gucken?
Zum größten Teil wahrscheinlich würde ich
ihn über Prime gucken.
Oder wenn ich ein Netflix-Abo habe,
was ich gerade übrigens gekündigt habe,
was nicht aktiv ist. Netflix-Abo wird
bei mir immer, wenn es da was cooles zu gucken gibt,
aktiviert. Dann wird das geguckt und dann wird es wieder gekündigt gleich.
Noch bevor ich fertig
gucken bin, weil es hält ja einen Monat.
Bei mir auch so seit 10 Jahren
bestimmt schon gucke ich kein klassisches Fernsehen mehr.
Ich gucke sicherlich die ein oder anderen
Beiträge, die es gibt.
Sei es in der Mediathek oder vielleicht auch mal über Kodi.
Aber
so klassisch von Fernsehsätzen...
Also ich kann ja bei mir das gesamte Fernsehen streamen.
Ich habe ja einen DVB-C Receiver
mit TV-Headern drauf und
ich kann quasi
von überall im Haus darauf zugreifen
und halt normales Fernsehen mir angucken.
Da ist aber kein HD Pro 7 dabei.
Weil das kannst du nicht einfach frei empfangen.
Da brauchst du eine zusätzliche Smart-Karte. Das kann das wieder nicht.
Das ist halt einfach bescheuert.
Ja, also warum sollte ich mir einen Film
da irgendwie Pro 7 angucken,
wenn ich mir den einfach auch wahrscheinlich
sogar kostenlos bei Prime angucken kann?
Weil bei Pro 7 gibt es ja meistens nur alte Filme.
Und wenn es ein älterer Film ist,
den ich gucken will und der nicht im Prime-Abo
drin ist, dann kann ich ihn mir meistens
bei Prime angucken, trotzdem mit Werbung.
Die nicht so nervig ist wie bei Pro 7
und die übertreiben es auch langsam. Oder aber
ich kaufe mir den einfach für 3,99 Euro,
wenn ich den unbedingt gucken will.
Das geht ja auch.
Ja, ich mache es ähnlich.
Ich habe eine VU Plus
DVB-C. Darauf
läuft
ähm
TV Headend.
Ich habe eine Custom Firmware da drauf.
Daniel Lull, danke schön für den Zap.
Ich habe eine Custom Firmware drauf.
Hier SSH. Wir hatten uns doch letztens.
Root Add. Hier.
Da bin ich auf meinem
Das ist mein DVB-C Receiver drüben im
Wohnzimmer. Custom Firmware.
Da läuft TV Headend drauf.
Und einen äh
ja, ein Programm, was
die DVB-C Receiver
anspricht.
Das ist eine gute Kombi, weil die, weil die Firmware,
die Firmware, die die mitliefern, ist halt
abgrundtief Schrott. Und dieses
Protokoll, was du da zum Streamen
drauf hast, ist auch abgrundtief Schrott.
Das Beste ist Custom Firmware und
TV Headend. Ich habe eine Kombination,
also, ich komme mal kurz gucken,
was ich da, was habe ich denn da eigentlich für.
ETC, äh
OS, ne,
Linux, ne, okay.
Ja, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie man hier
nachgucken kann. ETC.
Muss es nicht eigentlich OS Release
oder sowas geben?
Sternchen Release ist eine gute Idee. Gibt's nicht.
Ja, ich habe Open
ATV heißt das, glaube ich.
Open ATV. Und
da habe ich TV Headend laufen.
Die kannst du nachinstallieren aus den Paketen.
TV Headend
und Mini TV
oder sowas heißt das für die DVB-C Receiver
zum ansprechen. Das heißt, ich habe
acht, acht, acht Receiver
erkennt er hier drinne. Das heißt, ich kann
acht Sachen gleichzeitig gucken und aufnehmen.
Was in Wirklichkeit noch mehr ist, weil
es pro Receiver im Prinzip
nur pro Frequenz ist und
du kannst auf der gleichen Frequenz auch alles
gucken und aufnehmen. Ja. VTI
hatte ich auch. VTI war nix. VTI
war so ein ganz komisches Streaming Zeug.
Ähm, wie gesagt, ich benutze das
Ding auch nicht zum Fernsehgucken. Ich benutze das Ganze
nur zum
Aufnehmen. Fernseh gucke ich selbst.
Nutze? Nö. Nutze ich nicht.
Sind halt acht drinne.
Äh, nutze ich nicht. Wenn es hochkommt,
wenn es hochkommt, benutze ich mal drei.
Weil, keine Ahnung, meine Mutter irgendwas
aufnimmt, äh, die guckt
irgendwas anderes im Fernsehen und, und
dann nimmt sie vielleicht... Ja, also, drei sind
das höchste der Gefühle, die da genutzt werden.
Man kommt ja auch damit aus, weil, wie gesagt, es ja pro Frequenz
ist und mit vier Receivern hast du quasi
schon alle Frequenzen mehr oder weniger abgedeckt.
Zumindest... Was wollte ich
jetzt noch eigentlich sagen?
Ähm, ich gucke damit ja kein Fernsehen
mit der Box. Die Box ist
bei mir quasi Headless, steht die in der Ecke
und stellt nur
quasi DVB-C Receiver und
TV-Headern zur Verfügung.
Am Fernseh selbst ist
ein Shield-TV mit Kodi drauf
und dem TV-Headern-Plugin,
die sich dann verbinden zu dieser Box.
Dementsprechend kann ich halt auch Fernsehgucken von jedem
Rechner und jedem Gerät im Haus,
der TV-Headern unterstützt und
nachdem es Kodi für fast alle Geräten
gibt oder irgendeinen TV-Headern-Client
ist gar kein Ding.
Ja. Und das Shield-TV ist halt
ein super Gerät. Seit Jahren habe ich das
schon. Fünf, fünf Jahren,
fünf, sechs Jahren oder so. Das ist
halt ein super Gerät, weil das eben
nicht nur die Möglichkeit bietet, so was
hier mit Kodi zu machen und du hast aber gleichzeitig
auf dem Shield-TV auch noch
die offiziellen Apps für Amazon
und Netflix. Und du hast dann
keine DRM-Probleme, wie beispielsweise
mit einer Raspberry Pi-Box.
Und vor allem ist auch die Oberfläche deutlich
weicher und angenehmer als das
Geruckele mit Kodi auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Ja.
Das ist so mein Setup, was ich da im Wohnzimmer
habe. Ja, ich bekomme
auch immer noch. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das
2017er Shield-TV habe.
Komm, mal gucken. Ich habe mal
ein Video gemacht.
Ich mag es.
Max FPS Wohnzimmer
Setup. Ein Wohnzimmer-Setup.
Hallo. Das ist von
vor sieben Jahren. Krass, oder?
Von 2017. Ja, da habe ich noch ein 2017er
Shield-TV. Muss ich mal überlegen.
Seit sieben Jahren gibt es dort
Updates für das Shield-TV. Die haben
immer mal ein bisschen Probleme gehabt mit den Updates,
gerade wenn sie die Android-Version gewechselt
haben. Mittlerweile sieht
es auch anders aus, das UI.
Und
ich habe mittlerweile auch die Updates
deaktiviert, die automatischen
Updates, weil ich keinen Bock habe, dass
sich das über Nacht updatet. Kodi geht nicht,
TV geht nicht, Shield-TV ist im
Arsch. Wozu soll ich das updaten?
Ich update das vielleicht einmal im Jahr oder so,
nachdem ich Zeit habe,
um das alles zu fixen.
Aber sieben Jahre Support ist wirklich nice.
Und die Hardware ist immer noch
brauchbar da drauf.
Es ist nicht mehr so snappy wie ganz
am Anfang. Was wahrscheinlich
auch an verkackten
Android-Sachen liegt.
Aber insgesamt ist es immer noch super weich
und lässt sich angenehm
bedienen.
Max, kann ich dich was zu deiner Arbeitszeit
verkürzen fragen? Klar. Schieß los.
Das machen wir noch. Dann muss ich was
kuttern, Leute. Ich habe übertrieben Hunger.
Drei Mal dürft ihr raten, was es
heute gibt.
Ihr kommt nie drauf.
Lachs mit Nudeln.
Nein. Falsch. Letztes Jahr.
Äh, nicht letztes Jahr. Letztes
Wochenende
gab es Lachs mit Nudeln.
Das heißt, was gibt es heute?
Richtig. Nudeln mit
Bolognese. Korrekt.
Ist doch noch nicht mal zwölf.
Muss ja auch noch warm machen und alles.
Hat die Nintendo Switch nicht die
selben Prozesse wie das Shield TV? Doch.
Das ist irgendeine Tegra
Blablub-Plattform. Ich glaube, die
Switch hat eine Generation oder
eine Iteration neuer als das Shield TV.
Aber es ist im Prinzip
das mehr oder weniger gleiche, ja.
Brauchst du das nicht frisch?
Nö, das ist... Der Grund, warum es bei mir
am Samstag, äh, am Sonntag
immer entweder Nudeln
mit Lachs oder Nudeln mit Bolognese
Soße gibt, ist, weil es der Rest vom
Samstag ist. Und Samstag bin
ich recht viel unterwegs. Da bietet es
sich das an. Ja, also mir
fällt auch kein Android-Gerät ein, was sieben Jahre
Updates. Was ist
mit dem Geburtstags-Koch-Stream? So was wollte ich
mal machen. Nee, wollte ich nicht.
Bin ich gestört, wenn ich aus Versehen ApoRed
gelesen habe, anstatt Apropos?
Ich hab das aus dem Augenwinkel gesehen und ich hab gedacht,
du hast ApoRed geschrieben.
Kritischer Hase, ja. Okay,
also ich brauch mal, ich brauch mal
deine Continuous Integration,
Continuous Delivery
Meinung.
Ich habe eine, ich habe ein Closed-Source-Projekt,
ein Repo, wo dann über
CICD ein Release erzeugt wird.
Dort liegt also nur eine Echse.
Ich nutze also quasi GitHub quasi als Update-Server.
Ja, gibt's genug, die das so machen.
Wie würdest du sowas wie Patch Notes
umsetzen, damit sie in der Anwendung angezeigt
werden, irgendwo mit dem Git-Repo regeln?
Kannst du die Patch Notes nicht einfach irgendwie
als Markdown oder so in dein GitHub-Repo
pushen?
Oder als Text oder als JSON, wie auch
immer du es am besten abrufen kannst und in der Anwendung
anzeigen kannst? Ja,
ich würde das wahrscheinlich auch
irgendwie über das Git-Repo machen.
Ich mein, oder,
Commit Message, oder
was du auch machen kannst ist,
ähm, du kannst das im
Bild, du kannst das im Bild-Step, wenn du, wenn du
das nie online anzeigen lassen willst, wenn du das
nur in deinem Programm anzeigen lassen willst,
du könntest das ja auch im Bild-Step
irgendwie, ähm,
einlesen lassen
und embedden
als Text-Ressource oder so.
Weiß ja nicht, was du da, was du da hast.
Okay. Bist du für die
4-Tage-Woche auf 80% runtergegangen
bei 8 Stunden und Arbeit zu 10? Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Das ist so, wie du das sagst.
Äh, so wie du das erste, das hier
habe ich gemacht, ja? Ich bin bei, ich bin
auf, ich habe meine Arbeitszeit
reduziert und daraus hat sich dann die 4-Tage-Woche
ergeben. Sagen wir es mal so, ja?
Also ich habe meine Arbeitszeit auf 80% reduziert
und arbeite seitdem nur noch 4 Tage,
aber dann 8 Stunden am Tag.
Ich arbeite nicht 10 Stunden pro Tag.
Also ich krieg, ich krieg 20% weniger
Geld dadurch, dass ich Teilzeit
arbeite, als jemand, der Vollzeit in der gleichen Position
arbeiten würde. Mach das!
Das ist das Beste, was du machen kannst.
Ich kann das auch allen übrigens nur
empfehlen, die sich das preislich, äh, preislich
ist das falsches Wort, äh, gehaltstechnisch leisten können.
Wenn man, wenn man sich das
leisten kann. 20% geht meistens.
Also wenn man nicht gerade so an der Grenze lebt, wo man
sagt, ah, ich komme überhaupt gerade erst richtig aus,
kann man sich
20% meistens leisten. Ich kann das
im Prinzip nur empfehlen,
sobald man das sich leisten kann.
Weil, eine Sache,
die immer vergessen wird,
bei dieser ganzen Sache, was eigentlich obvious
ist, Rente ist dann auch weniger,
das ist richtig, ja, da gibt es schon ein paar Sachen
zu bedenken, aber ich verdiene trotzdem
genug, dass die Rente auch okay ist.
Also muss ich halt, muss man,
muss man halt rechnen, ja, ob
man das und wie man das und ob das sich
lohnt, aber ganz ehrlich,
Zeit
zu haben, gerade halt
auch in Jahren, wo man noch ein bisschen was machen kann,
ist eigentlich durch nichts zu ersetzen.
Aber, was auch immer
vergessen wird, ist,
wie drücke ich das jetzt am besten aus?
Eigentlich ist es obvious und jeder weiß es.
Ein Tag mehr frei,
heißt auch gleichzeitig
ein Tag weniger arbeiten.
Und dementsprechend
ist man nicht so kaputt und das
Wochenende ist auch schon wieder früher und wenn das
Wochenende vorbei ist, muss man auch
nur vier Tage arbeiten. Also es ist nicht
so, es ist von allem
weniger, ja. Also
es ist nicht so, dass man quasi
gleiche Arbeitszeit
hat,
dafür dann drei Tage, das ist das,
was man wie am Anfang so komisch
im Kopf hat, ja, so nach dem Motto, ja,
ähm, ich,
man arbeitet, also man denkt
irgendwie so unterbewusst, ja, man arbeitet dann
fünf Tage, hat dafür drei Tage frei, aber das stimmt
ja gar nicht. Das ganze Verhältnis
verschiebt sich, ja.
Also man hat dann quasi
drei Tage frei, aber muss dann
auch nur noch vier Tage arbeiten, bis man wieder
drei Tage frei hat. Das heißt dadurch, dass
man nur noch vier Tage arbeitet, ist man auch weniger
kaputt, ja, und dann hat man
nochmal drei Tage frei und dadurch hat man
sich drei Tage erholt. Es ist dann quasi
vier zu drei Verhältnis von einem
fünf zu zwei Verhältnis.
Und das nächste
Reduzieren wäre dann schon
ein, äh, ja,
drei zu vier Verhältnis. Also das nächste Mal
Arbeitsreduzieren wäre schon mehr frei als arbeiten.
Also
das ist, diese verschiebt, diese 20
Prozent Verschiebung
macht fünf Tage
arbeiten, zwei Tage frei zu
vier Tage arbeiten, drei Tage frei. Das ist quasi
das Verhältnis von Arbeit zu frei
verschiebt sich massiv
durch 80 Prozent Reduzierung.
Das ist, das ist halt oft, das muss man auch
erst mal gemacht haben, um das zu realisieren.
Also diese 20 Prozent Einsparung
ergeben, ähm, ergeben
viel mehr zurück
von dem, was man da hat, als, als man
die 20 Prozent spürt, ja.
Weil du, du arbeitest ja dann auch kürzer, ohne
fast länger frei. Das ist diese Kombination.
Du bist dann auch erholter, dadurch, dass du nur
vier Tage arbeiten musst. Kannst dich an den drei Tagen
komplett erholen, weil du dann auch Sonntag
mittags nicht schon denkst, oh fuck, morgen muss ich
wieder arbeiten gehen, sondern du denkst dir Montag
abends so, ah ja, gut, jetzt hab ich mich schön ausgeruht.
Jetzt kann ich eigentlich auch, äh,
entspannt wieder arbeiten gehen. Und dann sind es nur vier
Tage und du hast wieder drei Tage frei.
Ja.
Also das kann, ich kann es wirklich jedem nur
erzählen, jedem nur empfehlen, wenn man sich's leisten
kann. Und wenn, man sollte es natürlich auch
mal durchrechnen, wie sieht's mit Rente aus.
Wie sieht's mit Krankenversicherung aus. Wie kann
man das bezahlen. Wie sieht's mit Geldanlage aus.
So einfach mal machen. Komplett blind würde ich das
nicht. Aber wenn man sich das leisten kann
und sich mal ein bisschen Gedanken drüber gemacht hat, kann ich
das jedem nur empfehlen. Der Return
oder das, was man da raus
bekommt, ist, finde ich, viel mehr wert,
als die 20% Verlust,
die man hat an Gehalt.
Ja, das kannst du, das kann ja jeder machen,
wie er will. Ich find das gut, montags
frei zu haben. Montags hat Vorteile.
Montags hat
erstens den Vorteil, es ist direkt
am Wochenende dran. Und
zweitens den Vorteil, montags sind sie
alle super aktiv und motiviert und
gehen dir auf den Sack. Freitag ist
der schlechteste Tag zum Frei haben,
weil Freitag macht eh keiner mehr was und alle
gammeln nur rum. Weil Freitag ist. Du wirst
ja auch explizit davon abgeraten, Freitags
noch irgendwelche Changes umzusetzen und sowas.
Also, ich sag mal, wir nennen's
mal so, der, die Leute gammeln rum
Anteil ist am Freitag deutlich höher als
am Montag. Ja, das ist auch
nicht schlecht. Muss jeder, das muss
jeder so ein bisschen individuell entscheiden, was für
ihn da das angenehmste ist. Ich persönlich
finde Montag am sinnigsten, weil du hast drei Tage
am Stück frei. Du arbeitest vier Tage am
Stück, das wird dann auch nicht zwischendurch irgendwie unterbrochen.
Und Montag ist, ist meiner
Erfahrung nach auch fast mit der nervigste Tag
gewesen.
Ja, beste, ne? Sogar fünf Stunden
machen richtig was aus.
Ich geh mal davon aus, dass du dadurch jetzt auch auf vier
Tage reduziert hast, ne? Du sind dann quasi nur fünf Stunden.
Du wirst wahrscheinlich an den vier Tagen irgendwie
eine halbe Stunde länger arbeiten, dann passt's wieder.
Oder wie hast du das gemacht?
Also ich kann es jedem
nur wärmstens empfehlen.
Die Frage war, wie aufgeschlossene
Arbeitgeber dafür sind. Also ich kann euch das kurz
erzählen. Ich mach das ja
schon seit, keine Ahnung, 2012
oder so. Ich mach das ja schon wirklich eine ganze
Weile oder 2011, 2012 so rum.
Also ich mach das schon über zehn Jahre mit
Teilzeit. Mein Arbeitgeber
war überhaupt nicht aufgeschlossen dafür damals.
Ich war der erste, so in der
IT, außer, außer
Mädels mit irgendwie
Eltern, Teilzeit und sonst nichts.
Weißige Sachen und
haben jetzt Nachwuchs gekriegt und wollen reduzieren.
Also ich war der erste Kerl
in der IT bei uns damals, der das machen
wollte. Und ich bin
damals zu meinem Chef, der ist
zu seinem Chef, kann mir
gute NAS-SSDs empfehlen. Ganz ehrlich,
ich würd mir einfach eine Samsung Evo reinklatschen
und gut, das
sind zwar keine Enterprise Cray
NAS-SSDs, aber für das, was du machen willst, ist es wahrscheinlich
mehr als ausreichend.
So, mein Chef, ich bin
zu meinem Chef, hab dem das gesagt, weil ich fand das witzig.
Ich bin damals zu meinem Chef hin und hab gesagt,
hier, wir müssen mal kurz über
Arbeitszeiten und sonst was reden. Da hat sich
voll gefreut mein Chef. Und mein Chef
dachte damals, ich komm zu
ihm und seine Karrieremöglichkeiten,
Motivationstalks
hätten bei mir endlich gezogen.
Der hat gedacht, ich komm zu ihm und sag, ich will
jetzt auch mal
Projektsachen machen und sowas.
Und das erste, was ich zu ihm gesagt hab, nee, nee,
will ich nicht, ich will weniger arbeiten.
Haha.
Nee, ist was ganz was anderes, ich will eigentlich weniger
arbeiten.
Naja, also, hab ich meinem Chef
erzählt, der ist zu seinem Chef
und der ist zu seinem Chef,
das war dann quasi der IT-Chef, ja,
und der hat gesagt, mit
sowas fangen wir hier erst gar nicht
an. Abgelehnt.
So. Ich habe
aber nie offiziell mit schriftlichem
Antrag und so angefragt, einfach mal nur so
mündlich, ja. So, und dann
hab ich, dann haben die mir gesagt, wurde abgelehnt.
Und dann hab ich darauf
ich hab ja im Internet schon mal ein bisschen
geguckt, hab ich gesagt, Moment mal, Moment mal,
rechtlich gesehen ist das
so, das kann man gar nicht so einfach
ablehnen. Das einzige, was ihr
machen könnt, ist, könnt sagen,
aktuell geht das nicht,
weil der Max hier essentiell ist,
quasi um den Betrieb aufrechtzuerhalten,
aber wenn ihr das sagt, müsst ihr selbst
dafür sorgen, dass das
in einem halben Jahr abgestellt wird spätestens.
Man kann das nicht einfach ablehnen und dann
sagen, nie wieder, ja. Aber gut, es ist
gut. Ich hab mir gedacht, auf die Diskussion
lässt du dich gar nicht ein und ich bin damals
zu unserem Betriebsrat gegangen.
Und das hat sich ewig hingezogen.
Ewig.
Keine Ahnung. Ein halbes Jahr.
Ewig hat sich das hingezogen.
Ich war dann beim Betriebsrat und
irgendwann war da mal der
Betriebsratschef beim
beim IT-Chef
und er hat das da nochmal angesprochen
und die Aussage vom IT-Chef
damals war, ah ja,
hätte der Kerl das doch mal gleich gesagt,
wäre er hier vorbeigekommen, hätte mal gleich gesagt,
was Sache ist, dann hätte ich das auch genehmigt.
Ist klar. Ich fahr natürlich hoch
in 30. Stock, klopf da
an die Tür und sag, IT-Chef,
Alter, wie geht's?
Genehmigst du mir Teilzeitarbeit?
Ist klar. Die Logik, ja.
Natürlich.
Was sonst? Vor allem, als hätte
er das, wenn ich da hochgegangen wäre,
auch genauso reagiert, wie wenn der
Betriebsratschef hochgegangen wäre, ja.
Ganz bestimmt, ganz bestimmt.
Zumindest danach war das Ganze durch.
Ich hab die Vertragsänderung
geschickt bekommen, ab dann und
dann 80 Prozent
und dann ist das gut, dann ging das.
Ja? Und als ich mich beworben
hab, vorletztes Jahr,
also ich hab mich ja, ich hab ja
2022, hab ich einen neuen Job gesucht
und hab am 1. April 2023
angefangen, da hab ich das gleich
auch gesagt, dass ich das weitermachen will
und
das war
tatsächlich kein Problem. Da war man
damit einverstanden direkt.
Was aber auch unter anderem daran liegt, dass die
echt händeringend Senior-Admin-Leute
und Linux-Leute gesucht haben.
Da hat man überhaupt
gar keine Probleme mit gehabt.
Und ich mach das genauso
weiter wie vorher. Montags hab ich
frei. Da haben sich auch, das Gute
ist, das Gute
daran ist, wenn du das gleich von Anfang
an machst, die Leute gewöhnen sich daran,
die wissen es nie anders. Es wissen
alle Leute, mit denen ich zu tun hab,
es wissen alle Leute, mit denen ich
zu tun hab,
der Max ist montags nicht am Start.
Das wissen alle im Team, das wissen
alle von irgendwelchen Projekten, das
wissen alle von irgendwelchen Produkten,
wo ich ab und zu mal auf die Server
gucken muss, das wissen alle. Die wissen
alle schon im Kopf, okay, montags müssen
wir den Kerl gar nicht einladen.
Ich mach manchmal, ich mach manchmal
Ausnahmen, ich mach manchmal
Ausnahmen, ich
würde zum Beispiel, wenn wir irgendwie
so einen Teambuilding-Workshop
oder sowas haben und der ist halt,
sagen wir mal, montags, dienstags,
dann würde ich da auch mal hingehen. Wichtig
ist nur, dass es prinzipiell klar ist, dass ich
montags nicht am Start bin. Sodass ich
dann mal ab und zu eine Ausnahme mach, wenn irgendwas ist,
da hab ich überhaupt kein Problem mit. Ich finde eh,
das muss so gegenseitig sich
in Grenzen halten, ja? Also,
ich hab keine Schmerzen damit, auch mal montags
anzurücken oder auch mal am Wochenende irgendwelche
Wartungsarbeiten zu machen, aber wenn bei mir mal
irgendwas kurzfristiges ist, dass ich sag, ich muss mal
zum Arzt oder was weiß ich, muss mit
meiner Mutter zum Arzt oder irgendwas in der Richtung,
dann würde ich erwarten, dass das der Arbeitgeber
dann auch quasi
einem da entgegenkommt. Und das war tatsächlich
bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber echt
problematisch. Die wollten in der Regel immer
nur, dass du ihnen entgegenkommst, die wollten dir aber
selbst nie entgegenkommen. Das war auch so ein Punkt, der mir echt
auf den Keks gegangen ist. Da bin ich sehr zufrieden,
wie das bei meinem aktuellen Arbeitgeber ist.
Und eins muss ich auch mal sagen,
ich würde nicht sagen, dass meine Chefs
schlecht waren beim alten Arbeitgeber.
Okay, teilweise schon.
Nicht alle, waren auch gute dabei,
aber manche waren wirklich,
konnte sie wirklich zu nix
gebrauchen. Aber da habe ich den Eindruck,
dass mein neuer Arbeitgeber tatsächlich
die Führungskräfte mal nicht auswählen
nach, wer bei drei nicht auf dem Baum ist, wird
Führungskraft, sondern, dass es wirklich
ein geplanter Karriereweg ist, wo
die Leute sich dafür anmelden können, sie würden
das gerne machen und auch dementsprechend darauf
vorbereitet werden und gucken
können, ob das was für sie ist, bis es denn
dann wirklich mal soweit ist. Das merkt
man, weil gerade das Verhalten,
wenn mal was ist oder wenn es mal Probleme
gibt, ist so viel um Längen
besser, wie das mein aktueller Chef
handelt, als das, wie das beim alten Arbeitgeber
gehandelt wurde. Also die haben, die packen
dort tatsächlich nicht mal irgendwelche
random Leute auf die Position, sondern
wirklich welche, wo man den Eindruck hat,
okay, die sind da auch gut
in der Position aufgehoben.
Ja, das kann durchaus sein.
Dann sind wir aber alle
gefickt.
Ich habe zwar eine
private, nein keine private, ich habe
eine, ich habe noch eine zusätzliche
betriebliche Alter, zwei betriebliche Altersversorgung,
einmal vom alten Arbeitgeber, die läuft
natürlich, die ist ja nicht einfach
weg, ja, aber habe ich ja lange genug für einen bezahlt
und vom neuen,
aber, sagen wir mal so,
reich wirst du davon nicht, also
einen Großteil würde ich schon noch über die gesetzliche Rente kriegen.
So,
ich würde sagen, zwei Drittel
gesetzliche Rente, ein Drittel
Rest, aber
wenn es dann nichts mehr gibt,
habe ich eh gelitten.
Gut, das habe ich ja gerade erzählt.
Wie gesagt, mein Argument ist, dass es eigentlich
gesetzlich nicht ablehnbar ist.
Und dann habe ich
gar nicht weiter argumentiert, sondern bin direkt zum
Betriebsrat, als sie gesagt haben, sie wollen nicht.
Battlefield 3
Commentary. Heute. Kappa.
HD.
Homeoffice macht viel aus. Ja, das stimmt.
Homeoffice ist eine riesen
Zeitersparnis, gerade, dass man diese
ich fahre eine Stunde hin, ich fahre eine Stunde zurück und, und, und
kotze, weil ich mit der Bahn
fahren muss, nicht hat.
Es gibt Leute, die auf 75,
es gibt Leute, die können nicht genug haben,
es gibt auch Leute, die arbeiten 80 Stunden die Woche.
Aber letztendlich darf man nicht vergessen,
ich glaube,
niemand, den du fragst,
so nach dem Motto, ey,
in den nächsten 5 Minuten wirst du sterben,
was hättest du gerne in deinem Leben noch
gemacht? Ich glaube, die wenigsten würden
antworten, oh shit ey,
also ich hätte mal mehr den Hardcore-Karriere-Arbeits-
Grind machen sollen.
Die meisten Leute werden
sagen, ey, ich hätte mal mehr Zeit mit der Familie verbringen
sollen, ey, ich hätte mal irgendwie da hinfahren
sollen, das hätte ich schon, wollte ich schon immer sehen,
oder, oder, oder ich hätte mal mich vor
ein paar Jahren früher trauen sollen, dass man das
auszuprobieren, whatever. Die wenigsten werden sagen,
krasser Hardcore-Karriere-Grind,
den habe ich vermisst, ey, ich hätte mal, ich hätte
mal lieber 80-Stunden-Wochen, statt 40-Stunden-Wochen
machen sollen, ne.
7,7, äh, 7.30 bis 7,
boah, na gut,
du musst ja auch Pause machen, ne.
Aber schon ordentlich.
Im Endeffekt, wenn die damit nicht zufrieden sind, die können dich
immer noch rausschmeißen, ne.
Die können das vielleicht nicht als Grund anführen,
aber fristgerecht und
alles ordentlich kündigen können die dich ja jederzeit.
Je nachdem, was du für einen
Vertrag hast, ja, aber du musst ja, ich meine, man muss
es ja auch mal fair sehen, ja. Du musst ja auch als
Arbeitgeber die Möglichkeit haben, Leute, auf die du
keinen Bock mehr hast, irgendwie ordentlich loszuwerden.
Kann ja nicht sein, dass du
irgendwie jemanden hast, der dir auf den Sack geht,
und du wirst den gar nicht mehr los.
Also das muss ja schon Leute loswerden können, ja.
Ja, das liegt aber wahrscheinlich hauptsächlich
an den Verträgen, dass sie da nicht so einfach rauskommen,
weil die die Verträge so gestaltet haben.
Bist du, bist du irgendwie,
bist du Beamter oder irgendwie öffentlicher Dienst
oder sowas, wenn ich da irgendwas sehe?
Antrags-, Gehaltsgruppe, sonst was?
Was? Nein, ich arbeite vier Tage, acht Stunden
oder 7,8 oder irgendwie sowas.
Wie viel Homeoffice machst du?
Also von meinen vier Tagen,
die ich arbeite in der Woche,
mache ich
in den meisten Fällen drei Tage Homeoffice.
Drei-, äh, ein Tag nach Frankfurt.
Ja, das stimmt wohl.
Easy, easy YouTube Money.
Bei, bei über einem halben Jahr
kein Upload. Massive Money gab's da.
Ich glaube, ich hab, ich glaube ich hab letzten Monat
YouTube und, und
Affiliate und sonstigen Kram,
keine Ahnung, 25
Euro verdient oder so.
Twitch war ein minimal mehr, dadurch, dass ich noch
ein paar Subs laufen hatte, aber nachdem ich jetzt auch drei Wochen
oder so kaum gestreamt hab, ist das natürlich
auch runtergegangen.
Was du machst, wenn du keinen Betriebsrat hast?
Ja, das ist natürlich schwierig.
Da musst du direkt mit denen rumzackern.
Oh, ey, jeder wo er Bock drauf hat.
Wenn du noch jung bist, in einem Alter,
wo du denkst, hey, das ist jetzt das Richtige,
mach das ruhig. Letztendlich
ist, liegt's
mir fern, irgendjemandem hier irgendwie was
vorschreiben zu wollen, was er machen soll, ja?
Ich kann euch nur Sachen empfehlen, die aus
meiner Sicht gut sind. Ob ihr das dann macht,
oder nicht,
ist euer Bier.
Ja, da hätte ich auch keinen Bock drauf.
Home-Office-Bash ist outdated, overrated,
das wird nie wieder weggehen.
Wenn du im Alter keine Rente mehr hättest,
denkst du, du hättest früher mehr... Ja, aber,
ganz ehrlich, da ist man selbst auch ein bisschen
in der Verantwortung, einfach mal zu gucken,
was denn so zu erwarten ist. Man kriegt
jedes Jahr eine Hochrechnung geschickt,
was man als Rente bekommen wird,
und es steht auch jedem frei,
für sich selbst ein bisschen
Geld anzulegen. Und an sich ist
es ja relativ easy, gerade wenn du noch 20, 30
Jahre Zeit hast, bis du in Rente gehst,
wenn du einfach nur irgendeine Braindead-Sache machen willst,
bezahlst du einfach monatlich
das, was du dir leisten kannst, in irgendeinem
World-ETF und lässt 30 Jahre liegen.
Und dann lässt du natürlich nicht alles auf einmal
ausbezahlen, sondern entnimmst nach und nach,
sodass du noch ein bisschen Geld weiterverdienst
damit. Oder verdienst. Verdienst ist das falsche
Wort. Geht das überhaupt mit
der 4-Tage-Woche in einem kleinen Betrieb?
Ja, bei Betrieben
unter einer gewissen Mitarbeiteranzahl gibt es ja immer
Sonderregelungen. Das kommt dann
wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil auf deinen Chef an, ob der das
mitmacht. Ja, super, aber wenn man
nicht, wenn man bei Aldi an der Karte
Kassel hockt und schickt, ja gut.
Dann hättet ihr mehr machen,
aber auch nichts gebracht, oder?
Mehr machen, wäre dann wahrscheinlich
andere Jobs suchen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man... Isle? Eisle?
Nein, ich bin für den Sub. Exzellente
Subscriptions. Sehr nice.
Neue Software-Idee.
Betriebsrat-Champ. Was du
bekommst... Ist das... Chat. Ich kenne mich
an der Arbeitsrecht-Technik nicht alles wirklich
hundertprozentig aus, aber wenn ich
Arbeitgeber bin und jemanden
einstelle und sagt,
sagen wir mal, der hat drei Monate
zum Quartalsende Kündigungsfrist und
sonst was, da kann ich den doch ganz normal
ordentlich kündigen
und muss dann halt drei Monate oder vier Monate
warten, bis er weg ist.
Es sei denn, ich habe irgendwelchen anderen Krempel in
meinen Arbeitsvertrag geschrieben oder ich habe irgendeinen
Tarifvertrag oder sonst was, wo irgendwas anderes drinne
steht. Ich kann dem doch
immer ganz normal ordentlich kündigen, da spricht
doch nichts dagegen. Und Sozialauswahl
ist was, was ich bei einem kleinen Laden
wahrscheinlich eh nicht machen muss. Und bei einer ordentlichen
Kündigung bin ich mir gar nicht sicher, ob ich das überhaupt machen muss.
Ich muss den nicht abmahnen.
Ich kann doch jemanden
ganz normal ordentlich kündigen, wenn
ich nichts anderes im Arbeitsvertrag
vereinbart habe.
Der Begründung
fällt dir immer irgendwie ein.
Einfach kündigen ohne triftigen Grund
geht nicht? Echt nicht? Kann ich nicht sagen, ey,
ich habe keinen Bock mehr auf den Typ, ich
kündige den fristgerecht ordentlich
zum... Wie, das geht nicht, das ist ja
voll von Arsch. Das glaube ich nicht,
Leute. Das geht
doch immer um irgendwelche
Kündigungen, also gerade auch auf
Reddit, wo sich die Leute immer darüber aufregen.
Da geht es doch meistens um Kündigungen, so nach
dem Motto, ab heute kommst du nicht mehr in
Betrieb und sowas in der Richtung. Aber
darum geht es ja gar nicht. Wenn
ich, wenn ich, wenn jemand,
wenn jemand, wenn
ich jemand einstelle, so.
Und ich mache mir den Vertrag und sage,
hier, ganz normale Kündigungsfrist,
drei Monate zum Quartalsende. Und
ich kündige dem drei Monate zum Quartalsende,
das heißt, ich bezahle, der arbeitet bei mir noch
vier Monate weiter, ich bezahle den noch vier Monate
und dann läuft das Ganze aus und ist fertig.
Ja? Und
da kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das nicht gehen
soll. Es mag sein, dass wenn ich in einem
riesen Konzern bin, dass es da andere Regelungen gibt,
dass es da vielleicht irgendwelche Zusatzdinger
im Vertrag gibt, irgendwelche Tarifverträge oder
whatever da rein spielen. Aber wenn ich
jemanden einstelle und sage, also,
das denke ich mir nur so, ne?
Ich habe ja da auch
keine Ahnung von.
Aber wenn ich jemanden eingestellt habe,
und den ganz normal fristgerecht kündige,
zum da, wie es im Vertrag
vereinbart wurde, kann der,
das kann der ja auch, der kann
der ja auch machen. Dann ist das doch
okay. Ja, aber du, aber
sonst wirst du die Leute doch nie los.
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr
seid, ihr seid Arbeitgeber, stellt jemand
ein, und
ähm, keine Ahnung, nach
zwei, drei Jahren oder so,
wo der da ist,
hat der aus irgendwelchen Gründen,
macht der ganz merkwürdige Sachen und geht
dir halt echt auf den Sack.
Mit was auch immer, ja? Der geht dir in irgendeiner
Art und Weise so auf den Sack, dass du dir denkst,
Alter, ich hab keinen Bock mehr auf den Typ, ja?
Ich, ich, ich hab jetzt nichts Konkretes,
dass ich den fristlos kündigen will, oder
so, oder der hat auch nichts geklaut, dass ich ihn
rausschmeiße, der geht mir einfach auf den Sack, ich hab keinen Bock
mehr auf den. Da muss ich den auch ganz normal
fristgerecht kündigen können, ohne dass ich
irgendwie da, äh,
mir ein Bein ausreißen muss.
Also da muss ich auch mal die, also wenn das
nicht der Fall ist, dann, dann könnte ich sogar
die Arbeitgeberseite verstehen, dass man sich da drüber
aufregt. Wie, es geht nicht.
Ich hab einen Arbeitsvertrag
mit dem ausgehandelt, da steht
drinnen, Kündigung kann erfolgen,
keine Ahnung, äh, Monats-, äh,
Quartalsende, drei Monate.
So, und dann, das kann der machen und
ich auch als Arbeitgeber.
Kann ich nicht, okay.
Ja, wie werde ich denn jemand
los, der mir auf den Sack geht?
Wie ist das denn in Frankfurt so?
Kenne nur die Memes, aber selbst war ich noch da.
Frankfurt, Güls,
Goethestraße, Louis Vuitton-Store,
Zahl die Kollektion bar, Fick auf Sponsor.
Kann ich dazu nur sagen.
Äh, Frankfurt ist nicht schlimm. Frankfurt ist,
manchen Straßen ist Frankfurt abartig.
Zum Beispiel, wenn du am Hauptbahnhof hier zur
Nidderstraße und sowas da lang gehst,
da würde ich aber einfach nicht lang gehen.
Ansonsten ist Frankfurt vollkommen okay.
Und am Hauptbahnhof ist es auch
okay, weil am Hauptbahnhof ist so viel
Bahnsekundin, Polizei, wie nur irgendwie geht.
Das ist nicht so wild.
Außerdem ist es eh nur das Bahnhofsviertel,
was so abartig ist. Der Rest ist okay.
Also musst du dir in Frankfurt keine Gedanken
machen, dass du irgendwie jetzt auf die
Zeile gehst, was einkaufen wirst, abgestochen oder so.
Wobei,
wobei, wobei,
man sollte
in der heutigen Zeit nichts so schnell sagen.
Letztens gab es eine Meldung
von der Polizei in Frankfurt,
dass random
auf der Parkbank
am Main eine
von hinten angemessert wurde.
Also,
ganz so easy, wie ich gesagt habe,
scheint es ja dann doch nicht zu sein.
Ja, hier, Frankfurt,
Parkbank,
Messer. Okay, da geht's.
Ja.
Genau, hier, guck mal.
Rätsel und Motiv nach unvermittelter
Messerattacke am Frankfurter
Main-Over. Einzelfall. Ja.
Ähm.
Parkbank, Park.
Hier.
Ein 19-jähriger Afghane wird
beschuldigt, einer auf einer Parkbank
sitzenden Frau am Montag
unvermittelt von hinten mit einem
Cuttermesser in Kopf und Hals gestochen zu haben.
Also, auch in Frankfurt ist es
tatsächlich gar nicht mehr so, wie ich das gerade gesagt habe.
Du musst keine Angst haben, abgestochen zu werden.
Wenn du Pech hast und bist an der
falschen Stelle und sitzt einfach nur auf einer Parkbank,
dann kannst du doch von hinten gemessert werden.
Aber nein, Frankfurt ist nicht so
schlimm, wie das teilweise gemacht wird.
Im Prinzip ist Frankfurt kein
Slum in Brasilien, wo einfach
einer mit einer AK-47 rausrennt
und random auf eine Betonwand schießt,
weil sein Fußballteam verloren hat.
Wie kann es sein, ist Messerverbot?
Moment, Moment. Da nicht. Die Messerverbotszone
ist 500 Meter weiter.
Dann wäre das natürlich nicht, da wäre das nicht passiert,
wenn das Messer verboten wäre. Ganz klar.
Ich laufe, ich laufe regelmäßig an der
Waffenverbotszone vorbei und denke mir
auch immer, boah, jetzt fühle ich mich aber
sicher. Jetzt fühle ich mich
aber sicher, weil ich in der Waffenverbotszone
bin. Stellanzeigen.
Ja. Ähm.
Heute Abend, keck, wait. Das ist das Meme.
Ich weiß, ich streame Sonntagabend.
Nee, irgendwann demnächst wieder.
Machst du bei deiner 4-Tage-
Wochenüberstunde ein bisschen ab und zu mal, ja?
Die Überstunden kommen aber meistens
daher, dass
ich in der Bereitschaft
irgendwie was gefragt werde
oder dass vielleicht am Wochenende mal
Wartungsarbeiten sind, wo ich dann sage, ja klar, mache ich mit.
Oder dass
vielleicht mal wirklich irgendeine Veranstaltung ist am
Montag, an dem ich normalerweise ja nicht arbeite.
Oder aber wirklich mal, dass
irgendwie abends noch schnell was
gemacht werden muss. Es hält sich
aber in Grenzen. Es hält sich in Grenzen.
Es ist nicht so, dass ich quasi
jede Woche 8 Überstunden
habe, weil dann
wäre das ja auch keine 4-Tage-Woche
wirklich mehr. Ich weiß,
ich weiß, die Waffenverbotszonen sind
nicht wirklich dazu da, dass die Leute keine
Waffen mehr mithaben, sondern dass die Polizei
quasi ohne Verdacht durchsuchen kann. Ja, das hab ich
auch schon gelesen. Okay, ich
hab's verstanden, dass das nicht stimmt, was ich so
dachte. Arbeitnehmer
hassen diesen Trick. Also ich
kenne das bei uns, also bei uns, beim alten
Arbeitgeber. Also die einzigen Klagen,
die ich da mitbekommen habe, was
arbeitsrechtlich vor Gericht lag,
war, weil die die Leute rausgeschmissen
haben und nicht fristgerecht gekündigt haben.
So nach dem Motto, ey, am Morgen musst du dich
hier nicht mal blicken lassen. Ja, ein
Kollege von mir, ehemaliger Kollege von mir
auf der alten Arbeit, von dem hab ich gehört, jetzt um
drei Ecken, der wurde gekündigt
wegen Fristlos, wegen
Arbeitszeitbetrug.
Und ich hab da Dinger gehört,
wo ich sagen würde, ey,
die waren vielleicht doch nicht so
clever.
So nach dem Motto,
morgens, morgens eingestochen
und dann mit der Bahn
heimgefahren und sowas. Also,
ergeblich, ich weiß nicht, ob das stimmt, by the way.
Alles, alles nur
irgendwie um fünf Ecken, also wahrscheinlich stimmt das
nicht mal. Ja.
Und der wurde fristlos
wegen Arbeitszeitbetrug gekündigt
und die haben sich auch vor Gericht
wieder getroffen und er hat Recht bekommen.
Das war nicht gerechtfertigt,
die fristlose Kündigung und er
kriegt jetzt eine fristgerechte Kündigung und irgendwie
eine Abfindung dabei. Ja gut, auf
Reddit, auf Reddit wird auch viel Scheiße
erzählt, ja. Auf Reddit ist ja auch immer
so, oh, irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
ich hab Probleme mit dem Chef. Reddit
Antwort ist, morgen
zum Chef ins Büro gehen, auf den Tisch kacken und
kündigen, so. Das ist die Reddit-Antwort.
Das kannst du eh vergessen.
Diese Ratschläge von Reddit
immer richtig
da kann ja gar nichts passieren. Das ist
per Definition
unmöglich, dass in der Waffenverbotstour
jemand Waffen mitnimmt.
Das ist binary.
Sobald du quasi die Grenze überschreitest,
wo das Schild ist, despawned
deine Waffe, instant.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist gering, das stimmt.
Starship-Start, erstmal wieder
soweit.
Stimmt, hab ich gehört, das bringt irgendwelche
ESA-Sachen ins Weltall, ne?
Was sind eure Erfahrungen mit der IT mit einem Firmenwirt?
Da kann ich nichts zu sagen, hatte ich noch nie.
Keine Ahnung. Ich weiß auch nicht, wie das
bei uns, da wo ich gerade arbeite,
gehandelt wird. Hab ich mir noch nie gedacht. Wollte ich
auch noch nie. Ihr wisst, ich fahr eh nicht
gerne Auto. Und wenn, dann mit
meinem Fiat 500e.
Ich weiß nicht, was da gelaufen ist, aber es könnte
vielleicht sowas gewesen
sein. Aber wie gesagt, ich weiß es nicht. Alles Vermutungen.
Kleine Frage, wie gut stehen
die Chancen, dass Linux
auf einem beliebigen
neuen Windows-Laptop gut funktioniert?
MacOS fängt eben an,
mich zu nerven.
Warum ist Windows vor allem keine Option?
Ich benutze das nur. Guck hier,
da. Windows, Linux.
Aber gut, wenn du nicht willst.
Also, die Chancen sind in der Tat relativ
gut, dass das funktioniert.
Beim alten Arbeitgeber
hatte ich ein Surface Book.
Das ist der Inbegriff von Microsoft
und Windows Notebook, diese Dinger.
Und darauf hatte ich auch
ein Ubuntu laufen. Und das ging.
Hatte ein paar kleine Probleme,
die Tastatur wurde
zum Beispiel, die Notebook-Tastatur
wurde zum Beispiel im Boot-Prozess
nicht erkannt. Das heißt, ich konnte mein Passwort
für die Festplattenverschlüsselung nicht
am Notebook eintippen.
Aber mit einer externen Tastatur geht's.
Aber mit jedem
anderen Notebook, würde ich sagen, stehen deine Chancen
eigentlich relativ gut. Wenn du
advancede Sachen haben willst, wie so beispielsweise
externe
GPUs und sowas,
das könnte ein bisschen problematisch sein.
Aber mit den Basic-Sachen,
hast du, glaube ich, ganz gute Chancen.
Wo du
ein bisschen den Gedanken machen musst,
ist, wenn du es viel mobil verwenden willst,
weil oftmals ist der Stromverbrauch, je nachdem was
der Linux-Kernel an Hardware
da drin supportet und Energiesparoptionen
und sonstige Geschichten, ist der Stromverbrauch
vielleicht ein bisschen höher.
Aber wenn du den Laptop quasi nur
als Desktop-Ersatz verwendest,
ist das in der Regel kein Problem.
Das ist nur vorgeschoben.
Das halte ich für nur vorgeschoben,
weil, wenn du das
1000 Leute hast, die Homeoffice machen,
dass da mal ein paar Leute,
eine Handvoll Leute drunter sind,
die das System irgendwie ausnutzen, missbrauchen,
ist eigentlich
egal, was du hast, immer so.
Aber wenn es gut funktioniert,
ist es dumm,
das dann für 995 abzuschaffen,
weil 5 Leute es irgendwie
verkacken.
Das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Das ist einfach nur vorgeschoben.
Das heißt, man möchte das eh nicht haben,
weil man die Leute nicht richtig kontrollieren kann,
weil man sich da einbildet
und schiebt das jetzt vor.
Das liegt nicht daran.
Das ist vorgeschoben und die wollten das
die ganze Zeit schon nicht haben.
Also, es ist ja übrigens auch nicht Homeoffice,
es ist mobiles Arbeiten.
Das ist, weil Homeoffice jetzt heißt,
rechtlich hat andere Anforderungen
wie mobiles Arbeiten.
Also ich bin sehr froh,
wie das bei mir gehandelt wird.
Es läuft aber auch alles gut.
Das läuft richtig, richtig nice, muss man sagen.
Sowohl quasi on-prem
als auch in der Cloud.
Egal, ob man daheim ist oder im Laden.
Zusammenhalt übergreifen, Team übergreifen,
Projekt übergreifen läuft gut.
Kommunikation mit dem Chef läuft gut.
Die Arbeit wird viel schneller erledigt,
als wenn die Leute jeden Tag ins Büro und zurückfahren müssen.
Und die Leute sind viel eher bereit,
auch abends nochmal an irgendeinem Meeting teilzunehmen
oder sowas.
Wie dieser eine Kot-YouTuber von früher.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen.
Ich bin Wobblors, Mann.
Oder soll ich sagen, Hallo Jungs und Mädels.
Wobei ich das auf YouTube ja auch schon gar nicht mehr sage.
Jo.
Also ich bin da wirklich froh.
Die Leute nehmen dann auch, wie das läuft.
Die Leute sind dann auch öfters mal gewillt,
abends an einem Meeting teilzunehmen.
Zum Beispiel kommt öfters vor,
an den Tagen, wo ich nach Frankfurt fahre,
dass ich zurückfahre
und es ist noch irgendwelches Gemiete.
Also ich hab dann die Chance,
zurückzufahren um 14 oder 15 Uhr
oder ewig da hocken zu bleiben,
was dann teilweise gar nicht passt mehr.
Weil du dann Rufbereitschaft hast ab 18 Uhr oder sowas.
Und ich bin wirklich froh,
dass wir das so handhaben können,
dass ich sage, okay, keine Ahnung,
14 Uhr, 15 Uhr, ich fahre heim
und wenn ich dann, sagen wir mal,
14.30 Uhr noch irgendwas ist,
Gruppenrunde, Projektmeeting oder sonst was,
dann setze ich mir einfach mein Kopfhörer auf
oder besser gesagt mein Headset auf
und nehme da remote auf der Heimfahrt dran teil.
Weil ganz ehrlich,
was kann ich denn
bei so einem, äh,
bei so einer Laberrunde,
was die meisten Meetings sind,
was kann ich denn mehr dazu beitragen,
wenn ich im Büro sitze am Notebook,
als wenn ich, gerade wenn es um Gruppenrunde geht
oder irgendwelches Projekt-Sure-Fix,
was machen wir die nächsten zwei Wochen
oder sonstige Dinge
oder irgendwelche Sprintplanungen,
da brauchst du nicht dein Notebook.
Und selbst das hätte ich ja im Zug dabei
oder irgendwo dabei,
wenn ich irgendwas wirklich Strengendes zeigen muss.
Was könnte ich mehr dazu beitragen,
wenn ich in Frankfurt beim Arbeitgeber im Büro sitze,
vorm Rechner,
als wenn ich gerade im Zug sitze.
Zu 90% labern da eh alle durcheinander
und andere Leute
und die 5%, wo ich was sagen muss,
das ist nix, was irgendwie einen Unterschied macht,
ob ich das von daheim aus sage, im Zug sage,
auf dem Weg heim sage
oder wenn ich im Büro sitze sage.
Ja.
Deswegen ist das super.
Ich stech ein morgens dann,
stech dann aus, 15 Uhr oder 14.30 Uhr,
je nachdem wann ich heimgehe,
stech aus und wenn ich dann
an irgendeinem Meeting teilnehmen muss,
45 Minuten, buche ich einfach bei uns
über die Zeiterfassungs-App,
wenn das Meeting losgeht,
buche ich einfach nochmal mobile Arbeiten startet
und wenn das Meeting fertig ist, sage ich einfach
mobile Arbeit Ende. So, fertig.
Das ist super, dass das so dynamisch flexibel gehandhabt ist
und bei uns funktioniert das wunderbar.
Und im Endeffekt bin ich mir sehr sicher,
dass unterm Strich,
dass sowohl für mich,
aber vor allem auch für die Firma
oder für das Unternehmen unterm Strich
mehr Vorteile als Nachteile hat.
Bin ich mir sehr sicher.
Du kriegst einfach viel mehr geschafft
und die Leute sind sogar noch mehr bereit,
auch mal außer der Reihe was zu machen.
Das ist einfach nur von Vorteil.
Ich sage nicht, dass es in jedem Beruf
und dass es bei allen funktioniert,
aber gerade in der IT ist das was,
da hat es aus meiner Sicht nur Vorteile.
Ja, doch, ich hab Hunger.
Weiß ich nicht, also die Onboard-Tastatur ging nicht,
meine USB-Tastatur ging.
Beim Surface Book.
Naja, du kannst ja bei Ubuntu immer,
dass immer ein halbwegs aktuelles,
ich meine die releasen zweimal im Jahr.
Und selbst wenn du die aktuellste LTS verwendest,
die ist auch von April 2024.
Aber du hast Recht,
wenn du jetzt, keine Ahnung,
wenn du jetzt Ubuntu 22.04 installieren müsstest
auf einem ganz neuen Notebook,
da könnte es vielleicht die ein oder anderen Sachen geben.
Also ich gehe davon aus,
dass du mit dem Notebook,
wenn du nur noch 15 Notebook,
wahrscheinlich wenig Probleme hast.
Aber, weißt du was das Beste ist?
Du musst ja nicht gleich Linux drauf installieren.
Boote doch einfach mal eine Live-CD,
äh Live-CD, Live-Image.
Boote einfach mal ein Live-Image
und guck mal, ob alles funktioniert.
Ja, vom Tio habe ich auch schon ewig nichts mehr gehört.
Ne, self-owned meinst du nicht.
Ja.
Was mich bei der U-Bahn nervt,
sind meistens die Leute.
Da hocken in Frankfurt oftmals so,
ja wahrscheinlich sind das welche,
die euch schon vorstellen, wie die ausschauen.
Die mit, äh,
die schauen genau so aus, wie ihr euch denkt, dass sie ausschauen,
wenn ich euch das jetzt erzähle.
Die dann irgendwie in der Gruppe hocken,
mit vier, fünf Leuten und dort irgendwelche
Gangster-Rap-Sachen
laut auf ihrem Handy aufhaben.
Die gehen mir richtig auf den Sack.
Ich glaube, so nennt man das heute, ja.
Ich hab mal einen von denen
angeschwätzt, ja.
Kostet natürlich immer ein bisschen Überwindung.
Hab ich auch gefragt, soll ich mir das jetzt
die ganze Zeit anhören, muss ich mir das jetzt die ganze Zeit anhören?
Und
da meinte der drauf, bis jetzt hat sich
noch keiner beschwert.
Das war seine Rechtfertigung dafür.
Hab ich halt auch nur gemeint, ja jetzt ist es soweit,
jetzt beschwert sich einer.
Es hat sich bis jetzt noch keiner beschwert.
Also der, der ist wahrscheinlich
wirklich ernsthaft davon ausgegangen,
dass das der, die restliche U-Bahn feiert,
wenn da,
ich weiß nicht, was da lief. Es lief definitiv nicht
Haftbefehl oder sowas.
Machst du noch Gaming? Klar.
MMO, du meinst Dark Age of Camelot.
Also Dark habe ich jetzt tatsächlich
ein paar Monate schon nicht mehr gespielt.
Aber bei mir lässt das immer mal ein bisschen nach.
Also spätestens, also
sollten die eine neue Season starten, Ende des Jahres,
bin ich definitiv tausendprozentig dabei.
Und sollten sie keine neue Season starten,
werde ich wahrscheinlich spätestens im Dezember
wieder anfangen zu spielen, weil dann hab ich, oder
sagen wir mal so, spätestens Mitte November wieder anfangen
zu spielen, weil da hab ich genug Zeit.
Das stimmt, stimmt, stimmt.
Ja.
Hätte auch sagen können, ich fiege deine Mutter
oder sowas.
Das wäre auch eine Option gewesen.
Ja, ob das was wird, weiß ich nicht, weil
du brauchst ja auch eine gewisse
Spieleranzahl und
ich glaube, Dark hat keine,
hat nicht genug Spieler
für zwei aktive Free Shards.
Also entweder wird Atlas
einfach dead sein bei Release
und die machen dann eine neue Season
oder die Leute lassen das andere links liegen.
Ich glaube, so richtig
aufsplitten wird sich das nicht.
Ich meine, du hast ein paar tausend Leute
vielleicht, die aktuell noch Dark spielen wollen.
Also aktuell ist die Spieleranzahl wohl
gar nicht so schlecht, leider sieht man die
Spieleranzahl nicht mal richtig.
Aber es gab erst letztens wieder ein Event,
wo ich ein paar Screenshots gesehen hab
und da war richtig was los.
Welches iPhone benutzt du?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich hab ein...
Wo sieht man das?
Sieht man das in den System-Settings irgendwie?
Wo ist denn das?
General?
About.
iPhone. iPhone 14 Pro.
Und das ist
voll und ganz schnell genug,
top genug
von der Batterie und alles.
Ich werde mir die nächsten Jahre kein neues iPhone kaufen.
Erst wenn es keine Updates mehr gibt.
Das wird noch ein bisschen dauern.
Bereust du es manchmal, dass du
mit deinem YouTube-Kanal nicht... Nein.
Nein. Nein.
Ich kann mir das gar nicht vorstellen,
mich als Vollzeit-Influencer.
Da habe ich viel zu große Motivationsschwankungen,
was Influencer-Dasein angeht.
Und außerdem,
was ich am liebsten mache, ist Technikkram und Gebastel.
Das ist nichts, was ich auf YouTube machen könnte.
Nee.
Gar nicht.
Ich bereue vielleicht manchmal,
so faul zu sein
und nicht
mehr Sellout zu machen.
Weil auch mit wenig Content...
Es ist ja nicht so,
als dass meine Videos wenig geguckt werden.
Das kann man ja nicht sagen.
Die werden ja auch ordentlich geguckt.
Ähm.
Ich bereue manchmal nicht genug Sellout zu machen.
Weil man auch mit wenig Videos,
aber brauchbaren Aufrufen,
doch nice, easy money machen kann.
Mit ein bisschen Sellout.
Aber so ist es halt.
Dafür bleibt mir
vor blöden Werbeeinblendungen verschont.
Selbst da hätte ich keinen Bock drauf.
Ich bin einfach zu...
Ich habe einfach zu große Motivationsschwankungen,
was diese Influencer und YouTube
und Content-Creation Sache angeht.
Was hast du jetzt eigentlich für einen SIM-Vertrag?
Ich bin dumm.
Ich habe einen bei O2 gemacht,
weil es da extra SIM-Karten kostenlos
dazu gibt. Das heißt, ich dachte mir,
da kann ich ins Tablet noch einen reinmachen
und ins zweite Handy noch einen reinmachen.
Allerdings hat das O2 nicht geschissen bekommen,
meine Rufnummer zu portieren.
Die haben es einfach nicht...
Die haben es einfach irgendwie nicht hinbekommen.
Also nee, Moment, sorry, das stimmt nicht.
O2 hat es nicht hinbekommen,
ich habe nicht einschalten können,
was ich bräuchte, um die Rufnummer zu portieren.
Die haben glaube ich 14 Tage oder 3 Wochen gebraucht,
bis ich mich in meinem...
ja, wie heißt denn das?
Profil einloggen konnte.
Ich habe die auch hart geflamed auf Twitter und alles.
Die haben ewig gebraucht dafür.
Und nachdem es damals zeitlich ziemlich knapp war,
mit der Rufnummerportierung,
weil ich wollte ja die Rufnummer,
die ich auf meinem Diensthandy
beim alten Arbeitgeber hatte,
mitnehmen zu meinem privaten Handy.
Da musste ich meine Rufnummerportierung machen.
Dann habe ich gesagt, okay,
O2 bekommt es nicht geschissen.
Dann bin ich in Aldi gegangen
und habe mir ein Aldi Talk SIM-Kartenpaket geholt.
Und Aldi hat den Umzug innerhalb von 2 Tagen
hingekriegt von der Rufnummer.
Und jetzt habe ich einfach
das billigste Aldi Talk Paket.
Und das reicht.
Und ich bin richtig, richtig dumm.
Ich habe den O2-Vertrag
immer noch nicht gekündigt.
Da bezahle ich irgendwie
30 Euro im Monat dafür
und ich benutze ihn nicht.
Ich glaube, ich sollte das jetzt mal direkt
nach dem Stream machen, Alter.
Richtig hängen geblieben.
Seit 1,5 Jahren.
Ne, seit...
Ja.
Seit 1,5 Jahren.
Also sagen wir einfach mal,
20 Monate
waren 30 Euro, 600 Euro.
Einfach, einfach ohne jegliche
Gegenleistung O2 600 Euro
in Rachen geschmissen.
Passive Ausgaben.
Ja, werde ich, werde ich.
Du wirst es nicht glauben,
sogar der Friseur hat schon geschrieben
in Discord, wie es mit Black Ops 6 aussieht.
Zumindest mal angucken werde ich es mir.
Manscaped, die haben mich auch schon
angeschrieben.
Mich hat so gut wie jeder der 0815
Werbungstypen, die ihr da immer
seht, schon angeschrieben.
Raid, Shadow Legends, VPN, XY, Manscaped.
Alle waren die schon am...
Holy war auch schon am Start.
VPN-Werbung.
Ich wollte mal für NordVPN Werbung machen.
Ich war mir mit NordVPN
auch schon einig.
Und danach hat NordVPN mal auf
meinen Kanal geguckt.
Und hat dieses Video hier
gefunden.
Die Lügen der VPN-Anbieter.
Und das haben die gesehen.
Und haben gesagt, Max, damit wir
bei dir Werbung schalten, musst du dieses Video löschen.
Dann habe ich gesagt, NordVPN,
dann schalte ich eben keine Werbung.
Es gibt schon... Ja, die machen
manchmal, gerade wenn die, wenn die
zum ersten Mal
mit jemandem was machen, dann...
Also die Sponsoren machen das nicht.
Das macht dann irgendeine Werbeagentur.
Die scannt mal kurz so über den Channel drüber.
Und gibt mal VPN ein und guckt, was der
schon so erzählt hat und sowas.
Ja, das machen manche. Dann wollten sie nicht mehr.
Verständlicherweise.
Aber ich wollte auch nicht.
Das ist... Wisst ihr, was auch der Shit ist?
Wisst ihr, was auch
richtig gut geht?
Satisfying Teppichreinigungsvideos.
Kriegt ihr die auch manchmal?
So nach dem Motto,
150 Jahre alter,
ähm, keine Ahnung,
persischer Teppich,
seit einem Jahrhundert ungereinigt,
wird dann sauber gemacht.
Und sowas.
Und ich denke mir jedes Mal,
wenn ich das Thumbnail von diesem Video angucke,
die Typen haben einfach,
kurz vor dem, keine Ahnung,
eine Woche vor dem Video,
haben die diesen Teppich einfach mal komplett
ultra durch den Schlamm gezogen.
Um ihn dann sauber machen zu können.
Das Ding ist weder 150 Jahre alt,
noch ein halbes Jahrhundert,
Jahrhundert nicht gereinigt.
Haben wir eben mit meinem Sohn,
meinem alten N64, ausgepackt.
Nice. Oh. Sadge.
Der hat sich aber nicht so gefreut wie...
Wo ist denn...
Nintendo 64, Junge?
Der hat sich aber nicht so gefreut wie der, oder?
Kennt ihr das?
Nintendo 64!
Der ist komplett am Ausschreiten.
Der ist komplett am Ausflippen.
Nintendo 64.
Ich glaube, ganz so krass wird es nicht gewesen sein
in der heutigen Zeit.
Was muss man Kindern heutzutage
zu Weihnachten schenken,
als Eltern,
dass die so ausflippen?
Was ist denn heute?
Ich glaube, mit der Playstation 5 löst du heute
solche Reaktionen nicht mehr aus.
Nee.
Was musst du als Eltern deinen Kindern schenken?
Eine 4090 vielleicht?
Eine PS5 Pro?
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich habe keine Kinder. Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe mir da noch keine Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Aber ich frage mich gerade so,
was müsste ich meinen Kindern schenken,
dass die so ausflippen wie der Nintendo 64, Junge?
500er Subbombe bei Trimax.
Vielleicht, ja.
Patrick, ich glaube, es ist echt so.
Ich glaube, heute ist wegen sowas einfacher
mehr an Frühstücken.
Keiner mehr so happy und rastet so aus.
Du müsstest denen wahrscheinlich
heute einen YouTube-Channel
mit 500.000 Subs schenken.
Wobei, das ist halt komplett bescheuert.
Bringt ja gar nichts.
Will ja keiner dann sehen.
Da fällt mir nichts ein,
was du denen heute schenken könntest,
dass die so ausrasten.
Was hat man heute eigentlich
für Jogginganzüge an?
Früher hatte man
so eine Adidas-Hose an.
So eine Adidas-Jogginghose
oder so eine Adidas-Sporthose.
Da drüber irgendwie so
diese ganz dünnen
Sportjacken.
Diese ganz dünnen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
wie diese Dinger heißen.
Save immer noch Adidas.
Früher war halt diese Adidas-Sporthose,
diese mit den Knöpfen,
war früher komplett angesagt.
So.
Knöpfe.
Ja.
Diese Dinger waren früher mega angesagt.
Das, was damals schnell war,
weil Fickerhose genannt wurde.
Aus welchen Gründen auch immer.
Das war da voll der Trend.
Das hatte jeder.
Jeder wollte so eine Adidas-Hose
mit Knöpfen haben.
Ich habe übrigens auch manchmal,
fällt mir auf, so den passenden Assi-Look
für letzte Reihe im Bus in letzter Zeit.
Weil ich habe, seitdem ich
regelmäßig rennen gehe,
habe ich auch für die kältere Jahreszeit
habe ich so eine Funktion,
so ein paar Funktionsklamotten.
Also quasi eine lange Jogginghose
und so ein
langes
Reißverschluss vorne.
So eine Funktionsjacke,
wo man halt, wenn man schwitzt,
dass es dann halt nach außen geht.
Wo der Wasserdampf von innen
nach außen durchkommt.
Das sieht schon, das ist dann auch noch blau.
So wie die vielen Sachen früher auch.
Das hat dann schon so ein bisschen den,
den ich setze im Bus oder in der S-Bahn
und habe so diesen Assi-Look, ja.
Nur mit dem Unterschied, ich setze damit halt nicht
im Bus und in der S-Bahn, sondern ich renne damit rum.
By the way, rumrennen ist ein guter
Stichwort, Leute. Ich gehe jetzt
auf was futtern.
Nach dem Essen ruhe ich mich kurz
aus und dann gehe ich 14 Kilometer
rennen.
Es wird anstrengend. Je nach Runde
sind es vielleicht auch nur 12 oder 13.
Aber genug.
Lang genug.
Nicht Nudeln mit Lachs.
Es sind
Spaghetti Bolognese.
Ich muss mal kurz Wetter gucken.
Wetter in Hanau. Ah, hey, heute ist
ja ganz gutes Wetter.
Kein Regen.
Nix. Bisschen wolkig
wird es später, aber das juckt mich nicht.
Solange es nicht regnet.
Diablo 4. Warum Diablo 4 sollte? Gibt es eine neue Season?
Also wenn ich ein Diablo spielen würde,
dann ist es nur Diablo 2.
Mal wieder ein Diablo 2
Season Grind. Hätte ich echt Bock drauf.
Oder einen neuen Path of Exile Season Grind.
Aber ich habe keine Zeit,
gerade. Welche Klasse?
Du meinst, wo ich Diablo 2...
Wenn ich einen neuen...
Wenn ich eine neue...
Diablo 2 Season...
Wahrscheinlich
würde ich
Easy Mode machen.
Und wahrscheinlich
starten mit einer Sorc
für Easy
MF Runs und dann mit
einem Smite Pala
für weitere
Gear Runs.
Wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich erst Sorc und dann
Smite Pala. Falls das noch das Meta ist.
Ich habe jetzt ein paar Season
Diablo 2 nicht mehr reingeguckt.
Die patchen da ja auch öfters mal dran rum.
Zumindest würde ich
nicht irgendwie mit einem
Nahkampf-Barb oder so anfangen, weil das
doch als Season Start etwas zu...
Melee bist du eh doppelt...
Bist du eh in Diablo 2
mehrfach bestraft.
Also ich glaube, entweder
wenn ich wirklich Braindead spielen will,
dann Summer Necro, aber das ist so lahm.
Wahrscheinlich würde ich als erstes
mit einer Sorc anfangen.
Erstmal jede Menge MF Runs machen
und dann später für Endgame
Farming einen Pala
und die Sorc weiter gieren.
Dann hat man eigentlich alles,
was man braucht. Vielleicht bin ich
auch nicht mehr im aktuellen Diablo 2 Meta drin
und stimmt nicht, was ich sage. Da müsste ich mich mal schlau
machen, bevor eine neue Season startet.
Ich glaube, im August ist erst eine neue Season gestartet.
Wenn Season 9 startet, dauert glaube ich noch
eine ganze Weile.
Season 8 ist glaube ich im August
irgendwann gestartet. PoE?
Moment, PoE? Season Start? Hatte die
nicht erst... Hatte PoE
nicht erst noch eine
Season...
Die...
Wie sieht es eigentlich mit Path of Exile 2 aus?
Läuft
die Season nicht schon drei Monate oder so?
Ach, keine Ahnung. Egal, Leute.
Ich gehe jetzt was futtern.
Wir sehen uns. Bis
dann. Macht's gut.